Hallo Stefan. Noch wach? Ich bin noch wach und ich schreibe diese Frage relativ häufig spät abends.
Sehr gut. Ich habe mir auch ein paar Sachen abgeguckt. Stuckrad-Barres, ich weiß nicht genau, hat er die SMS verkürzt oder wurden die so geschrieben, aber Körper-an-Körper-jetzt, noch wach.
Fandest du eigentlich gut?
Habe ich alle in meinem Repertoire aufgenommen mit. Allerdings nicht an 1000 verschiedene Frauen, sondern nur an eine. Ich kann mich da reglementieren.
Ja und noch wach schreibe ich an sehr verschiedene Leute, aber ohne Hintergedanke, sondern einfach will ich wissen, ob sie noch wach sind, weil ich sehr gerne später abends telefoniere und dann kommt schon mal diese Nachricht von mir. Aber es ist doch ein anderes Verhältnis als das, was im Roman beschrieben wird. Nun will ich dir als erstes hier ein Foto zeigen und du beschreibst jetzt mal, was man darauf sehen kann.
Luisa Neubauer und Julian Reichelt stehen vor einer Wand und lassen sich fotografieren, fast Hand in Hand.
Fast Hand in Hand, also das muss man dazu sagen, nicht in Hand in Hand. Dieses Foto, man findet es leicht, wenn man die beiden Namen zusammen eingibt bei Google, ist entstanden 2019. Damals hat Luisa Neubauer im Axel Springer Haus den Place-to-be-Award erhalten, aus den Händen von Julian Reichelt, der zugleich auch noch die Laudatio auf sie hielt. Und da frage ich mich schon, es war ja 2019 nicht so, dass man Julian Reichelt mit sagen, wie er Georg Restle verwechseln konnte oder so, sondern es war ja schon ganz klar, wofür dieser Mann steht. Wenngleich wir dann irgendwelche Enthüllungen jetzt da haben, und wir werden uns ja jetzt auch nicht da eingehen mit befassen, aber warum tut man das? Man wusste schon vorher, wie Springer ist im Ganzen und man wusste, wie die Bildzeitung im Speziellen ist. Und Reichelt konnte man schon sehr gut kennen. Und dann lässt man sich nicht einen Award geben und geht dann eine Weile später auf eine Veranstaltung von Stuckrad-Barre und sagt, ja, das ist aber auch alles super getroffen. Das finde ich verlogen.
Ist es auch. Und meinem, also ich weiß nicht, man wächst ja immer so rein in so politische Haltung, aber ich finde, seit der Geschichte um Charlotte Roche ist die Bildzeitung gestorben für mich. Also da weise ich, da gebe ich niemals Geld für aus. Da nehme ich keine Einladung an. Ich bin mit Redaktionsschluss zu Ken Jepsen in den Keller gegangen, um mich zwei Stunden befragen zu dürfen.
Das wirst du aber heute auch nicht mehr machen.
Heute würde ich es auch nicht mehr machen. Das war sogar noch vor der Wahl von Trump. Also es war andere Zeiten. Aber schon damals hätte ich niemals auf eine Anfrage vom Bild reagiert. Die haben mich jetzt drei oder viermal eingeladen in ihre komische Bild-TV. Auch schon wieder abgewickelte. Der entscheidende Punkt, oder wie das heißt. Nee, das ist die Zeitung. Wie heißt das bei denen?
Meinung nach acht oder so etwas.
Also fünf Leute und jeder bringt drei Minuten Meinung mit oder so was. Und ich reagiere nicht mal drauf. Das steht völlig außer Frage. Wenn die kommen mit, wir geben ihnen ein Award, nimmt man den nicht an. Das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ich finde das ganz fürchterlich. Und ich spreche auch generell nicht mit Springer, also auch nicht mit anderen Springer-Zeitungen. Ich zucke da jetzt nicht gleich den Revolver bei mir. Der schreibt für Springer, du würdest mit der Welt reden. Ich würde nicht mit Springer-Presse im Allgemeinen sprechen. Hin und wieder lese ich Teile aus der Springer-Presse natürlich. Und ich möchte das jedenfalls nicht unterstützen, dieses ganze System Springer. Und deswegen mache ich das nicht und halte mich dann raus. Und ich finde es wirklich sehr, sehr merkwürdig, wie jetzt gerade einige zu merken scheinen. Oh, da habe ich wohl doch eine Weile aufs falsche Pferd gesetzt. Jetzt einmal mal schnell noch so einen Aufruf mitmachen für das Stuckrad-Barre-Buch. Wen ich dort auch fand, war Ronja von Rönne, die ja wodurch eigentlich berühmt geworden ist. Das war 2015. Ich vergesse ja leider nichts. Das ist Fluch und Segen zugleich. Das war 2015, nämlich mit einem Artikel, der in der Welt abgedruckt war, also in einer Springer-Zeitung. Und dieser Artikel hatte folgende Überschrift, warum mich der Feminismus anekelt. Und in diesem Text, den ich mir jetzt nochmal vorgenommen habe, ist etwas zu lesen. Also man muss sich jetzt vorstellen, Ronja von Rönne macht jetzt Werbung für ein Buch, das als Schlüsselroman verstanden werden kann, soll zum Thema Springer, Macht, Missbrauch, Frauen, Me Too etc. Und in dieser Kolumne steht, ich habe einfach selbst noch nie erlebt, dass Frau seiner Nachteil ist. In einem Land, in dem der mächtigste Mensch eine Vagina hat, wird Frauenquote für mich immer ein bisschen nach Vorteilsbeschaffung riechen. Das Gendern der Sprache finde ich ausgesprochen hässlich. Wenn Firmen ihre Produkte mit nackten Frauen bewerben, halte ich das für gerechtfertigt. Offensichtlich gibt es ja den Markt dazu. Ich finde den Hashtag Aufschrei albern. Das Bild vom bösen Chef, der seine Sekretärin lieber ein bisschen ankrabbelt als befördert, erscheint mir fremd wie eine Welt, die ich nur aus L'Oréal-Sketchern kenne. Ich glaube, das muss man nicht mehr weiter kommentieren. Vielleicht sollte sie wirklich mal das Buch von Stuckrad-Barre lesen, um so eine Kolumne dann nicht mehr zu schreiben.
Es ist also weniger ein Schlüsselroman als ein Schlussstrich-Roman, insbesondere für den Autor selbst. Also es geht ja nicht nur für alle Protagonisten, die du jetzt, sondern Stuckrad-Barre selbst.
Stuckrad-Barre, wir müssen das hier mal sagen. Man hört Zahlen, man hört Gerüchte. Ich höre Zahlen davon, dass Stuckrad-Barre knapp zehn Jahre einen Vertrag bei Springer hatte, wo ich sagen würde, der würde für uns beide reichen und wir könnten wie die Maden im Speck leben. So etwas hört man. Es gibt da verschiedene Sachen. Man kann da auch einiges ergoogeln. Wir wollen uns hier natürlich rechtlich sauber halten. Ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, man kann festhalten, Stuckrad-Barre hat in einem ungewöhnlichen Maße vom Springer-Konzern profitiert und hat auch dieses System mit seiner Prominenz gestützt und ihm Glanz verliehen.
Er geht so ein bisschen drauf ein, für den Freund, auf dem wir noch zu sprechen kommen, gearbeitet zu haben, und zwar mehr für ihn als für das Haus. Er will ja das Haus auch nie so richtig betreten haben.
So eine Summe denke ich auch über Freundschaft noch mal ganz anders.
Genau. Und im Spiegel macht er sich ja darüber nachträglich lustig. Und da würde ich auch sagen, ja, das ist der blinde Fleck, den er bewusst nicht noch mal bespielt, dass er die Frage bekommt, ja, sie haben ja auch damals für, in dem Falle sage ich jetzt mal Döpfner gearbeitet, die Legenden reichen von 4 bis 40.000 im Monat. Also das ist dann schon ein Chefredakteursgehalt oder so ein Herausgebergehalt, das man da bekommt für drei Texte im Monat. Und dann sagte er nur, manchmal waren es auch vier. Und das zeigt schon, ah ja, also er kennt dieses Privileg und weiß, dass man damit auch locker hätte aussorgen können. Also es hätte gar keine weiteren Arbeit bedurft.
Er wohnt ja offenbar immer wieder monatelang im Château Maman. Da habe ich jetzt mal nachgeschaut, weil das so ganz hübsch beschrieben war. Da gibt es nichts unter 1000 Euro die Nacht.
Genau. Und die große Frage, die sich dann stellt, ist, kann man diese eine Art von Abhängigkeit, die ihrerseits auch mal so eines Romanes würdig wäre, jetzt aufwiegend vergleichen, muss man es in Beziehung setzen, zu dem Thema von Abhängigkeiten, dem er sich nun gewidmet hat?
Nun, ich glaube, dass das Problem nicht ist, dass er sich dem Thema widmet und sich sein Thema jetzt nicht vornimmt. Also, dass er diese Abhängigkeit beschreibt und warum man eigentlich in so eine Abhängigkeit tritt und warum man für diese Zeitung arbeitet. Ich würde unterstellen, dass er gar kein Problem mit der eigentlichen Haltung dieser Zeitung hat, sondern nur ein spezielles Problem mit dem Umgang mit Frauen und mit dem Umgang des Chefredakteurs mit Frauen. Dass er aber nicht jemand ist, der auf irgendeiner Seite, das ist mir zumindest nicht aufgefallen, groß anprangert, wie zum Beispiel Springer natürlich Kapitalinteressen durchsetzt, wo es nur geht. Also, das ist ja nicht sein Punkt. Er ist ja ein Popliterat, der immer eigentlich auf dem Fun-Sektor unterwegs war und der Gesellschaftskritik geradezu verächtlich behandelt hat, weil er genau diese Politisierung der Debatte ja nicht mehr möchte, sondern eigentlich nur noch Fun haben. Oder man macht eben diese Individualisierung, die man ja bei ihm erleben kann, dass man persönliches Leiden, Drogenabhängigkeit, Alkoholabhängigkeit, Depressionen, Magersucht, was weiß ich, ausschlachtet, um jedes Mal wieder ein neues Buch daraus zu generieren. Also das, was heute jetzt jeder Influencer macht. Ich empfehle da sehr den Film Sick of Myself. Das ist eigentlich das Stuckrad-Barres-System, dann nochmal als Film sichtbar. Und da, glaube ich, hätte man sagen können und das wäre jetzt, wir wollten noch, naja, also das wäre meine erste These, dass er diese Frauengeschichte erzählt, das aber verquickt mit seiner eigenen Geschichte und aber bei der eigenen Geschichte die ganzen blinden Flecken da lässt und dies nicht beleuchtet bzw. er hätte dann sich nur mit den Frauengeschichten beschäftigen können. Er hätte ja auch eine weibliche Erzählerin kreieren können, das heißt, er hätte sich ja viel stärker, der ich erzähle, hätte sich viel stärker vom Autor ich lösen können. Denn dass wir das laufend zusammen denken müssen, liegt in der Natur eines Romans, der stark auf Schlüsselromanen angelegt ist und der ja auch Wendungen, Sätze verwendet, die wir aus anderen Kontexten kennen, nämlich dieses noch wach, ist ja etwas, was wir zum Beispiel dann auch im Boys Club Podcast hören, zum Beispiel auch in den Zeitrecherchen oder Spiegelrecherchen lesen können.
Also das finde ich jetzt wahnsinnig interessant, weil meine Lesart ist ganz konträr anders von diesem Buch und seiner Anlage. Für mich sind das hier zwei Geschichten, die ganz bewusst parallel laufen und nicht durch Zufall irgendwie verquickt sind oder so. Sondern wir haben den Chefredakteur und die Sophia, die einen Namen bekommen, stellvertretend für sehr viel andere. Er beschreibt es ja nicht, diese Einszene. Sehr viele, die auch unter dem Chefredakteur gelitten haben, dieses Fernsehsenders, begegnen ihm in einer Videokonferenz und es sind so viele Kacheln, dass er die gar nicht auf einem Bildschirm und plötzlich redet er und er sieht gar nicht wer und es ist ihm dann auch irgendwann völlig, also er verliert den Überblick. So wie er auch, man sich fragt beim Chefredakteur, hat er nicht auch irgendwann den Überblick verloren über seine SMS-Inbox? Also wie organisiert man denn mit 20 Frauen gleichzeitig und so? Und diese Geschichte zwischen dem Chefredakteur und all den Frauen namentlich Sophia ist eine Geschichte und parallel dazu wird und das ist dann interessant, weil das dann nicht Fremdbeschreibung, sondern Selbstbeschreibung ist, die Geschichte erzählt von ihm selbst und seinem guten Freund, der wirtschaftliche Chef des Redaktionsleiters, das Chef-CEO ist. Und in dem Falle würde ich jetzt mal ausdrücklich dazu sagen, man kommt nicht umhin und es wäre sehr verwunderlich, wenn das nicht Julian Reichelt und Matthias Döpfner sind. Also es macht gar keinen Sinn.
Sagen wir so, es gibt eine eine Verfremdung, die vorgenommen wird. Wir haben es mit einem Fernsehsender zu tun, aber ich sage mal, wenn ich jetzt nach zehn Jahren, neun Zwanzigern einen Roman schreiben würde über zwei Männer, die Wolfram und Steffen heißen und einen Podcast betreiben, der die treuen Zwanziger heißt, dann könnte man auch Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen, dass möglicherweise wir beide gemeint sind.
Also es bleibt dabei, wie ich schon in der letzten Ausgabe sagte, es sind nicht nur juristische Gründe. Es gibt auch künstlerische Argumente, das so zu machen. Aber für mich und es macht einen erheblichen Spaß aus, zu wissen, dass es sich hier umreichelt.
Wir sind hier in der Boulevard-Rezeption. Wir können uns gleich da noch mal anschließend Fragen stellen. Ich stimme dir absolut zu, dass so der Roman aufgebaut ist. Ich glaube nur, dass da, wo man Offenheit und Ehrlichkeit an den Tag legt, das bei den Frauen tut und bei dieser Konstellation, das aber bei der Konstellation der Freundschaft, die ja an sich auch viel interessanter ist, dass dort so vieles einfach nicht kommt. Also es ist auch gar nicht, dass man sich herausredet, sondern das ist einfach mal so lapidar und hat er sich wohl verändert oder komisch, ich erkenne ihn gar nicht mehr wieder. Also sie sind ja befreundet, wo wir schon gleich haben jemand, der in dieser Stellung ist, also der da schon Chef dieses unglaublichen Konzerns ist. Es ist ja nicht so, dass da jemand mal so reingeschlittert ist und dann hat man irgendwann den Draht zu jemand verloren, sondern wir haben es damit zu tun. Und wir haben nur eine große Verwunderung dann bei dem Schriftsteller ich, bei dem Erzähler ich, darüber, dass dieser Freund nun nicht mehr ganz so offen und ehrlich kommuniziert, wenn es um irgendwelche Vorfälle im Unternehmen mit Frauen geht. Lass mich noch, bevor wir auf den Roman sprechen, du hast den Podcast auch gehört, Boys Club. Hast du den komplett gehört?
Nee, nur die ersten zwei Folgen. Ich fand natürlich, und ich will das ja auch als Freundschaft zu Ihnen sagen, das war ein sehr gut produzierter Podcast. Da hat er auch die Joscha mit seinen Fingern mit im Spiel. Aber ich finde es eben inhaltlich mit der Kritik beim letzten Mal schon angemerkt, wir haben es hier mit einem Roman zu tun und ich bin sehr froh.
Aber lass mich erst was zu dem Podcast noch gerade sagen, weil ich finde, man muss schon mal, ich will mal zwei, drei Worte dazu tragen.
Alle Kritik meinerseits habe ich beim letzten Mal gesagt.
Ja, du würdest aber nicht jetzt mir langsam zustimmen, dass vielleicht doch eine, sagen wir, eine gewisse, wie sagt man im Marketing, wenn man sich so ein Cross-Marketing gab, also zwischen Zeitveröffentlichung, Podcastveröffentlichung und Romanveröffentlichung.
Überzeugt mich gerne von anderen.
In Folge 6 kommt zum Beispiel auch noch mal dieses noch wach vor, was wusste Matthias Döpfner? Also man hat hier schon tolle Überleitungen geschaffen. Dieser Podcast ist ja so aufgebaut, dass er zum einen erzählen will, wie es den Frauen in dem Unternehmen ergehen. Und zum anderen erzählt er ein bisschen die Geschichte der Bildzeitung, allerdings sehr rudimentär. Also das kann man in Sichtdokumentationen auch besser sehen. Da wird auch noch mal Klaus Steg zum Beispiel interviewt. Und zu Wort kommen auch die ein oder anderen Geschasten, oder die Bild verlassen haben. Das ist eine Kritik aber dann an Springer, die sehr oberflächlich bleibt. Also ein ehemaliger Redakteur kommt da zu Wort, der sagt, ja das ist ja schade eigentlich, dass in der Bild jetzt nicht mehr so schöne Geschichten so ein bisschen verrückt waren, wie früher UFOs landen oder Bär erschossen werden. Und da denke ich mir, naja, ist das jetzt das Problem, dass die Politisierung bei Bild stattgefunden hat? Sondern das Problem ist ja, in welcher Art hat die Politisierung stattgefunden?
Sie trauen sich kein Humor mehr zu, sondern es ist alles nur noch so super ernst. Und das würde ich sagen, ist auch vielleicht ein Problem.
Was mich an dem Podcast stört ist einmal dieser Ton, der angeschlagen wird, der Betroffenheit, dass so eine enorme Emotionalisierung stattfindet und dass man es an Einzelfällen irgendwie aufziehen will, aber zugleich das System zeigen will. Und ich frage eigentlich an diesem Punkt schon mal, und wir haben ja auch schon uns über diese Zeitrecherche geäußert beim letzten Mal, benötigt man eigentlich investigativ Journalismus, um die Bildzeitung zu analysieren? Also man benötigt investigativ Journalismus vielleicht, um rauszufinden, was war denn da jetzt genau mit den Frauen los? Da wird sicherlich der Investigativ-Journalismus wichtig. Aber muss ich mich jetzt mit einzelnen Leuten treffen, die nochmal sagen, ja tatsächlich haben wir damals so ein Flüchtling so richtig vorgeführt und so weiter? Denn das zeigt die Zeitung mir ja direkt. Da muss ich ja nicht nochmal jemand nachfragen. Also ich muss ja auch nicht mit Til Schweiger nochmal darüber reden, warum Manta Manta so schlecht ist, sondern das sehe ich ja da schon. Das heißt, was man eigentlich doch analytisch leisten kann, bietet die Zeitung oder bietet einem das Video-Format, das sie da haben im Internet, doch sofort an. Ich meine, wie lange gibt es jetzt den Bildblock? Seit über zehn Jahren wissen wir eigentlich, wie das System Bildzeitung funktioniert. Es gibt die Kritik an Springer seit 68. Denken wir an die verlorene Ehre der Katharina Blum von Heinrich Böll. Und hier wird aber jetzt nochmal so investigativ rangegangen. Und eigentlich sind sehr viele Erzählweisen dann große Entschuldigungsorgien, nämlich für die einzelnen Akteure. Und das eine ist, dass Frauen dort in Abhängigkeitsverhältnissen sind. Und das muss auch aufgeklärt werden. Und da bin ich auch sehr dafür, dass das geschieht. Das andere ist aber, wenn man jetzt so tut, ja, also diese ganzen Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse und dieses ganze System Bild und dieser Druck und all das führt dann dazu, dass man als Journalist hingeht und mit einem Flüchtling ein Interview führt, um ihn danach einer rechten Meute auszuliefern, in einem wirklich völlig sinnentstellenden Artikel. Das ist die individuelle Verantwortung auch des einzelnen Journalisten. Und es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten als bei Springer zu arbeiten, wenn man eine journalistische Karriere machen will. Das wird in dem Podcast zunehmend so dargestellt, als seien die da so hineingeraten und sie wussten nicht, wie ihnen geschieht. Da muss man fast wieder mit dem Max Gold-Zitat kommen, es sind schlechte Menschen, die dort arbeiten. Also man muss auch mal wieder die Verantwortung an die Akteure zurückgeben. Das eine sind sexuelle, erotische Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse, die sich ergeben. Aber man kann auch Nein sagen, denn das läuft dann am Ende nur noch darauf hinaus, also zumindest jetzt in diesen ersten sechs Folgen, die ich gehört habe, dass man dann sagen kann, ja, was können wir tun, damit es Bildredakteurinnen besser geht? Und dann muss ich sagen, nee, das ist nicht das Hauptproblem. Das ist ein Problem und das muss gelöst werden. Ist auch ein Fall für Anwälte. Aber es geht jetzt nicht darum, wie schaffen wir mehr Diversity und Empowerment ins Springerhaus, sondern eigentlich muss ja mal die Bildzeitung als solches kritisiert werden. Und das findet aber viel zu wenig statt. Und das liegt auch daran, dass man das alles so sehr dann auf diesen so bösen Chefredakteur abstellt. Und ich bin da wirklich sehr, sehr wütend darüber, dass man in diesem Podcast eigentlich zum Teil Leute, die schlimme Sachen getan haben, journalistisch, auf diese Weise entschuldigt, dass man sagt, ja, aber dieses System Springer, was dann noch soweit geht, dass man sagt, ja, es ist unglaublich, was dann Volontäre da erleben und man denkt, was kommt jetzt? Naja, dass dann irgendjemand losgeschickt wird, irgendeine Reise antreten muss und dann darf sie sogar Business-Klasse fliegen. Und das wird aber dann so umgemodelt, als sei das irgendwie Druckausübung, damit man dann noch besser was abliefert. Wo ich denke, also alle Volontäre, die ich zumindest in meinem Leben kennengelernt habe, wären froh, sie könnten mal irgendwo in Business-Klasse. Sie müssen ja meistens mit einem Sparticket in der zweiten Klasse versuchen, das noch irgendwie absetzen zu können. Also das ist schon wahnsinnig verrückt. Und worauf ich glaube, alles jetzt hinausläuft, ist, dass man sich sehr auf den Übeltäter Julian Reichelt konzentrieren wird im Diskurs. Das ist ja Springer im Prinzip jetzt auch sehr recht. Dann kriegt noch ein bisschen Döpfner etwas ab. Aber sonst erleben wir doch jetzt gerade, wie Linksliberale Paul Ronzheimer hochleben lassen wegen seiner Kriegsberichterstattung. Wir erleben doch, wie der Maximal-Opportunist Mickey Beisenherz gestern im Podcast noch Franka Leefeld eingeladen hat. Also wir erleben doch gar nicht die eigentliche Problematik bei diesen ganzen Enthüllungen, nämlich dass hier die FDP ein großes Medienhaus hinter sich hat und deswegen so viel durchbekommt. Das wäre ja eigentlich die Kritik, die zu leisten ist. Und das findet aber leider nicht statt. Und stattdessen bekommen wir dann lauter emotionale Geschichten serviert, bei denen ich aber auch eigentlich mit demselben Bulvarblick draufblicke, wie wenn die Bild-Zeitung mir irgendwas erzählt, dass der Haussegen bei Marianne und Michael schief hängt.
Und all das greife ich jetzt mal auf, um dich davon zu überzeugen, dass das ein sehr gutes Buch ist.
Okay, das war jetzt meine Podcast-Kritik. Das war noch, wir waren noch nicht hier meine...
Genau.
Wir kommen jetzt mal zu dem Buch.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage, wie kann man das eigentlich besser machen, wenn man den Podcast nach den und den Maßstäben, die du jetzt genannt hast, kritisiert? Wie kriegt man es dann besser hin? Und wir haben hier eher mit einem Buch zu tun, in dem es eben nicht Döpfner und nicht Reichelt sind, weshalb niemand hier irgendwelche Anstrengungen erwarten muss, dass irgendwelche Sachen so richtig krass belegt werden und die Plausibilität über, haben wir aber ganz lange recherchiert und so weiter, uns irgendwie gelogen wird. Weil es ist eh immer verdächtig, wenn dieses investigative Aushängeschild so hochgehängt wird, dass man sich fragt, aber ihr wisst schon, dass wir einen Rechtsweg und Staatsanwälte haben für diese Art der Aufgabe. Also da muss man uns jetzt nicht irgendwie reintricksen in so einer Art, ist aber auch noch schön geschrieben, Literatur. Ich habe beim letzten Mal schon gesagt, wenn Holger Stark meint, das sind wichtige Zitate, lese ich in diesem Text nur die Zitate. Dann ist mir egal, welche Überleitung Holger Stark noch von Döpfner Zitat zu Döpfner Zitat schreibt, sondern dann ist der Journalismus einfach für mich passé. Dann will ich nur noch wissen, ja, hat es denn jetzt Konsequenzen? Und damit meine ich aber juristische Konsequenzen. Also ich erwarte nicht drauf, dass die Zeit jetzt mir publizistisch plausibel Döpfner zur Strecke bringt. Weil warten auf Godot ist nicht mehr. Also da ist einfach, wenn Sachen justiziabel sind, sind sie justiziabel. All das spielt ja hier im Buch gar keine Rolle, denn es ist ja nicht Döpfner und es ist ja nicht Reichelt, sagt der Autor und er nennt sie ja auch nicht beim Namen. Und da wird es nämlich wahnsinnig interessant. Also ich habe eben schon diese Aufstellung gemacht. Sophia als Schiffre, oder Sophia als Schiffre für sehr viele Frauen. Und dann der Chefredakteur, der keinen Namen bekommt, sondern der Chefredakteur. Chefredakteur, wissen wir, das ist eine Organisationsbezeichnung. Während der Autor und sein Freund, Freund ist eine persönliche Zuschreibung, dass der dann auch noch in entsprechend wichtiger Rolle, also hier wird nicht vom CEO oder so durchgehend gesprochen, sondern es ist der Freund, der zum Ex-Freund wird. Das ist die Verwandlung, die da drinsteckt. Und der Chefredakteur, der, und das ist ja der große Aufhänger, immer noch Chefredakteur ist, obwohl so viel Arbeit drinsteckte, ihn eigentlich dieses Amtes zu entheben und man hatte ihn sogar soweit. Und dann kam dieses Compliance-Verfahren zu dem Schluss und das ähnelt sich nun wirklich mit dieser Reichelten-Geschichte. Also die New York Times publiziert oder die New Atlantic oder wie sie es hier nennen. Daraufhin wird vom Freund als CEO die Entscheidung getroffen, wir entheben ihn jetzt seiner organisatorialen Macht, damit auch all seiner Aura, die für die Frauen so interessant war, und sagen, er pausiert jetzt erstmal, bis wir unser Compliance-Verfahren abgeschlossen haben. Und dann, und das ist ja diese Pointe vor der Pointe, kommt er plötzlich wieder und ist wieder der Chefredakteur. Und der Freund macht noch so eine große Schose drum herum und sagt, ja, ja, wir haben aber auch daraus gelernt und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist ja der Anlass. Und da, also da stößt ja das Buch dann wirklich an die Realität zu sagen. Und weil Reichel damals nicht gefeuert wurde nach diesem Compliance-Verfahren, habe ich dieses Buch geschrieben. Also das Buch ist, die Publikation dieses Buches ist eigentlich eine Fortsetzung des neunzehnten Kapitels des Buches selbst. All das, was jetzt so stattfindet, von dem wir wieder nicht sehen, was stattfindet, weil kein Rechercheur der Zeit gerade mit Stuckrad-Barres so im Gespräch ist, uns aufzuzeigen, wie die Geschichte des Ich-Authors hier weiterging. Das ist das eine, was die Konstellation, die soziale Landkarte sozusagen angeht, um uns das plausibel zu machen, was hier zu erzählen ist. Das zweite ist die Fragestellung. Während du ja zurecht kritisiert hast, dass sich der Podcast eigentlich die falsche Fragestellung stellt, nämlich ist der Springer-Verlag der einzige, der noch Journalisten ausbildet, muss man einmal durch die Springer-Hörle gegangen sein, um als Journalist was zu sein und so weiter und so fort.
Und wie können wir dann den Frauen helfen?
Genau, wie können wir dann den Frauen helfen? Da ist ja immer die Frage, wie kommt man rein? Gibt es einen falschen Weg rein und so weiter? Die Frage stellt sich Herr Stuckrad-Barre als Autor hier gar nicht, sondern ihn interessiert allein, wenn sich Menschen begegnen und alles ist gut. Das Einvernehmen ist irgendwie da und es hat sich auch keiner gewehrt, niemand wurde gewaltigt und so weiter und so fort. Wie kommt man denn, wenn sich der Wind dreht, wenn sich die Stimmung ändert, wieder raus aus dieser Beziehung? Das ist ja die zentrale Frage und das ist eine völlig legitime Frage, die absolut berechtigt ist, weil sie eben von den ganzen Journalisten nicht aufgegriffen wird. Und da muss man auch Plausibilität herstellen, nicht über diese Erklärungen, was in irgendwelchen SMS entstanden, sondern da muss man auf einer Gefühlsebene und auch ein bisschen abstrahiert. Und das muss dann auch nicht Döpfner und Springer und Reichheit sein, sondern das kann dann überall einfach thematisiert werden. Diese Art des Machtmissbrauchs im Sinne von, hier sieht man, hier korrumpiert plötzlich Macht in eine persönliche Beziehung rein. Also es spielt ja keine Rolle, wie mächtig jemand ist, wenn jemand einfach nur sagt, ich habe für uns einen Tisch im Borchi klar gemacht. Und so eine Einladung habe ich ja noch nie bekommen. Jemand macht für mich einen Tisch im Borchi klar. Dann geht man ins Borchardtessen und ist dann unter diesen ganzen Prominenten. Und das gilt dann aber als Freundschaftsdienst. Das macht man halt so. Der eine hat halt diese Kapazitäten, so was zu erreichen, schön und gut. Aber wenn dann plötzlich die Szenerie kommt, sie hatte einen Zitat-Fick-Rückfall und zwar nicht, um sich weiter hochzuschlafen, sondern um ihren Absturz zu verhindern, dann wird es ein Problem. Also das Problem viel weiter hinten in dieser Verkettung von persönlichen Begegnungen und so weiter anlegen. Und das fand ich wahnsinnig gut, wahnsinnig wichtig und eben auch noch wahnsinnig clever geschrieben einfach über diese hunderten Sachen.
Wir bringen mal ein paar Sätze zu Gehör. Und zwar beginnt das Ganze so. Und dann fragt er dich, ob er dir den amerikanischen Botschafter vorstellen darf. Und dann machst du einen Knicks und schämst dich. Aber der Botschafter ist total nett und spricht dich mehrmals mit deinem Namen an. In deinem Geburtsort habe er studiert und sogar seine Frau kennengelernt. Sie müssen uns mal in Wisconsin besuchen. Er lobt dein Englisch, du lobst sein Deutsch. Und dann geht das so weiter und dann... Er ist eigentlich gar nicht dein Typ. Klingt vielleicht komisch, aber auch deshalb vertraust du ihm total. Deine letzten Boyfriends haben immer nur sich selbst gesehen, waren krass eifersüchtig, zum Teil sogar aggro. Alles war Kampf, das hörte nie auf. Und auch lange nach Ende der Beziehung konnte da jederzeit nochmal eine Attacke kommen. Und plötzlich triffst du diesen Menschen, der dich sieht, der dich versteht, der dein Potential erkennt und dann dich glaubt. In einer Nacht, in der du dich plötzlich wahnsinnig einsam fühlst und Angst hast, dass dein Ex, der immer noch einen Schlüssel zu deiner Wohnung hat und den einfach nicht wieder rausrückt, plötzlich in der Tür steht, da ruft dieser wunderbare Mensch dich an. Er hatte ein fast unheimliches Gespür für solche Momente und er sagt dir, du könntest zu ihm kommen, auf seinem Sofa seist du sicher. Und das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass du denkst, er ist mein Retter. Nein, du glaubst nicht an Märchen und Barbie, Prinzen, Scheiß, Dreck. Und du willst auch auf jeden Fall sehr professionell sein und Grenzen sind wichtig und so. Aber das hier ist nicht so, wie es von außen vielleicht aussieht, dieses Klischee, deutlich älterer Chef kümmert sich um die junge, hübsche, auszubildende Knick-Knack-Haha-Null. Ihr habt etwas ganz Besonderes. Er macht also hier Folgendes, dass er erstmal in diese Perspektive der Frau hineinkriegt, der Erzähler.
Aber auch nur für dieses...
Oder wir eine Erzähler-Stimme, eine weibliche haben, die jetzt so einen inneren Monolog hat darüber, wie es eigentlich dazu gekommen ist. Und das ist die Uvertüre zu diesem Roman. Und dann aber haben wir die Stimme des Ich-Erzählers und diese Beginn zu erzählen. Erst einmal vom Château Marmont. Man ist dort in einem Luxus-Resort, hat dort es mit einigen Prominenten zu tun. Drew Barrymore und Co. sind immer wieder mal da und man verlebt die Tage am Pool, glaubt eigentlich, dass nicht viel los ist. Aber dann verändert sich auch dadurch die Welt durch Trump, Weinstein und Co.
Lass uns kurz bei der Overtüre bleiben, die ich ja sehr gelungen fand. Ich habe es inzwischen auch einmal so ein bisschen angelesen und also so zur Hälfte. Und dann habe ich es jetzt zweimal gehört, weil auch Stuckrad-Barres das finde ich ganz toll vorliest. Gerade am Anfang. Er ist noch nicht in diese Ich erzähle, das Schicksal von Sophie und allen Beteiligten, sondern für zwei Kapitel ist es und dann hast du und dann weiß man nicht genau, ist das ein Selbstgespräch einer Protagonistin oder kriegt der Autor der Leserin in dem Falle in den Kopf und erinnert sie vielleicht an Sachen, die so oder so ähnlich auch erlebt hat und macht schon mal, da man ja sehr weiß, worum es in diesem Buch gehen soll, schon mal so ein paar Problemfelder auf, bei denen man sich fragt, wo ist denn eigentlich das Problem? Und dann beschreibt er und das finde ich ist sehr gelungene Fahrstuhlsoziologie und das ist so ein eigenes Genre, das ich mal kurz begründe. Menschen steigen in den Fahrstuhl mit nur einem Ansinnen. Sie wollen das Stockwerk wechseln. Und wenn man sich danach fragt, was war im Fahrstuhl los? Gar nichts. Ich war ja nur zehn Sekunden drin. Das ging halt schnell und so weiter. Und ein Soziologe steht so da und denkt, da ist doch alles im Fahrstuhl passiert. Es spielt sich doch alles im Fahrstuhl ab. Und wir kennen das heute. Der Pitch ist natürlich der Pitch, den man im Fahrstuhl macht. Also man begegnet zufällig dem Chef und so weiter, pitcht dann irgendwas und plötzlich ist die Welt eine andere. Und vielleicht ist sie dann auch wirklich eine andere, aber zumindest kann man schon mal in den Fahrstuhl anders aussteigen, als man eingestiegen ist und so. Und er beschreibt das hier, finde ich, also wirklich toll, wie die Sophie, Sophia oder du halt in dem Falle, also du, wie es angesprochen, du hast einen technischen Fehler gemacht. Du bist also neu in einer Organisation und dir unterläuft ein Fehler. Alle lachen über dich und auch außerhalb der Organisation. Du hast eine falsche Bauchbinde eingeblendet. Auch auf Twitter wird sich darüber lustig gemacht. Alle bekommen es mit und dann kommt der Chef und rettet dich aus dieser Situation. Nicht indem er irgendwie und so weiter ist ja unser wohntechnisches Problem, sondern er fängt dich da auf, wo du gerade bist, nämlich irgendwie am Boden. Und du wärst dich aber nicht dagegen, weil er ist ja der Chef und eigentlich ist es ja auch noch angenehm, das so zu erfahren und es ist auch noch gar keine sexuelle Dimension, sondern ihr verabredet erst mal regelmäßig im Büro mit ihm Mittag zu essen, während alle in die Kantine gehen, wissen auch alle, ok, du hast zuerst den Fehler gemacht, sie haben über dich gelacht, jetzt fürchten sie dich so ein bisschen, weil sie wissen, du kommst nicht mit in die Kantine, sondern bist beim Chef im Büro essen. Und wenn du doch mal in der Kantine bist, ist man sehr freundlich zu dir und dein Platz neben dir bleibt niemals leer, weil alle jetzt mit dir und so weiter, weil sie wissen, ah, da ist vielleicht so ein kurzer Dienstweg zum Chef. Und das finde ich ganz herausragend beschrieben, weil das so diese Situation ist, niemand kann hier irgendwerem einen Vorwurf machen, dass das so passiert. Es ist einfach gar nichts Verwerfliches. Und trotzdem sehen wir schon, was dämmert. Wir wissen ja, worauf das Buch hinausläuft, selbst bevor wir es gelesen haben, weil es ja diskutiert wird.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass du das sagst. Ich bin sehr, sehr froh, dass du das sagst und würde nämlich da mal einhaken wollen. Es ist ja hier erst einmal nichts Schlimmes dabei. Das sind Situationen, die sich so oder so ergeben können. Hältst du diesen Roman für so klug, dass er uns einmal die Differenz aufzeigt zwischen dem, was da mal so passiert und wo es dann eine systemische Dimension annimmt des Machtmissbrauchs? Haben wir nicht eher es hier mit einem Roman zu tun, der von Anfang an das schon unter einem Problem verhandelt und damit ja auch einen Roman geschaffen hat, in dem es keine Sexualität mehr gibt außerhalb des Machtmissbrauchs? Und auch der Ich-Erzähler geradezu zölibatär zu leben scheint. Es gibt einmal den Moment, wo er sich fragt, ob er mit Sophia auch so gerne redet, weil vielleicht da doch was mehr kommen könnte. Und das ist aber diese einzige kleine Augenblicke, in denen mal darüber nachgedacht wird, dass man vielleicht selbst auch begehren hat, ein sexuelles Wesen ist. Sonst ist der Roman völlig davon befreit.
Es gibt noch eine zweite Stelle.
Und man tut das um diese eigentlich intrikate Frage nämlich, wann wird es denn problematisch oder wann haben wir es mit einem Machtmissbrauch zu tun und wann ist das eine natürliche Hierarchie, die im Begehren entstehen kann zwischen Menschen generell. Und das hat dann auch gar nichts mit Mann oder Frau oder so zu tun. Das wäre eine Frage und das wird jetzt eigentlich mein Leitthema dieser ganzen Folge sein. Das wäre etwas, was Brad Easton Ellis verhandeln kann, was er auch verhandelt in The Shards. Also ich will hier schon mal ganz deutlich sagen, The Shards ist der ganz große Roman und Brad Easton Ellis kommt ja hier auch vor bei Stuckrad-Barre. Und Stuckrad-Barre versteht aber Brad Easton Ellis nicht mehr. Er sei jetzt auch so komisch und liebt jetzt so das politisch Unkorrektsein. Ich würde sagen, Brad Easton Ellis ist immer noch derselbe geblieben, aber Stuckrad-Barre, so meine Unterstellung jetzt hier schon mal, springt auf einen fahrenden Zug auf, um noch eine Weile weiter die Karriere machen zu können, die jetzt ein bisschen im Argen gelegen hat, weil man diesen engen Springerkontakt hat. Man schaufelt sich jetzt frei, aber wir schweifen jetzt ab vom Text. Aber ich frage dich, löst der Text das ein, dass da mal wirklich gezeigt wird, was dann aber das Begehren ist, wo es nicht mit Missbrauch zusammenhängt?
Wir begeben uns jetzt auf das wichtigste Gebiet dieses Buches, außerhalb des Textes. Denn diese Fragestellung hatte ich auch. Und es gibt diese eine Stelle. Er, der Ich-Autor, hilft Sophia und fängt dann auch plötzlich an, mit ihr so rumzuscherzen. Sie ist ja eine sehr starke, sehr taffe Frau. Und er legt ihr ja so Worte in den Mund, wo man denkt, ah, die ist so witzig. Es ist nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass man sich tatsächlich so ein bisschen in sie verguckt, wenn man mit ihr zu tun hat. Nur, man weiß eben nicht genau, braucht sie ihn wegen dieser Hilfestellung, der er leistet. Und es wird ja im Buch ganz klar gesagt, die Frauen können sich nicht alleine helfen. Sie beschädigen ihren Chef und damit immer auch sich selbst. Die Männer müssen da eine Rolle spielen. Auf der Täterseite sowieso und weil auf der Täterseite dann auch auf der Helferseite sozusagen. Die Frauen schaffen es nicht allein. Und jetzt ist diese eine Verhandlung. Er schickt so eine SMS und macht so einen Scherz und fragt sich, ist es eigentlich schon ein Flirt, was ich jetzt mit Sophia habe? Und sind wir hier im Einvernehmen oder ist sie auch von mir abhängig, weil ich ihre Helferposition bin? Und dann, und das finde ich noch interessanter, macht er diese zweite Stelle. Das Hollywood Access Tape von Trump. Also er geht zur Wahl, will Präsident werden und dann plötzlich kommt dieses Tape raus. Also ich begrabsche Frauen überall, ist mir doch egal, die sind mir ja unterlegen, ich bin ja Donald Trump. Schadet ihm das eigentlich oder nicht? Und da ist ja Stuckrad-Barre ganz deutlich und schreibt, ich glaube eher im Gegenteil. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, was meint er damit? Also welche Rolle spielen eigentlich die Männer im Publikum, die keine Frauen haben, die sie ausnutzen, Machtmissbrauch begehen, weil sie gar nicht in dieser organisationalen Machtposition sind, in die Verlegenheit zu kommen, irgendwen übers Trösten dann so langsam an sich zu binden und dann ihn zu verdeutlichen, wenn du mir nicht gefügig bist, ist deine Biografie einfach zu Ende. Und diese unausgesprochenen Sachen, da denke ich mir, ich lese halt zu wenig Literatur, aber was ich immer so höre, was Hullback und so behandeln, da könnte man es schon mal thematisieren, ob nicht diese Rolle der zuschauenden Männer ist, zu sagen, ja, was der Reichelt macht, ist schon blöd. Und es wäre auch blöd, wenn es meine Tochter betrifft, aber ich bin schon ein bisschen neidisch darauf, dass er so einen Zugang zu Frauen hat und den auch so strukturiert organisiert, dass er genau weiß, was die erste SMS sein muss. Und dann ist so zehn Tage lang Dauerfeuer an Laffbombing und so weiter. Und dann hüpft man halt in die Kiste, weil man dann irgendeine Dienstreise plötzlich zufällig und gleich ein Hotel und so.
Laffbombing habe ich auch erst im Podcast jetzt gelernt von diesen Voice-Club-Folgen.
Ja, dieses Überschwemmen mit Nachrichten und so weiter.
Ja, und die Frage kann ich aber beantworten. Bei Wellback wäre das zu lesen. Wellback würde mit großem Tynismus dann darüber schreiben, dass das der Grund ist, warum Trump gewählt wurde oder würde dann genau eine solche Konstellationen schreiben. Oder auch ein... Brad Easton Ellis macht ja zum Beispiel in seinem letzten Roman The Shards eine sehr interessante Passage auf, wo es einen jungen Mann gibt, also den ich erzähle, der eigentlich Drehbuchautor werden will und dann bei diesem Hollywood-Produzenten ist, in der Suite und erst mal nicht so genau ahnt, worauf sie hinausläuft, aber dann doch. Und dann lässt er sich darauf ein, er wird ziemlich gezwungen. Also im viel größeren Maße ist da ein Zwang, der ausgeübt wird, als das jetzt hier geschildert ist im Chefredakteursystem von noch wach und Bradysson Ellis geht aber dann doch noch mal hin und zeigt diese ganze Ambivalenz dieser Hierarchie und des Begehrens. Und wie dann plötzlich das eigentliche Opfer einen Stolz darauf entwickelt, diese Reife zu haben, sich auch noch auf das eingelassen zu haben. Also da kommt, will ich sagen, viel mehr Ambivalenz, viel mehr Widersprüchlichkeit des Menschseins, des Begehrens zutage, als hier. Und das ist mein Vorwurf. Und deswegen bin ich auch enttäuscht von diesem Roman. Also ich habe den ja jetzt nicht gelesen, um ihn schlecht zu finden, auch wenn ich mich da negativ zu Stuckrad-Barre geäußert habe. Sondern was mich an diesem Roman enttäuscht, ist eigentlich das, was du so stark gemacht hast, bevor wir den Roman gelesen haben, nämlich die Fiktionalisierung. Ich finde die Fiktionalisierung und auch die Literarizität zu gering und halte den Roman zu nah an dem, was wir vom Investigativ, Journalismus und von dem besagten Podcast kennen. Und dadurch beraubt man sich als Schriftsteller eigentlich der Fähigkeit der Literatur, nämlich genau das, was uns wirklich zwischenmenschlich interessieren würde, einmal aufzuzeigen. Und das kommt in Momenten mal vor. Da ist der Roman auch stark. Aber sonst ist sehr viel, sehr schwarz und weiß, was man machen würde, wenn man eine Anklageschrift formuliert, was aber für einen Roman unter literarischen Gesichtspunkten nicht besonders sinnvoll ist.
Also genau da unterscheiden wir uns am meisten. Denn ich halte die extrem hohe Nähe, also die Approximationshoffnung, die man haben kann, dass man hier, und ich finde, der Machtmissbrauch zwischen dem Chefredakteur und Sophia ist das eine und den anderen Frauen. Aber die extrem hohe Approximationshoffnung, die man hat, wenn man so ein Buch in die Hand nimmt, zu erfahren, Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barre und Matthias Döpfner, was gibt es da eigentlich noch zu sagen? Und da finde ich, ich kenne die anderen Bücher von Stuckrad-Barre, wie gesagt, nicht. Und ich werde sie mir aber noch mal anschauen, jetzt unter diesem Eindruck, weil ich das wirklich herausragend unterhaltsam, verständlich, plausibel... Es beantwortet mir so ganz viele Fragen, die mir auch erst... Es ist so ein Textverlauf und plötzlich, die Frage habe ich auch noch, und dann so drei Sätze später kommt dann auch so die Antwort. Aber wenn du so angedeutet, er macht diese sehr kurze Sprache, er will ja wirklich nicht die Zeit des Lesers verschwenden. Also ich finde es ein sehr dichten, sehr vollgepackten…
Es ist eine Sprache, die der gesprochenen Sprache sehr nahe kommt. Deswegen liegt es dann nahe, ihn als Hörbuch dann zu erleben. Es ist keine Literatur, die… Ich finde, ich sage, sie ist nicht eigenständig, aber sie lebt sehr davon, dass man den Ton von Stuckrad-Barre im Ohr hat und weiß, wie er so ist. Das ist bei anderen Literaten ja völlig anders, aber hier ist das sehr, sehr deutlich. Das, was wir von Stuckrad-Barre kennen, wie wir seine Interview-Äußerungen kennen, und das bekommen wir hier dann in verdichteter Form nochmal. Aber dann sag doch mal was zu diesem Verhältnis des Freundes, zu diesem Chef des Konzerns.
Also, ich will mal Worte aufgreifen, die verwendet werden, um uns die zentralen Protagonisten darzustellen. Erste innertliche Szene ist, sie sind in Amerika, weit weg, und es ist eine Autofahrt von Los Angeles nach San Francisco. Und wir haben alle noch im Hinterkopf, ja, damals hat Matthias Döppner die ganze Springer-Chef-Riege verdonnert, jetzt leben wir drei Monate in San Francisco. Wir kriegen jetzt mal mit, wie das im Silicon Valley und so weiter, wir tanken uns hier mal voll. So, sie sitzen in dem Auto und reden über den Skandal bei Springer unter Kai Diekmann. Damals irgendwie nackt baden mit der Belegschaft und so weiter. Und da möchte er uns noch mal das allerletzte Mal eigentlich vorgaukeln, wenn wir hier über Springer reden, ist das eine Fremdbeschreibung. Dabei ist das ja schon ein Gespräch. Und ich glaube, in dem Falle dieser Autofahrt hat es sich so gegeben, dass einfach Stuckrad-Barre neben seinem Milliardär und besten Freund, der ihn eben auch durchfinanziert und gar keine Ahnung hat, wie viel er ihm ermöglicht mit diesem Gehaltscheck. Also, davon wird jetzt ganz blöd dargestellt, wie viel er ihm ermöglicht und diese Autofahrt findet statt. Und ab dann, also da ist es noch mein Freund. Und es verändert sich dann, also es ist dann so der Salon-Geistesmensch, vielleicht mein allerbester Freund. Wir sind sehr eng, praktisch Brüder. Manchmal, also einmal spricht er dann auch von Freund. Ach, das ist eigentlich meine Liebe und so. Also sie sind sich sehr dicke und diese andere Ebene, also dass er eben nicht nur Freund, sondern eben auch Chef dieses Ladens ist, blitzt dann manchmal durch, wenn er sagt, er war es in dieser und jener Situation nicht gewohnt, dass Menschen keine Angst vor ihm hatten, wenn sie ihm begegnet sind. Also es wird schon klar, okay, du verschweigst uns ja, wie viel Geld du bekommen hast damals, aber du verschweigst zumindest nicht, dass er dir gegenüber nicht, also dass du so eng in seinem Kreis warst, dass er an der Beziehung mit dir profitiert hat, um anderen gegenüber darzustellen. Aber ich bin hier der Chef. Also man hat mir bei vielen mächtigen Menschen, bei Putin ist ja immer so diese Frage, wer nährt ihn eigentlich in seiner Machtfülle und so weiter? Wo kann er so verdunklen? Ich kenne den und den und den und so und ich habe alles in der Hand. Und wem gegenüber spielt das aus? Und hier ist ganz klar, Stuckrad-Barre gehört zu denjenigen, die eigentlich nichts zu befürchten haben von Matthias Döpfner.
Weil er eigentlich eine hofnahen Funktion hat.
Genau, diese hofnahen Funktion, während er dann immer damit spielt, ist nicht eigentlich Döpfner der Hofnah. Zum Beispiel seinem Chefredakteur gegenüber. Wer ist denn da eigentlich der Chef von den beiden? Der Chefredakteur wird uns ja dann auch vorgestellt. Der Chefredakteur per se und dann Krawalldödel und dann immer dieses ruhig Brauner, wo er ja auch nochmal dieses Brauner besonders ist. Eigentlich auch Pferde gemünzt, aber wir wissen, wie er das hier verwendet und so. Macht auch mehrmals Tucker Carlson für noch ärmere. Er schreibt halt so über Bande, das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut. Und dann kommen diese Protagonisten vor, Eden Musk, Lars Eidinger. Das finde ich auch sehr sand zusammengebaut. Ich finde auch sehr viel Lars Eidinger-Bild, wie man es so breit treten kann.
Dass der auch nochmal durch irgendeine verrückte Performance rennt, weil das gerade so schick ist.
Fragst du, wie Musk, kommst du mit ins Theater? Und er so, ist eine Bescheuert, ich gehe jetzt nicht ins Theater, ich lege mich in meine Bude hier und schlafe auf dem Holzbrett, um meine Firma aufzubauen.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch ganz kurz sagen, wie der Freund geschildert wird, der dann ankommt in Amerika. Da heißt es, auf gar keinen Fall war er es jetzt geboten, Scherze über seine seltsame Kleidung zu machen. Er trug einen Stanford-Hoodie aus Kashmir, eine Sonnenbrille mit buntschangierenden Gläsern und anders als sonst keinerlei Haargel, was bei seinem noch immer sehr kräftigen Haarwuchs eine wirklich seltsame Ananas-Frisur erzeugte. Kurzum, er sah komplett verrückt aus. Seine Armbanduhr war auch neu bzw. neu-alt mit Stoffe am Band gekonnt abgeschrabbelt. Seine Kleidung und Aufmachung sollten fraglos bedeuten, dass sie ihm nichts bedeuten. Und so ging es dahin, in die neue Welt. So etwas kann er beschreiben, aber das macht nicht den ganzen Roman. Wir lesen hier immer so einzelne Passagen und die finde ich auch ein bisschen unterhübsch.
Ich würde mich da verhüten, ich habe mir ein paar rausgeschrieben, aber man darf es nicht immer so kontextlos machen. Also im Verlauf der Geschichte.
Nein, ich finde die Passagen kontextlos gut, aber ich finde, dass sie in der ganzen Erzählung nicht funktionieren. Also die ganze Erzählung ist wahnsinnig ermüden.
Auf die Und so ging es dahin in die neue Welt, was ja schon fast zu kitschig ist. Er macht sich immer sehr lustig über Menschen, die zu kitschig sind. Ja, genau. Er greift so ironische Sachen auf, die er dann als kitsch noch mal markiert und sie trotzdem ausspricht. Weil auf dieses Und so ging es dahin in die neue Welt folgt ja dann so ein Angeschneit waren wir trotz Freiheit. Also wo diese total vulgäre Liberalismus-Idee von dem Freund noch mal durchschimmert, der ja als vollständig entrückt von der Welt dargestellt wird. Der hat keine Ahnung, wie man Beziehungen führt. Der verabschiedet sich vom Telefon mit. Jetzt beginnt die Tischrede der Zentralbänkerin und so weiter. Also der überhaupt kein Gespür für gar nichts hat. Allen nur auf die Nerven geht, sich Freundschaft erkauft, würde ich eben in dem Fall auch sagen. Und der vor allem nicht weiß, was sein eigener Fernsehsender die ganze Zeit sendet. Und da, das ist ja der Ausgangspunkt für diese, weil du ja gefragt hast, nach der sozialen Lage zwischen den beiden. Und da finde ich es dann wahnsinnig interessant. Denn während der Chef, der Freund als Chef des Chefredakteurs keine Ahnung hat, was der Chefredakteur die ganze Zeit veranstaltet, leidet der Autor zunehmend darunter, dass es hier zwar ein Freund ist, der ihn, wie wir jetzt dazu sagen, unausgesprochen sehr gut bezahlt. Und plötzlich muss sich der Autor, also Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barres, die ganze Zeit damit befassen, dass wir es hier mit so einem Brüllsender, einem seltsamen Sender, einem Krawall-Nachrichtensender, einem Höllenhaus zu tun haben, dass die ganze Zeit Nachrichten als Aufwiegelungs-Game-Show fabriziert. Ein Menschenverachtungssender mit Palliativ-Sendungen, die einem gar nichts zutrauen, aber alles zumuten. Ständig nur Breaking News, also Brechnachrichten. Und je schlimmer die Lage, desto besser die Stimmung.
Gut beschrieben, aber hier muss ich doch gleich wieder einhaken. Ist das sehr glaubwürdig, dass wir den Chef eines Konzerns haben und der weiß nicht, was da passiert? Wir wissen ein bisschen von Roger Schawinski, der ja über seine Sat.1-Zeit ein Buch geschrieben hat, dass Leo Kirch Sat.1 kaufte und auch nicht so recht wusste, was da eigentlich los ist, weil der so viel im Portfolio hatte. Er wusste nur eines, es gibt dieses Lied von Falco, alles klar Herr Kommissar und deswegen war er der Auffassung, sollte Kommissar Rex weiterhin im Angebot bleiben. Also völlig enthoben, jeglicher klugen Entscheidung, einfach nur ach ja, es gibt das Falco-Lied, Kommissar Rex hat auch was mit Kommissar zu tun. Und das sagte er ja dann auch wohl immer wieder am Telefon. Entschuldigung, es war nicht Leo Kirch, es war Heim Saban. Heim Saban ist ein großer Falco-Fan und war deshalb auch dafür.
Genau, der kam damals zu Sat.1 als Finanzinvestor mehr, mit programmatischen Ideen.
Aber hier haben wir es ja mit jemandem zu tun, der aus dem Springer-Haus ist, dort groß geworden ist, der dann diese besondere Seilschaft zu Friede Springer hat, der dann diese un glaubliche Position und das Erbe erhalten hat und der sehr genau wissen wird, was der Sender macht, wenngleich er nicht da sitzen wird und sich Viertel nach acht mit Nena Schinke anguckt. Das glaube ich auch nicht. Also wir setzen jetzt immer voraus, dass die Figuren hier im Roman, was mit den wirklichen Figuren zu tun haben, das ist natürlich eine bloße Unterstellung, sagen wir hier aus juristischen Gründen. Aber ist das, wenn wir jetzt mal in der Logik dieses Romans bleiben, ist das glaubwürdig, dass der Chef nicht weiß, was da vorgeht oder sagt er einfach, naja, diese schmutzige Arbeit, die macht mal jemand anders. Also so wie man im Hotel ist, weiß man auch, naja, die Leute, die jetzt hier die Betten oder so abziehen, die bekommen kein gutes Geld. Aber ich weiß ja trotzdem darum, dass es die gibt. Ich weiß ja schon, dass das nicht die meiste Menschen sind.
Und das macht ja dieses Buch für mich nicht nur wahnsinnig interessant, sondern auch amüsant. Denn ja, es gibt diese noch Wach-Thematisierung, Frau und der Chefredakteur und so weiter. Aber diese Beziehung von Stuckrad-Barres zu Döpfner, sage ich jetzt mal, so wie ich das. Nur deswegen ist es für mich so interessant. Ich habe ja immer die Vermutung und die wurde auch immer nur genährt und es gab niemals gute Argumente dagegen. Diese Chefriege weiß nicht, was in ihren Programmen und in denen der Anderen los ist. Diese Intendenzen in dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen interessiert nicht, was Illner mit irgendwem diskutiert. Wer zu Gast bei Anne Will ist, die interessiert. Welcher sozusagen Eindruck, welche Wirkung hat das in der Gesellschaft? Und das lesen sie morgens in diesen Nachtbesprechungen, wenn irgendwelche Leute das so aufschreiben. Die gucken diese Sendung nicht, also das ist immer die Legende.
Aber der Springer-Konzern macht ja nicht ganz zufällig eine solche Politik seit Jahrzehnten. Und eigentlich könnte da genauso auch Gewerkschaftsarbeit illustriert werden. Nein, es ist ja eine ganz klare politische Ausrichtung. Und wir sehen es ja auch an den Döpfner Nachrichten, die offenbar so sind, dass man an die Redaktion nochmal Anweisungen schickt. Stärkt, please, stärke die FDP. Also auch wenn man dann vielleicht nicht jede einzelne Sendung guckt. Und man hat ja auch immer jetzt wieder Produzenten in Podcast-Interviews erlebt, die dann wissen, was Reality-TV ist und die das auch im großen Teil produzieren. Aber die kennen natürlich jetzt nicht jedes Reality-Format ganz genau, das sie da produzieren. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen hat man einen Blick doch dafür. Und was ich mich nämlich daran anschließend frage ist, nehmen wir mal an, Matthias Döpfner liest dieses Buch und aus mir unerfündlichen Gründen erkennt er sich in der Figur dieses Freundes wieder, der ja hier einen Fernsehsender betreibt und keinen Zeitungskonzern. Glaubst du, dass das ein Buch ist, das Döpfner schadet? Ich würde sagen nein. Ich glaube, dass diese Haltung über allem zu schweben und das gar nicht so genau zu kennen, ist ja eine super Entschuldigung. Dass es hier einen Dialog gibt über ein Bild, das hochgeladen wurde und der Chef dann des Konzerns fragt seinen Freunde, also den Ich-Erzähler, wo ist denn dieser Post gewesen? Facebook? Nee, Twitter. Hä? Aber das ist doch mit Foto. Ja, bei Twitter gehen auch Fotos. Sicher? Sind das nicht immer nur diese 140 Zeichen? 280 Zeichen mittlerweile, glaube ich. Und Fotos, Fotos auch schon eine ganze Weile, soweit ich weiß. Und was stand da nochmal ganz genau? Also was wir hier erleben können, ist, dass wir es mit einem CEO zu tun haben, der diese Dinge nicht weiß und über den Sachen schwebt. Und das wiederum ist durchaus möglich. Es gibt diesen Film Margin Call, ich weiß nicht, ob du den gesehen hast, über die Lehman-Pleite. Und da gibt es einen ganz tollen Moment, wenn der Oberchef, der CEO, einfliegt mit dem Helikopter, gespielt von Jeremy Irons. Und er sitzt dort mit allen am Tisch und die haben da dicke Akten, sagen ja so folgendermaßen das und das und sagt halt stopp erzählen sie es mir als sei ich ein siebenjähriges Kind und der Film lässt offen, ob er es wirklich anders nicht versteht oder ob er die nur vorführen will.
Ich finde die Szene auch stark, weil durchschimmert am Ende, dass er es im Detail alles weiß, aber er wissen möchte, was seine Vorstandsregel über ihn denkt.
Und da bekommen wir doch dann am Ende diese Antwort, die ich auch hier sagen würde, wir haben es hier eigentlich mit einem Buch zu tun, das mit dem Freund Ex-Freund relativ glimpflig umgeht.
Ja, also ich würde differenzieren zwischen ob es Döpfner schadet, wenn er es liest oder ob es ihn ärgert und es wird ihn wahnsinnig ärgern, weil der ganze Nymus einfach hier zertroschen wird. Es ist dieses Ahnungslose dahin stolpern, Investitionsentscheidung, Springer macht jetzt mal das und das und das und das und dann guckt man einfach mal, man überlässt es dem Management, man will einfach nur diese Berichterstattung, aber dann wirklich nur für Dreijährige haben, man interessiert sich für nichts und wenn es dann...
Privanzschatzperspektive wird das genannt, ja im Roman, ganz gut.
Ja, und wenn es dann hart auf hart kommt, zeigt Stuckrad-Barre wieder ganz wunderbar, wie so ein Chef einfach unterwacht wird. Er hat ja diese eine Szenerie, er redet sehr gerne mit dem Freund und macht ihm so Vorschläge und findet es immer gut, wenn die dann auch umgesetzt werden, aber er muss immer darauf achten, als Letzter im Raum gewesen zu sein vor der Entscheidung, weil er einfach, wie bei Trump, es ist so sprunghaft, es gibt da kein Arbeitsgedächtnis. Die letzte Idee ist die beste Idee, die man hat. Und wenn man nah genug an die Entscheidungsfindung rankommt, kann man halt damit überzeugen. Also der Freund und Chef dieses Fernsehsenders wird schon als wirklicher Dösbattel, bei dem man sich nicht genau erklären kann, wie konnte denn das passieren? Und er wird im Grunde von seinem Chefredaktor vorgeführt, insbesondere als dann dieses, bevor das Compliance-Verfahren beginnt, gibt es ja so eine Art, wie soll man sagen, eine virale Kampagne. Man möchte jetzt auch die Rolle der Frau und so weiter in der Arbeitswelt mal betonen, macht das, plant das dann so als trojanisches Pferd. Der Freund ist total überzeugt davon und durchblickt gar nicht, dass das ja auch alles ironisch gelesen werden kann. Der Chefredakteur aber sofort und ersetzt dann den Freund eben auch Schachmatt. Und in der Beschreibung dieser Szenerie beantwortet uns der Autor ja sehr viele Fragen, die er uns vorher dann gestellt hat, nämlich was ist eigentlich mit meinem Freund passiert, wie konnte denn das und so weiter. Und ja, der hat sich einfach von der Welt verabschiedet. Er spielt nur noch diese Management-Rolle des Gesellschafters, der so ein bisschen drüberschwebt und nur noch von einer Tischrede zur nächsten der großen Majestäten fliegt und der Chefredakteur übernimmt einfach den Laden. Inklusive aller Macht, die er halt auf Menschen ausüben kann, inklusive. Und dann spielt eben eine große Rolle die Sache mit den Frauen. Aber ich würde eben sagen, dieses Buch muss man nicht primär als, sondern das ist, es könnte auch genauso gut ein Beziehungsdrama zwischen dem Autor und dem Freund sein, die zerbricht an einer Fragestellung. Und das ist eben hier die sehr wichtige Aufarbeitung, weil der Ich-Autor dadurch, dass so viel an ihn herangetragen wird, was er sonst auch nicht sehen würde, dann einfach thematisiert. Und da geht es dann um diese Fragen des Machtmissbrauchs, sexueller Übergriffe und so weiter. Aber man könnte das, also ich würde sagen, das kann man auch auf die Illustrationsebene dieses Romans schieben, dass das gar nicht so die primäre Fragestellung fast ist. Mich hat jedenfalls diese ganze, was ist das für eine Beziehung zwischen so einem Freigeist wie dem einen und dann dem absolut im Management und in der Verantwortung Gefangenen, der aber auch am liebsten so ein Freigeist noch wäre. Und Döpfner kam ja über diese ganze, ich rezensiere Musik und so weiter Schiene da rein und hat sich ja immer verstanden als Künstler.
Oder jemand, der zumindest die Künstler versteht.
Genau. Und musste dann leider so ein Hardcore-Manager werden, der den Laden einfach am Laufen hält. Und das fand ich eigentlich noch interessant.
Da erfahren wir hier nochmal was Neues. Also wissen wir das nicht über Döpfner. Wissen wir um dieses Schillernde nicht auch. Also ich frage mich, was bietet jetzt die Literatur mir? Und ich will jetzt mal das Lösen von den real existierenden Figuren. Wenn ich das jetzt mal lese, diesen Roman, also ich finde, ein Roman muss ja auch, auch wenn er ein Schlüsselroman ist, so funktionieren als literarischer Text, dass er für sich einen Mehrwert darstellt. Und ist diese Freundschaft in einer Weise beschrieben, dass sie wirklich einmal fernab der Klischees mir erzählt wird? Oder ist das nicht gerade genau diese übliche Perspektive, die man einnehmen würde auf eine so ungleiche Freundschaft? Bekommen wir hier kontraintuitive Schilderungen geliefert von dieser Konstellation? Ist dieses Buch nicht angereichert stattdessen mit unheimlich vielen Klischees von, wie sich Mächtige verhalten, wie sie diese Souveränität performen, all das? Ich würde sagen, wer doch das Manager-Magazin hin und wieder liest, der kennt doch all diese verschiedenen Macken und Mucken, die sehr reiche, sehr erfolgreiche Leute haben. Und wo ist das wirklich Interessante? Ich verstehe noch nicht mal so richtig diese Freundschaft, außer dass ich da zwei mittelalte Männer sehe, die dann zu irgendwelchen älteren Songs noch mal tanzen oder sich gegenseitig Mut machen, wenn es mal wieder in der Liebe nicht so richtig klappt. Aber auch das scheint mir nicht in irgendeiner Weise was Besonderes zu sein. Ich finde, dass der Roman fortwährend behauptet, diese Freundschaft sei so besonders. Aber er macht mir diese Besonderheit eigentlich doch gar nicht verständlich. Und er versucht dann zugleich ja noch, sich in diesem Feld der Pop-Literatur zu bewegen. Deswegen kommen ja Markennamen, Songs, all das vor. Also man will ja eigentlich diese Pop-Literatur-Welt, die man in Deutschland mit etabliert hat. Oder zumindest zu einer neuen Blüte gebracht. Es gab Jürgen Fauser und so schon früher. Aber diese will man nicht ganz verlassen. Zu der gehört aber eigentlich, dass man unpolitisch ist im Sinne von man prangert nicht das soziale Elend an. Also das war verboten. Man steht in Sylt, dringt Champagner, macht solche Dinge. Das ist die deutsche Pop-Literatur und die amerikanische macht das dann noch mal auf einem viel höheren finanziellen Niveau. Und hier jetzt aber sagt man plötzlich, ah ja, aber das ist jetzt noch mal so ein gesellschaftliches Thema, dem muss ich mich doch mal annehmen. Und das ist das Thema Machtmissbrauch und Me Too. Das andere wird ja alles ausgeblendet. Und hier würde ich einfach einhaken, dass das nicht glaubwürdig geschildert wird, dass wir also plötzlich aus einer Pop-Literaten-Perspektive heraus eine engagierte Literatur vorgespiegelt bekommen, die aber in Wahrheit dann eigentlich entweder zu Lasten der Literatur geht oder einfach so ein Preaching to the choir ist, weil jetzt gerade alle sagen würden, ja, Me Too ist schon eine wichtige Bewegung.
Also ich denke, und ich habe wenig Pop-Literatur gelesen, aber dieser Anspruch, wie du ihn beschreibst, dass man sich nicht allzu sehr in die Ungemütlichkeiten hineinbegibt, um dann naturalistisch irgendwie aufzuschreiben, wird hier absolut bestätigt mir gegeben. Ich habe es zwar nicht so gefordert, aber ich finde, dass einen der großen Vorzüge dieses Buches, dass man sich hier hunderte Seiten lang mit einer sozialen Fragestellung beschäftigt, bei der sehr viele aus den ersten Reaktionen von anderen Medienhäusern gesagt haben, wieso, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Also ist doch irgendwie, wo sie auch zu erkennen gehen, ist es bei uns auch so ein bisschen so. Also wir haben zwar jetzt nicht so den Chefredakteur, der völlig durchdreht, aber dass junge Frauen erst mal kommen und gerade im Fernsehen dann auch nach Aussehen und so weiter ihre Ernteilung bekommen. Nur das alles darzustellen, zu beschreiben, die Fragestellung nochmal geradezuziehen, nämlich es nicht allzu verwerflich und erst gar nicht zu verurteilen, dass es überhaupt zu sozialen Bändelungen kommt und zu Begegnungen und auch Sex und so weiter.
Ich finde schon, dass der Roman das eigentlich grundsätzlich in Frage stellt. Also bei dem Roman frage ich mich am Ende, ob man dann sagt, ja gut und deswegen müssen wir das jetzt so in Amerika machen, ab sofort ist jegliches Flirten im Betrieb untersagt.
Nee, also da bleibe ich ganz streng dabei. Für mich ist diese Fragestellung, wie kommt man aus dieser Beziehung wieder raus, ohne dass die organisationale Macht dann plötzlich ausspielt, was vorher eben einfach verdeckt werden konnte, weil sie sich ja beide einvernehmlich und es ist ja toll, den Brüchchen zu essen und so weiter. Also da würde ich sagen, ist er ganz sorgfältig durchgegangen und hat das…
Aber er macht doch keinen dritten Weg auf. Also das ist ja überhaupt mein ganzes Problem, wenn wir jetzt mal über den Roman als Phänomen sprechen und über diese ganzen Debatten.
Lass uns mal kurz bei der Sprache bleiben. Die Poente ist ja nun wirklich… also die müssen wir nochmal einzeln thematisieren.
Die Schlusspoente, das machen wir nochmal einzeln.
Genau. Zur Sprache. Ich habe es sehr genossen, dieses Buch zu, wie mir gesagt wurde, einem sehr wichtigen Thema und wir haben ja dann auch beim Spiegel online, nicht bei Spiegel online, sondern in der Zeit gelesen und dann eben, also bei Spiegel online oder beim Spiegel in der Fragestellung, die Stuckrad-Barres derzeit untergeworfen worden, hingeworfen worden und dann eben Böhmermann Podcast Boys Club, die ganze Zeit gehört, das ist ganz richtig recherchiert, das sind die Schicksal der Frauen und so weiter. Die Sophia ist hier, die wird uns nicht als Opfer gezeigt, sondern das ist einfach eine starke Frau, die weiß, was sie will, die liebenswürdig ist, die dank Stuckrad-Barres Sprachfähigkeiten, der eher ihr dann einfach viel unterjubelt, indem man zuerst von dieser, also diese Ich-Hazelerei am Anfang so ein bisschen spielerisch damit umgeht. Wir hören also sehr viel von dieser Sophia und sehen sie aber nicht als Opfer und man schafft es trotzdem, das Thema zu behandeln, ohne dass man mich verprellt die ganze Zeit mit. Sie haben aber ganz sauber recherchiert und hier ist auch ganz viel Blut geflossen.
Das mit Sicherheit. Mich würde aber interessieren, wie geht man dann mit den Ambivalenzen um? Also wir haben ja, hätten wir jetzt einmal tatsächlich, bis auf diese ganz kurze Passage, dass Sophia und der Ich-Erzähler auch eine Liebesgeschichte nun unterhalten, dann würde sich ja ganz viel noch mal davon ableiten, ganz viele Nuancen würden sichtbar werden in dem Zusammenspiel nicht nur der Geschlechter, sondern generell darüber, wie hierarchisch Liebe an sich vielleicht aufgebaut ist oder wie wenig hierarchisch man sie aufbauen kann. Dass das aber alles nicht passiert, sorgt bei mir dafür, dass wir jetzt so einen Entschuldigungsroman für Autor, Neubauer, Rönne und Co. haben, die sagen, ja das geht aber auch gar nicht. Und meine grundsätzliche Frage, und da sehe ich das auch als Phänomen an diesem Roman, deswegen müssen wir auch darüber sprechen, gibt es denn noch irgendwo auf der Welt eine Möglichkeit, einen dritten Weg aufzutun? Also es muss doch noch eine Alternative geben. Also entweder springt man jetzt auf jeden linksliberalen Wurken Zug auf und ist dann auch irgendwann in Selbstgerechtigkeit erstarnt und kennt keine Ambivalenz mehr und lässt keine Radikalität mehr zu oder man muss jetzt bei Julian Reichelt mitmarschieren, was mir auch keine gute Lösung scheint. Und das finde ich einfach, dass die Literatur, die ihr eigentlich Zwischenräume eröffnen kann, die es gar nicht tut, während das ein Pratt Easton Ellis macht. Und deswegen finde ich diese Geste des Pop-Literaten, der jetzt eine engagierte Literatur schreiben will, der sein Jacuzzi jetzt hier formuliert wie Emile Zola, doch sehr, sehr merkwürdig. Und ich finde in dieser Reflexion über Pratt Easton Ellis wird das sehr deutlich. Also über Pratt Easton Ellis heißt es, da lasst mich diese Passage vorlesen. Alle paar Wochen ging ich Abendessen mit dem durch Emotionen seit jeher nicht bestechlichen Pratt Easton Ellis, der sich immerfort lustig machte über dieses liberale Gegreine. Abschätzig bezeichnete er die erregt hashtaggenden Social-Media-Aktivisten als Snowflakes. Schneeflocken also, viel zu empfindlich, bei der ersten Schwierigkeit schon weggeschmolzen. Ideologie schlage neuerdings, Ästhetik in der öffentlichen Debatte und sogar in der Kunst. Das war Pratt Easton Ellis stetig wiederholte Gegenwartdiagnose. Und der stimme ich auch gerade, was die Kunst anbelangt, zu. Heute schlägt Ideologie, Ästhetik, also dass dieser Roman hochgejetzt wird zu einem Meisterwerk, zeigt ja auch, dass Ästhetik nicht mehr so wichtig ist. Aber ich setze meine Lektüre fort. Und er hasste alles daran. Er selbst hatte eigentlich das härteste Anti-Trump-Buch geschrieben. Wie wohl das nun auch schon wieder fast 30 Jahre her war. Und er hatte damals eigentlich auch kaum jemand begriffen. Eine essentielle Zutat der Charakterprägungen von Patrick Bateman in American Psycho war Trumps widerwärtige Kapitalismus-Verherrlichung und Männer-Allmacht-Schmonzette The Art of the Deal gewesen und die Konsequenz des splatterkommickhaften Frauenschlachtens und überhaupt alles in der Kapitalismus-Apokalypse, die dieser Alice-Roman Yay-Ja entwarf, war weniger surreale Fiktion gewesen, als wie heute festzustellen war, doch recht präzise Prognose. Brad Eason Alice, das Genie, hatte tatsächlich alles vorausgesehen und dass er heute nun bloß Verachtung und Hohen empfand für all jene, die höchst zufrieden damit waren, Fuß auf Stampfen darzulegen, was jetzt ja jeder sah, war also aus künstlerischer Perspektive gar nicht so unverständlich. Eben. Ich fand es trotz dem mühsam lange zuhören, mochte auch ich den Wehklagen nicht, die vor allem nach den Wahlen jetzt niemals vergaßen, sich einen Hillary-Button anzupinnen. Aber Brads Spott störte mich dann doch, das war so gemein. Vielleicht störte mich auch seine tiefgefrorene Überlegenheit. Warum denn so nihilistisch, lustig eigentlich erwartete ich womöglich, dass Brad Easton Ellis empathisch reagieren würde auf den Weltenlauf. Das war ja vollkommen lächerlich. Und das ist aber das, was er sich jetzt plötzlich selbst sagt. Ich bin jetzt mal empathisch, wo ich das vorher immer nur mit mir selbst und meinen Leiden gewesen bin. Und da muss ich sagen, da hält Brad Easton Ellis die Fahne hoch und macht weiter mit seiner unbestechlichen Gegenwartstdiagnose. Und das ist eigentlich etwas, wo dann auch wieder große Literatur raus entsteht. Und das ist hier bei Stuckrad-Barres nicht gelesen. Also für mich lesen sich die meisten Teile hier wie die Paraphasierung und Verlängerung jener Recherchen, die wir schon in der Presse lesen konnten.
Ich widerspreche. Und zwar leicht scharf. Denn es geht ja auch um mich als Leser. Dankenswerterweise. Anders als beim Boys Club, anders als bei Holger Stark nimmt Stuckrad-Barre mich als Leser irgendwie ernst. Und jetzt könnte man ja durchaus, wenn du sagst, also rundherum gibt es ja viel Recherche und hier sehen wir doch auch nichts anderes. Iris Radisch kommentiert dieses Buch in der Zeit mit dem Satz, es ist ja doch nur wieder ein Männer-Roman. Naja, nicht ganz, aber es ist ein Männer-Roman. Jagoda Marinic im Stern. Ein Autor lässt sich feiern, weil er ein MeToo-System anklagt, von dem er lange profitiert hat. Und wer hört auf die Frauen, um die es geht? Und jetzt die Frage. Ich als Mann lese das Buch eines Mannes über ein Problemsystem, in dem Frauen Opfer sind und Männer Täter. Und wo kann denn da noch Romantik und ein dritter Weg und so weiter stattfinden? Also ist das nur noch Verurteilung von, was stattfindet oder nicht? Und er hat ja manchmal, wir haben das einer angesprochen, er schreibt diese SMSen an Sophia und fand das dann selbst zu kitschig und weiß nicht genau, flirte ich jetzt gerade mit ihr. Er macht ja ganz am Anfang dieses, sie ist plötzlich immer, also die erste betroffene Frau ist immer beim Chef im Büro, sie beginnt zu daten, er macht Tische im Borchi klar und dann reflektiert er kurz, wie ihr sonstiges Dating-Leben aussieht. Sie begegnet mir Männern, die sich die ganze Zeit entschuldigen, die stolz darauf sind, dass sie zu Hause kochen, ins Fitnessstudio gehen, zur Arbeit und dann am liebsten zu Hause abhängen. Und er macht so ein Sittenbild der Männer, in dem wir dann auch wieder lesen und denken, ja aber wurde uns das nicht eingedrichtert, dass wir jetzt mal so die sanfte Seite zeigen sollen und jetzt ist es hier auch wieder falsch. Und plötzlich machen wir damit auch so ein System mit möglich, in dem dann jemand wie, ich sag jetzt Reichelt, einfach so eine, ja, also wenn du sagst, du bist schon immer gern geritten auf Pferden und du warst ja auch mal ein Mädchen, wir wissen Mädchen mögen ja Pferde, dann erzähle ich die Geschichte, wie ich durch die Wüste ritt, der Bombe entkam und als Kriegsreporter irgendwie auf dem Pferd die letzte Ausflucht nahm und fragt dann zurück, habe ich jetzt zu viel von mir erzählt? Ja und das findet sie dann wieder niedlich. Also wo sie diese ganze Gefährlichkeit und überhaupt, was Männer ja sich immer gerne andichten, aber leider nicht haben, was sie nicht auf den Tisch packen können, in so Dating-Kram, er kann das plötzlich. Und ich bin dem Autor hier wirklich sehr dankbar, dass er diese Sachen andeutet, dass es sie gibt, dass er mitreflektiert, welche Rolle die Männer als die Helfenden, sowohl als gute Freunde, als auch auf Aufdecker in solchen Geschichten machen. Aber nicht so viel, also nicht wieder nur ein Männerreflektionsgeschichte daraus macht, sondern dem einfach Stuckrad-Barre seiner Sophia, die er sich erfindet, seine sprachlichen Fähigkeiten leidt, um sie einfach erzählen zu lassen, wie es sich so anfühlt in so einem System. Und unter dieser Maßgabe ist das einfach ein wirklich sehr unterhaltsames Buch.
Ich sehe auch gar kein Problem darin, warum Männer so ein Buch nicht schreiben sollen. Und natürlich kann auch ein Mann ein MeToo-Buch schreiben. Es muss ja auch nicht jede Schriftstellerin gezwungen sein, ein MeToo-Buch zu schreiben. Sie kann sich auch mit anderen Themen beschäftigen. Also da würde ich überhaupt keine Geschlechterzuordnung machen. Ich sehe die Schwäche des Romans in der mangelnden Literarie CTAT. Denn was bekommen wir denn eigentlich hier erzählt? Den Ich-Erzähler erleben wir manchmal mit seinem Freund. Die Treffen werden immer wortkager, werden immer schwieriger. Wir erleben den Ich-Erzähler immer mal wieder, wie er Abstand von Deutschland nimmt in Château Marmont. Dort trifft er dann Hollywood-Stars oder gefallene Stars wie Rose McGowan, die entscheidend dazu beigetragen hat, dass es diese Weinstein-Enthüllungen gab. Und er bemüht sich dann auch da ein bisschen zu schildern, wie das Klima ist. Wenn gleich das doch, ich will nicht sagen oberflächlich bleibt, denn um Oberflächendarstellung geht es ja an der Pop-Literatur, sondern ich finde, dass vieles einfach so wahnsinnig abgegriffen ist, was wir hier bekommen, um nicht zu sagen abgeschmackt, dass ich immer den Eindruck habe, ja, so hätte ich es mir auch vorgestellt. Und das ist mir zu wenig dann von Literatur, wenn ich nicht mehr überrascht werde in den einzelnen Schilderungen. Dann läuft das eigentlich darauf hinaus, dass das Verhältnis zu diesem Freunde immer schlechter wird und man sich mit den Frauen solidarisiert. Und eigentlich erfahren wir dann nur von einer Zoom-Konferenz, wo sich alle mal zusammen schließen. Und dann werden solche Compliance-Verfahren in Angriff gesetzt. Aber das System an sich ist, hier kann man den Begriff mal verwenden, so resilient der Verlagstrukturen und so weiter, dass man sich da nicht draus lösen kann. Und dass damit die eigentliche Entmachtung nicht stattfindet. Aber das ist ja eine vollkommen träge Dramaturgie. Also ich denke jetzt nochmal an Precht, der sagt, ich muss jetzt nochmal so erzählen, wie das war, jung zu sein. Aber jetzt einfach nur mal so ein Roman zu erzählen, wie man jung ist. Also erfinde ich jetzt mal so einen Mörder, sage aber, den gab es wirklich. Und wir wurden damals eingesucht. Ich erzähle über diese Geschichte, wie da Körper zerstümmelt werden. Auch etwas über die Vergänglichkeit von Körpern, über diese unglaubliche Schönheit auch dieser Körper, die man bis gestern noch begehrt hat. Also man nimmt einen hohen Grad an Fiktionalisierung vor, um dann über sich auch wohl sprechen zu können und aber über noch so viel mehr. Und hier haben wir so eine Minimal-Fiktionalisierung, die uns dann leicht literarisiert und durchaus bekömmlich und unterhaltsam ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich mich gar nicht amüsiert bei der Lektüre. Uns nochmal das eigentlich jetzt mit ein bisschen mehr Fleisch, ein bisschen saftiger serviert, was wir, was ich im Podcast vermisse, du vor allem dann bei großen investigativen Recherchen vermisst. Da kann man sagen, gut, das ist jetzt mal so geleistet, aber ich erwarte mir von Literatur, und das ist jetzt wirklich nur eine literaturkritische Perspektive, die ich darauf einnehme, eigentlich mehr als das. Mehr als ein paar gute Sätze, ein paar lustige Dialoge. Denn das Problem ist vielleicht auch, was selbst geäußert wird in diesem Roman an einer Stelle. Da heißt es, wo die Dummheit regiert, ist es natürlich einfach, klüger zu sein. Also da geht es um die Konstellation in diesem Verlag und in diesem Fernsehhaus. Und da ist vielleicht ein gewisses Problem für Stuckrad-Barre. Diese Welt, die er da beschreibt, ist dann am Ende doch sehr dumm. Mit den großen, sich wichtig fühlenden Akteuren. Und es ist vielleicht sehr schwierig daraus, dann einen sehr viel klügeren Roman zu machen. Man ist natürlich ein bisschen klüger als die Sendungen, die da beschrieben werden. Aber auch nur so ein bisschen. Und das ist mir wiederum zu wenig.
Ich würde dir eigentlich grundsätzlich, und zwar gerne zustimmen. Ich würde es immer machen, außer in diesem Fall. Ich will noch kurz beschreiben. Wenn ich bei Netflix irgendwas suche, was ich mir angucke, ich will auch immer, also ich will kein Drama. Wenn da steht, das ist ein Drama, weiß ich schon. Ich will irgendwas Jenseitiges, was Außerwältliches. So ein paar Aliens oder irgendwas darf schon sein. In dem Fall fand ich es gerade gut, dass hier nicht ins Jenseitige abgewandert wurde, sondern dass nahe angerückt würde an einen Fall, der einfach da ist. Bis hin zu, dass man wirklich Wesensgleichheit erkennt und sagt, okay, das ist jetzt nicht mehr Milieustudie, das ist auch nicht mehr sprachliche Ausgestaltung eines Literaten, sondern das ist einfach mal ganz kurz Berichterstattung, was so abläuft. Darüber hinaus finde ich aber, ist es eine ganz, also wirklich wunderbare Verwendung von Sprache. Sehr viele Autoren, die seitdem dieses Literatur-Pop-Literatur-Zeug begründet wurde, versuchen entweder Sprache so zu verwenden, wie der angebliche Leser sowieso die ganze Zeit schon seine SMS schreibt und so weiter, also dass man da einfach so Bestätigungen erfährt. Ah ja, das ist, so macht man das heute. So wie man ja die Schulhofsprache einfach immer als die coole, also das Jugendwort des Jahres wird dann immer mit sehr großem Interesse der höheren Altersklassen, weil man will ja auch mal, und wenn man weiß ja, die coolen sind die jungen und so. Und es erfordert extrem viel Mut für jemanden wie Stuckrad-Barre, der nämlich totale Angst vor Kitsch hat. Und er hat das auch immer nur sehr ironisch und dann bloß kein Wort zu viel, dann destraft er das so durch, dass man denkt, jeder andere Auto hätte irgendwie fünf Seiten geschrieben und sich gefreut, cool, schon fünf gute Seiten. Er rafft das noch mal zusammen auf zwei Seiten und dann fliegt das aber wirklich nur ohne Zeitverschwendung sozusagen in mein Leserezeptionserlebnis rein. Und das finde ich einfach gut. Also in diesem Buch stecken einfach, was die Sprache angeht, sehr viel Mühe. Ich wäre verwundert, wenn das in einem Rutsch so gelingt, denn das gelingt dann nur wirklich wahnsinnig wenigen im ersten Durchlauf, so zu schreiben, wie sie wollen. Sondern das ist dann dieses ganz filigrane Nacharbeiten und immer wieder rausarbeiten, dass Arbeit drinsteckt. Also bloß nicht die Manufaktur des Textes erkennbar zu machen, sondern einfach den Leser so teilhaben lassen an dem, was eh grad passiert. Die SMS, in die man eh grad schreibt.
Das ist ein bestimmter Sound, den er kann und den er durchhält.
Genau, den finde ich aber sehr gut getroffen. Also das ist wirklich herausragend, stringent, dicht, sehr amüsant, sehr unterhaltsam.
Aber es passiert ja so gut wie nichts. Findest du das sinnvoll, dass man da, und ich habe mich endlos lange darüber informiert, dass man da versucht, irgendeine Performance zu machen, die dann aufdecken soll, was im Fernsehkonzern los ist. Und dann entscheidet man sich nochmal anders. Das ist doch wahnsinnig bemüht und mühsam. Und es ist auch da nicht in den Beschreibungen besonders originell, wie ich auch diese Chateau-Maman-Beschreibungen nicht originell finde. Also wenn ich da andere Autoren daneben lege, die amerikanische Hotels beschreiben, und ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder Alice nennen, dann ist das auf einem ganz anderen Niveau. Ich würde mal gerne wissen, wie sieht denn das Ding überhaupt aus? Ich höre von einem Pool. Wie ist der Pool? Welche Möbel? Ich würde mal gerne ein bisschen Fleisch an das Ganze da mal dran bekommen. Weil das, was ich da erfahre, da kriege ich ja mehr, wenn ich mal nach dem Hotel google. Und das finde ich einfach nicht besonders gut.
Da muss man das Mühe geben. Szenische Einstiege zu vermeiden und mir nichts zu erzählen, wer sonst noch in seinem Kaffee rührte, während er erzählte, finde ich gar nicht.
Nein, darum geht es nicht. Aber man muss schon eine Örtlichkeit konkreter machen, außer zu sagen, ja, da sind Drew Barrymore und Rose McGowan. Sondern man muss auch ein bisschen da was liefern. Und das tut dieser Roman nicht. Und er ist sich so sicher, dass er allein deshalb trägt, weil es diese Skandalgeschichte gibt, die wir alle kennen. Und wenn wir die aber einmal aus dem Gedächtnis verlieren, und das tut man ja, während man so ein Buch länger liest vielleicht mal, dann merkt man, wie schwach das Buch ist, wie sehr es eigentlich davon lebt. Auf den Schultern steht dessen, was eigentlich kritisiert wird. Und wenn wir diesen Fall nicht hätten, oder nehmen wir mal an, morgen würde herauskommen, stimmte alles nicht. Also es hat gar nichts gegeben. Das ist jetzt sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber gehen wir mal davon aus. Dann würde dieser Roman-Hilfiger in sich zerfallen, weil dann würde er nicht mehr als das funktionieren, was er eigentlich sein könnte. Denn wo man zum Beispiel darüber diskutiert, welches Wort verwenden wir, da sind die Frauen, die darüber sprechen, wie nennen wir das. Und dann kann man sich irgendwann auf Machtmissbrauch einigen. Und dann ist aber diese Frage einvernehmlich, nicht einvernehmlich. Wo beginnt das? Wo hört das auf? Und dann steht in diesem Roman einfach nur, es war ein ziemliches Durcheinander. Und hier müsste aber die Literatur kommen und nicht einfach sagen, was war ein ganzes Durcheinander, sondern Klarheit bringen. Und wenn es diese Klarheiten nicht gibt, dann die Widersprüchlichkeiten und Ambivalenzen herausarbeiten.
Also ich optiere da für Geschwindigkeit statt Klarheit.
Einfach schneller vorlesen lassen oder was?
Nee, ich will einfach, dass es schneller erzählt wird. Ich brauche vielleicht diese ganzen Erzählungen, die du dir wünscht, gerade nicht. Also vielleicht ist es auch gerade deswegen ein guter Roman für mich, weil mich die Kulisse gar nicht so sehr interessiert, sondern der Fall und wie diejenigen, die beteiligt sind, darüber denken. Ich habe mir dann auch die Frage gestellt, angenommen Sofia ist ausgedacht, alles andere wäre auch ausgedacht, würde mich der Roman noch genauso interessieren. Und ich würde ihn wahrscheinlich weniger als das Buch der Stunde empfehlen, würde aber trotzdem sagen, die Beziehung zwischen Autor und Sofia ist lesenswert. Die Geschichte drum herum mit dem Freund und dem Chefredakteur wäre etwas uninteressanter, aber die Beziehung von Sofia zum Ich-Autor finde ich, die würde es tragen.
Aber die Frauen-Einstimmen würdest du nicht mehr so gründlich rezipieren. Wir haben dieses Zoom-Gespräch einfach dokumentiert. Jede Frau bekommt mal eine Stimme und sagt dann, sein nächtliches Wein ist extrem spooky. Aber gespielt ist das nicht, so was kann man nicht spielen. Das geht ja immer ewig und richtig mit Tränen. Also die reden dann so, wie sie reden und das wird dann wiedergegeben. Ich hatte ja vorher schon jahrelang Fernseh gemacht, Top-Ausbildung, alles hatte dabei und so weiter. Sie erzählen dann immer so, wie sie da hingekommen sind und wie es dann war, was dann ihnen passiert ist mit diesem Chefredakteur. Das ist etwas, was einfach nur dokumentiert ist. Dafür hat man dann diesen Zeitartikel gehabt.
Genau. Und unter dieser Maßgabe würde ich sagen, dankenswerterweise gibt es diesen Fall in echt, sodass ich einen Anlass hatte, das Buch zu lesen. Und nun habe ich dadurch Sophia kennengelernt. Und ich finde, Sophia ist eine erwähnenswerte Person, die ich wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ein paar Mal in Einklang bringe, wenn ich über andere Bücher rede, weil man es dann immer wieder erwähnenswert fand. Das Finale. Wir sagen ausdrücklich dazu, es ist ein kleiner Spoiler. Oder vielleicht auch nicht, aber ich finde schon, es ist sozusagen... Es gibt ja eine Kapitelmarke zu unserer einen Minute, da werden wir es ja nicht mehr nennen, aber ich will trotzdem zum Finale etwas sagen.
Ja, du musst das beschreiben, was da jetzt passiert im Finale.
Also das Finale beginnt mit dieser großen Veranstaltung. Der Freund steht in seiner Funktion als Chef des Hauses auf der Bühne. Die Öffentlichkeit schaut zu. Er fragt, werde ich gut verstanden? Ist das Mikro an? Und dann fängt er an zu erklären, ja, wir müssen jetzt den Chefredakteur wieder installieren und das Compliance-Verfahren ist ins Leere gegangen. Und es ist aber wichtig, dass die Frauen sich geäußert haben und die werden das auch beachten und pipapo. Und dann fragt sich Stuckrad-Barre so, sollte der Chef ihn nicht einfach jetzt nochmal fragen, ob ihn alle verstehen? So auf innerlicher Ebene, das ist eine sehr gute Pointe. Und dann endet das Buch aber damit, dass sie an diesen Ausgangspool zurückkommen und dort erfahren, vor ihren Augen, während sie da waren, während sie mit ihren eigenen Problemen zu tun haben, hat sich was ganz ähnliches abgespielt. Und sie wurden gefragt, du hast das gar nicht gemerkt. Und die so, nee, haben wir nicht gemerkt.
Das Hotelpersonal soll unterm Machtmissbrauch gelitten haben, da soll es sogar Missbrauchsfälle gegeben haben, irgendwelche sexuellen Belästigungen. All das, was eigentlich zuvor beschrieben wurde.
Es passiert nun vor ihren Augen, aber ohne dass von irgendwem die Freundschaft für eine halbe Million im Jahr erkauft wurde, ohne dass man eine soziale Beziehung, eine Freundschaftliche zu einem Opfer aufbaut, ohne dass darüber hinaus sehr viele andere sagen, okay, dann ist das jetzt unser Ansprechpartner, wir wenden uns ihm zu, er ist ein Freigeist, er wird damit schon irgendwas machen. Wenn das alles nicht stattfindet, kriegt man von den Dramen in dieser Welt nichts mit, selbst wenn sie direkt vor einem im eigenen, in der eigenen Lebenswelt passieren. Und das ist ja sehr, mit bewusster Aussagekraft, über das eigene Buch da platziert.
Denn wir nehmen das selbstredend alles nur wahr und das ist für mich die ehrlichste Stelle in dem ganzen Buch und auch die beste Stelle. Und das ist am Schluss, das ist nicht unklug, das so zu setzen. Aber eigentlich streicht er fast das Buch damit durch. Und das ist tatsächlich eine ganz gute Geste. Denn was wir natürlich haben, ist, dass wir nur diesen Hype gerade haben. Und der Grund, warum wir darüber reden jetzt hier, ist der, dass wir die Leute kennen oder kennenlernen wollen. Wir wollen durchs Schlüsselloch blicken. Wenn wir diesen Fall lesen würden von irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen, das nicht diesen Ruf hat, dann würde uns das alles gar nicht in dieser Weise mitnehmen. Denn das ist ja auch etwas, was ich bei diesem Podcast immer deutlich machen würde. Naja, wenn da so gezeigt wird, die jungen Frauen wussten ja gar nicht, wie das da so in dem Hause vor sich geht. Überspringer kann man sich schon ganz gut informieren. Während die meisten anderen Unternehmen Blackboxen sind, da wissen wir überhaupt nicht, was da so eigentlich läuft. Und da wird es sehr schwierig, was herauszufinden, bevor man da arbeitet. Das ist beim Springer-Konzern anders. Aber dass man das hier nochmal auch auf die richtet am Ende, die laufend von solchen Vorfällen betroffen sind und die nicht die große Zeit-Story bekommen, die keinen eigenen Podcast bekommen und worüber auch Stuckrad-Barre niemals einen Roman schreiben würde, ist zumindest ein ehrliches Zugeständnis, dass wir uns hier natürlich mit sehr, sehr luxuriösen Problemen, wenn man so will, rumschreiben. Also zumindest mit Problemen, die nur wenige betreffen. Und durch diese starke Personalisierung, und das ist ja nun mal eine Vorgehensweise des Bulvares, hat man das Systemische nicht im Blick und müsste eigentlich jetzt viel mehr darüber Artikel zum Beispiel schreiben, wie kann man denn eigentlich es so sinnvoll verrechtlichen, dass noch so etwas wie Flirte am Arbeitsplatz möglich ist. Zugleich aber die Möglichkeit besteht, dass, wo klare Machtmissbräuche vorliegen, auch da bessere Verfahren in Gang gesetzt werden können. Denn da gibt es sicherlich Aufholbedarf. Und diese Fragen stellen sich aber alle dann nicht. Und das liegt aber auch daran, dass wir mit einer Medienwelt zu tun haben, wie mit einem Autor, der nur willens ist, in die Unterhosen der eigenen Peer-Group zu blicken und nicht den Blick weitet für das Grundsätzliche. Und so ist das Grundsätzliche nicht verhandelt im Miteinander der Geschlechter, in den verschiedenen Begehrlichkeiten, auch was freundschaftlich an Ambivalenzen entsteht. Denn über einen Freund weiß man sehr viel, hat ihn damit auch in gewisser Weise in der Hand. Das ist ja eine generelle Konstellation. All das würde zu sehr viel mehr literarischer Reflexionen einladen. Aber das wird nicht geleistet, weil man eine so fast comic-hafte Schilderung hat, der Ereignisse, die uns schon sehr bekannt sind. Und das ist dann am Ende ein schwacher Trost, dass die Schwäche des Romans am Ende des Romans eingestanden wird. Aber für mich macht das die 370 Seiten davor nicht gut.
Und ich werde es natürlich noch mal als die Stärke des Buches betonen, denn wir sind alle blind vor Schicksalen, die uns nicht interessieren. Und wir lernen aber in diesem Buch das Ausmaß kennen. Es sind nämlich einfach alle Frauen betroffen. Und jetzt sind wir als Leser, rutschen wir immer ein bisschen in die Rolle des Ich-Erzählers. Das Ich wird ja fast zum Ich dann in dem Moment. Wir haben also hier am Ende die Botschaft bekommen, jetzt haben wir wieder nur ein Buch darüber gelesen. Aber wir haben auch alle eine Freundin gewonnen, finde ich. Sophia, an die wir uns erinnern. Und jetzt können wir immer feststellen, allen Frauen, denen wir so begegnen, sind Sophias. Also man braucht nicht die eigene Tochter, die eigene Freundin, die eigene, was auch immer, die Betroffenheitsgeschichten aus sozusagen dem Inneren, den familiären, den freundschaftlichen Milieu erzählt. Sondern wir haben jetzt so eine Sophia etabliert, mit der einfach überall argumentiert werden kann. Und in deren Sicht hat das Buch dann doch etwas geschaffen und sich nicht nur durchgestrichen, sondern uns nur noch mal markiert, dass einfach nur das mal kurz miterleben dann nicht reicht. Und in deren Sicht finde ich das gar keine schlechte, weil sehr realistische Einschätzung, was man eigentlich mit Sprache so machen kann, nämlich genau das. So einen Leseeindruck einfach über die Zeit retten. Naja, und für alle anderen würde ich sagen, es ist nicht ganz uninteressant jetzt diesen weiteren Verlauf zu verfolgen. Springer wird jetzt eine Weile schweigen und da wird es ja auch intern dann heißen, naja, der Freund hat sich ja hier nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen, der Reichelt ist ja weg und jetzt ist eine Frau Chefredakteurin in der Bild.
Genau.
Und damit ist das Ding auch abgeschlossen.
Ich sehe ja nicht, dass das Eigentliche kritisiert wird an Bild. Nicht dieser merkwürdige Patriotismus, nicht die Xenophobie.
Aber macht er schon scharf. Also da sind schon Textstücke drin, die wirklich ins Auge gehen.
Ja, die uns zeigen, dass das sehr populistisch dazu geht. Aber nochmal, hier wird schon von einem Autor der Versuch unternommen, so zu tun, als hätte sich das alles so verstimmert. Und als hätte man vor fünf oder sieben oder acht Jahren noch ohne Weiteres einen ganz wunderbaren Arbeitgeber gehabt. Und eine hervorragende journalistische Zeitung, wenn man mit Bild gekungelt hat. Und das ist einfach nicht der Fall. Und man wird jetzt so eine Behandlungsstrategie bei der Bildzeitung fahren und dann geht das einfach so weiter. Und das ist das Verlogene. Und da frage ich mich dann schon, wenn er, du hattest das zitiert, sich die Frage stellt, rettet Hannes Jennecke die Schildkröten? Oder retten die Schildkröten Hannes Jennecke? Dann frage ich mich hier auch, rettet Stuckrad-Barre die Frauen? Oder retten die Frauenschicksale Stuckrad-Barre? Und inwieweit ist der Roman dann eher Kotau vor dem Zeitgeist? Und auch wieder vielleicht ganz typisch, denn eines war ja doch der Pop-Literatur immer gemeint, nämlich eine sehr opportunistische Haltung zum Zeitgeist, um es mal so auszudrücken. Und wenn dieser Zeitgeist sich wandelt, muss der Pop-Literat natürlich auch seinen Opportunismus anpassen, am Gegebenheit.
Na, immerhin ist das damit dann dokumentiert, dass sich der Zeitgeist jetzt wandelt.
Der Zeitgeist hat sich definitiv gewandelt. Das ist klar. Und ich glaube, auch eine Ronja von Rönne würde diese Kolumne heute vermutlich nicht mehr so schreiben. Ob sie sie noch denkt, ist eine andere Frage. Aber ob sie sie schreiben würde, da bin ich mir sicher, dass das nicht passiert.
Gut. Also empfiehlst du es zum Lesen?
Nein. Ich schon. Ich empfehle The Shards von Brad Easton Ellis. Noch einmal.
Also immer zwei Lesempfehlungen. Außer einer Buchbesprechung ist es doch gut.
Noch wach mangelt es an Literarizität. Diese Minimal-Fiktionalisierung erfüllt allein den Zweck, vor juristischen Auseinandersetzungen geschützt zu sein. Sonst aber ist der Roman vor allem das Dokument einer allgemeinen Entwicklung. Ob Comedy-Sendungen oder Dokumenta. Alles folgt jetzt journalistischen Kriterien. Und das ist wiederum derart bulvardesk, dass die Analyse dem Gefühl weichen muss. Und am Ende steht Literatur, die schwach ist und Journalismus, der uns nicht weiterhilft. Aber Stefan sieht das anders.
Ich weiß nicht, was Literarizität bedeutet und lese selten Romane. In dem Fall würde ich sagen, sehr gut, dass uns ein Autor heiß macht, weil er uns vielleicht glauben macht, es ginge hier um Springer und Co. Das ist mir aber im Nachhinein egal, denn danke Stuckrad-Barre, dass du uns deine Sophia vorgestellt hast und wir sie so ein bisschen für ein oder zwei Tage mit als Freundin haben durften. Wir lesen eine Fibel. Wir lernen also lesen.
Wir lernen lesen. Wir gehen mit dieser Fibel allerdings nicht in die Schule, sondern in den Krieg. Es ist die Kriegsfibel 2023 von Alexander Kluge im Surkampfverlag erschienen. Alexander Kluge ist uns aufgefallen in den. Letzten Monaten immer wieder mit klugen Äußerungen zum Krieg in der Ukraine. Also das Thema Krieg verhandeln, nicht in dem Sinne, dass er jetzt irgendetwas schreibt, das uns sagt, wie wir jetzt den Ukraine-Krieg beenden, sondern er reichert diese Fibel an mit Fotos und mit kurzen Texten, die Tagebuchform haben, dialogische Form haben, über den Krieg dabei vorkommen. Vor allem der Erste und der Zweite Weltkrieg. Und ein bisschen dann geht es auch um die Ukraine und um Russland der Gegenwart.
Ja, Ramde ja ganz interessant. Seine Mutter wird geboren und der Erste Weltkrieg steht noch aus. Er wird geboren im Alter, also seine Mutter ist 36, als er geboren wird. Und in der Zeit sind schon zwei Weltkriege so weit drum, also er 44 geboren, dass man dann sagt, ja, okay, dann mach nochmal eine Fiebel zu diesen beiden Kriegen. Dass es Weltkriege sind, ist ja nicht unbedeutend. Dafür, dass wir gerade diskutieren, ist es eigentlich schon Weltkrieg auf manchen Dimensionen, ja, ja. Und was ist eine Fiebel? Ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt in der Wikipedia. Also eine Fiebel ist ausdrücklich ein Leser-Lernbuch, das deswegen auch so mit Bildern arbeitet. Und Fiebel-Bibel kommt nicht von ungefähr. Also gerade zu Zeiten, als es nur die Bibel gab, als Buch hat man sich gesagt, wir brauchen aber noch eins, das mal ein bisschen sanfter daherkommt und die Kinder nicht gleich inhaltlich überfordert. Also machen wir ihnen eine Fiebel. Weil wenn Kinder Bibel aussprechen, das allererste Mal, klingt das noch wie Fiebel, weil sie das B am Wortanfang nicht richtig hinbekommen. Also haben wir es hier mit wahrscheinlich einer sehr kreativen, klugen, ausgefeilten Benennung dieses Buchs zu tun.
Weil wir den Krieg ja immer erstmal lernen müssen. Wir müssen den Krieg lesen lernen.
Lassen wir verstehen, um was es hier geht. Inhaltlich würde ich dann aber sagen, okay, wir können Alexander Kluge, wir wissen, was er beabsichtigt. Es ist tatsächlich dieses, wir werfen erstmal wahllos im Grunde Geschichten rein, die so ein bisschen illustrieren und uns dem Thema so nähern.
Sehr enigmatisch, um es auszudrücken in Worten, dass man nicht sagt, vieles ist unverständlich, was er eigentlich mit der ein oder anderen Anekdote bezweckt. Es ist nicht alles unklar, aber vieles. Und ja, man kann das, wenn man so dieses Denkgebäude von Kluge Kins, eine Art zu fragen, zu reden, dann kann man sich da einiges aufschlüsseln. Aber auch wenn da jetzt der Lektor wohl ordentlich mitgearbeitet haben soll, wie wir am Ende des Buches erfahren, so ist doch zu sagen, dass vieles ein bisschen wie eingestreut erscheint, was dann vielleicht in einem Interview gut funktioniert, was aber dann bei der Lektüre Schwierigkeiten mit sich bringt.
Wir kennen das ja von seinem Fernsehprogramm. Funktioniert ja auch so, dass sie auf Länge gezogen haben, was man so an Verwirrung noch stiften kann.
Noch ein paar Texteinblendungen, damit wirklich alles unklar wird.
Und sich dann vielleicht auch Protagonisten holt, die von sich aus schon nur Quatsch erzählen. Also wir erinnern da an Dingsder Bums. Wie heißt er? Helge Schneider. In ja verschiedener Kriegsrolle. Also er wurde Soldat verkleidet und wie auch immer. Oder Georg Schramm saß ja da auch ein paar Mal.
Vielleicht können wir mal einen Abschnitt lesen, der interessant ist. Denn du hast ja immer gesagt, Vorsicht, nicht dass irgendwann die Atombombe auf Stuttgart fällt. Und da fahren wir ganz am Anfang etwas ganz Erstaunliches. In jenen Tagen des Winters 1945 durchbrachen deutsche Panzerverbände die dünnen amerikanischen Linien in den Adennen. Wie ich später erfuhr, sollte dieser letzte Vorstoß einer zusammengefassten motorisierten Truppenmasse die Mars überschreiten und auf Antwerpen vorstoßen. Der Nachschub der Westalliierten sollte unterbrochen werden. Die dafür verwendeten Straßenkarten für die Truppe, die gesamte Logistik, stützen sich auf Unterlagen noch aus der Zeit des Blitzkrieges von 1940. Zum Zeitpunkt des Angriffs hingen die Wolken tief über den Tälern der Adennen. Und hätte dieses Wetter sich über die Weihnachtstage hinweg nicht aufgehält, hätten die amerikanischen Luftstreitkräfte das Gelingen des Vorstoßes eventuell nicht verhindern können. In solchem Fall hätte der Krieg in Europa sich um bis zu einem Dreivierteljahr verlängern können. Die Gefahr, von der wir Schüler nichts wussten, bestand darin, dass die im Sommer 1945 einsatzbereite Atombombe dann nicht in Ostasien, sondern in der Mitte des Deutschen Reiches zu Zündung gebracht worden wäre. Die Archive des Pentagon besagen, dass wäre im August 1945 der Krieg in Mitteleuropa nicht beendet gewesen, die Planung vorsah, die Atombombe auf Ludwigshafen zu werfen. Alternatives Ziel Lüneburger Heide. Göttinger Mathematiker an der Entwicklung der Bombe beteiligt, hielten das auch, um US-Truppen zu schonen, für einen geeigneten Platz.
Ich habe es mir auch rausgeschrieben.
Das Wetter.
Das Wetter war entscheidend. Und das Wetter war schon mal entscheidend. Der Nebel für Napoleon bei der Schlacht um Weimar und Jena-Weimar und so. Also in der Ansicht, Wetter ist immer noch für uns selbst in diesen, wir können alles mit KI prognostizieren und so weiter, das Wetter ist immer noch eine zufällige Sache. Und in der Ansicht sind wir hier immer noch dem Zufall ausgeliefert, denn der Krieg wird immer noch, also der Wetter ist einfach ein großer Akteur. Und Geschichtsschreiber, wie man hier sieht.
Was ich immer wieder gut finde, ist, wenn es diese kindliche Perspektive ist, die der alte Autor nochmal in sich wachruft, wenn er sagt, ich kann mit Gewissheit sagen, in keinem Moment habe ich diese in die Stadt einrückende Truppe mit den Flugzeugen, die vor drei Tagen die Stadt zerstört hatten, in Zusammenhang gebracht. Es gibt für das Beobachtungsvermögen eines 13-Jährigen keinen Allgemeinbegriff Feind. Also er beschreibt einmal die Bombenangriffe der Alliierten und sieht dann, wie sie dann kommen als Befeier. Und er bringt das aber überhaupt nicht zusammen, sondern er hat diese Kategorie feindlich, was uns auch wieder nahelegen soll, wie irre eigentlich diese grundsätzliche Kategorie Feind ist. Also da hat das Buch seine starken Momente.
Krieg ist Krieg für sich. Das betont er hier wieder. Das haben wir ja auch schon thematisiert in seinem Gespräch da auch. Und er hat hier noch ein Bild, weil du die kindliche Perspektive ansprichst, die ich finde, fand ich ganz interessant. Er fragt sich nicht, wofür sollen meine Söhne kämpfen, sondern er erklärt nochmal, wofür seine Mutter gekämpft hat. Und sagt dann, für Werte hätte sie nie gekämpft, fürs Überleben ihrer Kinder schon. Also selbst Frauen, die zu dieser Zeit gar nicht als Soldaten in Betracht kamen, hätten oder und haben noch Kampfeswille gefunden. Aber, und das ist eben auch so, wie das Wetter so zufällig da reinstreut in so ein Geschehen, eben auch es sind nicht die großen Hitlerreden oder die Aufwiegelungen oder der Volksempfänger, der nochmal die Botschaft verkündet, jetzt ist aber für das Vaterland loszuziehen, sondern es ist der kleine Rachefeldzug oder eben die Abwendung von Gefahr für das unmittelbare familiäre Leben. Und so gilt das auch heute noch. Man kämpft in der Ukraine, wird man irgendwo an die Front gekämpft und fast, ich will es ausdrücklich und vorsichtig und in Anführungszeichen, aber ich will nur auf so eine kleine Soziologie mal hinweisen, die sich dann, wie soll man sagen, zusammenbinden lässt auf die Idee von du schickst als Befehlshaber eine kleine Kompanie in den Krieg und wartest bis der erste von denen erschossen wird, weil dann der Rachefeldzug der anderen beginnt und das den Krieg am Laufen erhält. Es ist nicht deine Rede, die du vorher an alle Lebenden hältst, sondern sobald da Rache für den toten Kameraden ausgelebt wird, beginnt diese Kriegsdynamik, die dann dieses Eigenleben, das Eigenrecht des Krieges hat, die Alexander Kluge da immer wieder so betont. Und er macht als fast Widersatz dazu nochmal deutlich, die Gefahren des Krieges beginnen mit der Planung. Planen Großmächte erst mal, sind sie kaum noch aufzuhalten. Wenn wir also jetzt diese ständige Thematisierung sehen von China, der neue Klassenfeind, der systemische Rivale, wird irgendwann angreifen, wir müssen uns auf die schießende Auseinandersetzung einstellen. Also Bütikofer, der da gar keine Nuancen mehr zulässt, oder Norbert Röttgen, dann ist das schon der Krieg. Also dann zählt das alles schon mit rein, dann sind das schon die Vorläufer und dann kann man im Nachhinein immer noch sagen, aber zuerst geschossen hat. Aber da findet einfach sehr viel drum herum und vorher statt. Und das nimmt für uns ja nochmal den Blick. Das ist in der Hinsicht sehr lehrreich und anscheinend auch sehr wichtig.
Da heißt es, im Nachlass eines russischen Admirals ist ein Memorandum zu finden, in dem es heißt, dass falls die russische Führung durch einen Enthauptungsschlag ausgelöscht und die russischen Abschusszentren für Raketenzulande zerstört wären, dennoch das letzte in den Tiefen des Ozeans verborgene U-Boot einer geheimen Sonderklasse mit einer finalen Serie von nuklearen Raketen die wichtigsten Metropolen der USA zerstören werde. Wenn das aber im Hirn des Entscheiders über den Erstschlag nicht im rechten Moment präsent sei, helfe solches Endergebnis niemandem. Also man hat hier nochmal den Kalten Krieg und die Bedrohung. Und wie also langfristig geplant wird und wie diese langfristige Planung auch dann nur Sinn ergibt, also dass man es nicht tun muss, wenn die Gegenseite wiederum weiß, ach so, wenn wir jetzt diesen Schlag machen, dann würden die auf jeden Fall dieses U-Boot in Gang setzen. Und das wäre ein Problem dann für uns ganz schnell geworden. Also diese kleinen Momente, diese Aha-Erlebnisse bei der Lektion, finde ich doch immer sehr erstaunlich, weil man glaubt ja immer, jetzt so viel zu wissen, wenn wir über den Krieg reden, so sind ja die Talkshows aufgebaut. Aber hier merken wir dann immer so, ah ja, das ist dann am Ende ausschlaggebend gewesen.
Man muss so ein bisschen inspirativ lesen. Und ich habe mir auch zwei Sachen noch rausgeschrieben. Zum einen die Panzerung, also gar nicht so der Panzer als Gefährt, sondern die Panzerung. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Wenn ich jetzt mir ein Panzer überstülpe, ziehe ich damit auch gleichzeitig eine Zielscheibe auf. Habe ich mir mal so notiert. Umso mehr Panzerung auf der einen, umso mehr Resilienz auf der einen, umso mehr Kreativität im Krieg auf der anderen. Also wir haben da immer eine versuchte Augenhöhe, immer so eine Waffen-Gleichheit, die angestrebt wird. Das macht also den Krieg nur kompliziert. Das allerdings ist wieder ein Problem der Sache selbst. Krieg ist ein Meister der Paradoxien. Er entzieht sich einfach allen, vor allem allen Erklärungen. Man kann ihn nur noch einfach ausleben. Vielleicht im Rückblick kann der Historiker noch mal irgendwas über Abläufe sagen, aber man ist erstmal gefangen im Geschehen. Und das Gegenteil von Krieg ist nicht Frieden, sondern Antikrieg. Also auch während Krieg nicht läuft, läuft er doch immer mit, weil man ihn nämlich kontinuierlich verhindern muss. Also Antikrieg ist kontinuierliche Arbeit. Und das ist natürlich eine Aufgabenstellung, die uns hier der 150-jährige Alexander Kluge allen nochmal mitgibt. Es gibt keinen Frieden, es gibt nur Antikrieg. Es ist quasi immer Krieg. Aber manchmal ist man noch erfolgreich mit der Verhinderung des Auslebens.
Ja, man liest das so und sieht, wie intelligent man eigentlich sein muss, um diese Dummheiten zu unterlassen. Und man erlebt einen medialen Diskurs, der ein ganz anderer ist. Es ist sicherlich kein besonders gelungenes Buch, dass man jetzt sagen kann, das muss man unbedingt gelesen haben. Aber diese wenigen Momente der völligen Klarheit darüber, wie unklar eigentlich die Situation im Krieg ist, wie das Wetter entscheidend ist oder wie sich die Zeit zu krümmen scheint, wie man eigentlich es mit Chimären zu tun hat, da gibt es eine ganz wunderbare Passage. In diesem Buch wird dann doch sehr ersichtlich, was man eigentlich daran hat an einem Autor, der einen solchen Blick auf das Ganze nimmt. Und der ja jetzt nicht einfach nur als Poet draufblickt, sondern der auch beispielsweise Herfried Münkler zitiert. Aber auch ganz andere Töne von Herfried Münkler, als man die sonst lauter so kannte. Und er zeigt auch dann selbst noch bei einem Bismarck, was interessant ist. Also es gibt ja diese berühmte Stelle in Don Carlos von Schiller, dass Schiller versucht, diesen König, der ein schlimmer Dispote eigentlich ist, der Gedankenfreiheit eben nicht gestatten will, wie man dem aber doch auch etwas Menschliches abbringt. Das ist ja die Frage, wie schafft man eine vielschichtige Figur? Also das, was ich jetzt eben kritisiert habe an Stuckrad-Barre, dass zum Beispiel der Chefredakteur nicht besonders vielschichtig erscheint. Oder vielleicht auch der Freund nicht. Und Schiller macht das dann mit einem Satz, nämlich es gibt eine Szene, da kommt dann das Personal raus und sagt, der König hat geweint. Und damit ist plötzlich nochmal ein ganz anderes Bild auf den König geworfen. Und wir machen hier jetzt einen Sprung von Schiller zu Kluge, nämlich, da gibt es einen kurzen Abschnitt, der heißt, wie Bismarck weinte, weil er keine Siegesparade wollte. Und folgendes ist da zu lesen. Wenn ich an die Redewendung Frieden schließen denke, erzählte mein Vater, ein Arzt sehe ich vor mir, einen Mann, dem eiserne Härte zugesprochen wurde, den Grafen Bismarck. Noch ist er kein Fürst, kein Reichskanzler. Er sitzt in der Abenddämmerung in einer Stube eines Schlosses südlich von Königgretz. So hieß das Schlachtfeld des vorherigen Tages in preußischer Version. Die österreichische Armee ist besiegt. Dieser Mann, dem eine gewisse Versteinerung nachgesagt wird, ist ein beweglicher und bewegter Geist. Er fühlt sich verantwortlich. Er weint. Ihm rinnen die Tränen aus beiden Augen. Es ist salzhaltige Flüssigkeit, ursprünglich abstammend aus Organen, von Seetieren, den Vorfahren auch von preußischen Naturen. Das ist mindestens fünf Millionen Jahre her. Aus so ferner Zeit hat sich die Fähigkeit erhalten, Versteinertes zu verflüssigen, Salz aus dem Inneren von Seele und Körper nach außen zu treiben. Der Grund für die Tränen, der König von Preußen, beharrt darauf, nach der siegreichen Schlacht nach Wien zu marschieren. Dort will er eine Siegesparade veranstalten. Vom Darm an aufwärts hat Bismarck ein bewegtes Körperleben und darüber erhebt sich eine Seele, die weiß, wenn wir triumphieren, verlängern wir den Krieg ins Unendliche. Das ist am Ende des Buches. Das gibt er uns jetzt mit. Damit gehen wir hinaus. Er hat mit seiner Trauerarbeit in der Dämmerstunde künftige Kriege nicht verhindern können. Noch am 30. April 1945 hängt sein Porträt im Bunker des Reichskanzlers, in dem Hitler sich umbringt. Es wird dann aus dem Rahmen herausgeschnitten, eingerollt und durch die Linien der Russen in den Westen gerettet. Das Porträt hatte durch seine Präsenz in der Reichskanzlei den Kriegsausbruch von 1939 nicht verhindert. Jetzt aber 1866 behindert das weinerlich verzerrte große Gesicht, weil es durch seine Offenheit, seine Waffenlosigkeit, den König erschüttert, dessen Absicht, auf seinem Paradewunsch zu bestehen. Keine Parade, keine Fortsetzung des Krieges. So etwas ist Heilkunst. Dabei war dieser preußische Aristokrat kein Arzt. Das kann man sich vielleicht schon mal merken, egal wie dieser aktuelle Krieg ausgeht, von dem die einen sagen, die Ukrainer müssen ihn gewinnen, die anderen sagen, sie dürfen ihn nicht verlieren. Wie auch immer er ausgeht, man sollte sich die Tränen Bismarcks vor Augen führen. Sprechen wir jetzt über die veröffentlichte Meinung. Das ist die Studie, die Harald Welzer und Leo Keller vorlegen. Wir haben ausführlich über das Buch von Precht und Welzer gesprochen, wie ich finde, sehr, sehr differenziert. Was aber damals nicht vorhanden war, war eine große empirische Studie. Die lief ja noch oder natürlich muss auch weiter empiriebetrieben werden. Jetzt hat man hier von Beginn des Ukraine-Krieges bis zum Januar 23 einmal ausgewertet, wie die Medien und auch interessant wie Twitter berichtet haben, bzw. was die hauptsächlich gehörten Stimmen waren. Es ist ganz erstaunlich, wie diese Studie beginnt, denn sie hat auch etwas Essayistisches. Auf dem Höhepunkt der Debatte um die Lieferung von Kampfpanzern in die Ukraine bekam einer der beiden Autoren dieses Textes eine E-Mail aus der Redaktion der Welt mit der Bitte, sich zum gerade veröffentlichten ARD-Deutschland-Trend zu äußern. Dort ging es um die Meinung der Bevölkerung zur Lieferung von Kampfpanzern. Interessant schien dem Absender, dass 52 Prozent der jüngeren Deutschen dagegen waren, womit sie die relativ stärkste Gruppe der Ablehnenden stellten. Dieser Sachverhalt zog die folgende journalistischen Fragen nach sich, die man zu beantworten bat. Also wir können uns ja jetzt denken, dass vermutlich Welzer diese Frage bekam und nicht Leo Keller. Wie sollte die Konsequenz aus diesem Dissens zwischen Jungen und Alten sein? Muss die Politik, müssen Medien den Jüngeren nur besser erklären, warum Leopard-Lieferungen nötig sind? Da schreiben dann die Studienautoren unsche, erkennt man an diesem Beispiel, dass der Absender so wenig Zweifel an der Notwendigkeit der Lieferung von Kampfpanzern in die Ukraine hekte, dass ihm völlig aus dem Blick geraten war, dass der journalistische Auftrag eigentlich nicht darin liegt, anderen Menschen zu erklären, warum sie falscher Meinung sind. Allerdings, und davon wird in diesem Text noch die Rede sein, lässt sich im deutschen politischen Journalismus eine solche Einhelligkeit den Fragen des Ukraine-Krieges beobachten, als sei tatsächlich die Funktion des Journalismus für die moderne demokratische Gesellschaft für richtig Erkanntes unter das Volk zu bringen. Und dass dieses es gleichfalls als richtig erkennt. Diese Konstellation haben wir vorgefunden. Und das ist ja etwas, was wiederkehrend. Wie können wir das den Leuten nochmal erklären? Statt mal zu akzeptieren, dass die Leute vielleicht andere Meinungen haben. Sie sprechen dann über diese Diskrepanz, die ja auch im Buch aufgemacht wird zwischen öffentlicher und veröffentlichter Meinung. Sie zeigen auch, der Journalismus hat eine besondere Aufgabe. Schon deshalb, weil ja im Parlament fast nur Akademiker sitzen. Es gibt nur sechs Prozent überhaupt im Parlament, die eine abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung als höchsten Bildungsabschluss angeben. Und hier wäre eigentlich der Journalismus dazu da, auch eine Korrektur zu dieser Missrepräsentanz darzustellen. Und tatsächlich aber dominiert, wie sie es nennen, eine Regierungsflieger-Journalismus. Und sie sprechen dann auch davon, dass die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie so funktioniert, dass man immer darauf schaut, was ist skandalisierbar, was hat einen großen, sie zitieren hier Roger Wilmsen, Wallungswert. Das finde ich ist ein sehr schönes Wort. Und da heißt es, da schreibt man probaterweise auch Ministerinnen aus dem Amt. Ja, Anne Spiegel, können wir uns da in Erinnerung rufen. Oder heizt Konflikte zwischen Koalitionären so auf, dass sie womöglich zu Regierungskrisen führen, über die man dann wiederum auf ganz intimer Sicht berichten kann.
Die müssen sich alle verstehen, ansonsten kann man nicht regieren.
Natürlich, ja. Und damit wird auch mehr und mehr der politische Journalist zum politischen Akteur. Und wir führen jetzt mal eine kleine Erläuterung dazu, was eigentlich jetzt hier das Problem ist, neben dieser starken Personalisierung und all dem. Es gibt eine Komplexitätsreduktion, sagen die Autoren, die nur noch pro-Kontra-Haltungen kennt. Und diese pro-Kontra-Haltungen müssen dann auch bei jeder Person, die sich äußert abgefragt werden, wir erinnern uns an diese Fragen. Muss die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnen? Und wenn dann jemand sagt, ja, die Ukraine darf den Krieg nicht verlieren, ja, man muss sie ihnen auch gewinnen. Also man muss da ganz klar Farbe bekennen. Wie sind sie jetzt vorgegangen? Also sie haben sich die Leitmedien angesehen von FAZ über Bild, Spiegel und so weiter. Sie haben sich auch Tagesschau, Heute-Journal, so etwas angesehen, ZDF Heute. Das ist etwas, was sicherlich wichtig ist. Sie beziehen sich auch auf diese Studie da von Mainz, die es ja schon gab, die ja auch schon gezeigt hat, dass es doch eine sehr einseitige Berichterstattung gab. Aber sie wollen jetzt nicht einfach nur nochmal gucken, wie haben die Leitmedien berichtet. Das ist ja diese Studie, die damals von der Otto Brenner Stiftung veröffentlicht wurde, die sehr eigenartig übrigens rezipiert wurde von Negemeyer und Co., als würde diese Studie dezidiert Welzer und Precht widerlegen. Ich habe das jedenfalls sehr anders gelesen. Naja, hier ist man also so vorgegangen, dass man sich vor allem quantitativ gedacht hat, müssen wir vorgehen. Insgesamt hat man 107.000 Texte ausgewertet. Man hat zusätzlich 1,1 Millionen Beiträge aus 140 Regionalzeitungen ausgewertet und 13,5 Millionen Twitter-Beiträge.
Wie macht man sowas denn heute zu teilen?
Ja, das ist die richtige Frage. Natürlich mit KI wird dann genauer beschrieben. Kann man alles nachlesen. Nicht mit Vogue GPT, da gibt es andere Software. Die Zeit wird übrigens nicht erfasst, weil die das Crawlen nicht ermöglicht, gestattet erlaubt. Aber alle anderen Leitmedien sind drin. Zeitleser könnte jetzt immer sagen, bei uns war aber alles anders. Ist ja auch nicht in der Studie erfasst. Man hat also gefragt, wie oft wurde die Forderung nach Kampfpanzerlieferung thematisch? Wie oft wurden Eskalationspotenziale thematisch? Welche Parteien wurden im Zusammenhang mit dem Ukraine-Krieg? Wie oft genannt? Welche Experten wurden genannt? Man muss hier schon mal gleich sagen, das ist also eine Studie, die jetzt hier auf 25 Seiten zusammengefasst ist. Die Sache ist, wir haben jetzt nicht eine Tiefenanalyse, wie waren genau die Beiträge oder welche Beiträge waren eher so, eher so. Man hat das so ein bisschen versucht darzustellen, aber natürlich ist das bei so einem Konvolut dann sehr, sehr schwer herzustellen, beziehungsweise das wäre dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal eine andere Studie. Wir bekommen dann hier aufgezeigt, wer am meisten zitiert wurde. Da geht es dann beispielsweise um Strack Zimmermann. Da heißt es im Kontext des Ukraine-Krieges immerhin ein Ereignis mit globaler Wahrnehmung und Wirkung. Passiert es, dass einer FDP-Abgeordneten mehr mediale Aufmerksamkeit zuteil wird, als etwa den Regierungschefs so kleiner Länder wie Indien, Brasilien oder Südafrika. Das wird dann mal aufgezeigt. Also Strack Zimmermann kam in diesen Medien häufiger vor, als die Regierungschefs von Brasilien, Modi und Südafrika zusammen. Und wenn wir jetzt mal in uns gehen, dann wissen wir vielleicht auch gerade nicht, wie der südafrikanische Präsident heißt. Ich musste es auch dann in dieser Studie nachvollziehen, dass er Cyril Ramaphosa ist. Aber das zeigt natürlich auch, wie unterrepräsentiert das alles ist. Das heißt, wir reden jetzt hier von Nennungen. Also wir reden gar nicht von Interviews, sondern nur von Nennungen. Und wir sehen da schon mal das Problem, dass wir eine sehr deutsche Sicht auf diesen Konflikt haben. Und es gibt dann einen Bericht des European Council on Foreign Relations, der hier zitiert wird. Da heißt es im Resümee, das Paradox am Krieg in der Ukraine ist, dass der Westen zugleich geeinter und weniger einflussreich in der Welt ist als je zuvor. Aber daraus, sagen dann die Studienautoren, folgt nicht, dass man also jetzt mal besonders sich anschickt, in die Welt zu blicken. Wie wird denn sonst noch darüber gedacht? Sondern man verweist lieber die ganze Zeit auf die UN-Resolution. Eine Mehrheit der Staaten ist doch auch gegen diesen Krieg. Und dann reicht das. Wenn man aber eben schaut, wo sind denn die meisten Menschen, dann sind das die Länder, die eben nicht dagegen gestimmt haben oder die sich enthalten haben. Und dann wird die Perspektive schon eine andere. Es heißt hier, bemerkenswert ist jedenfalls, dass weder die Abfuhr, die der brasilianische Präsident Lula dem deutschen Bundeskanzler bei dessen Suchen nach Unterstützung für die Ukraine erteilte, noch etwa Diskussionsbeiträge aus den USA, Asien, Afrika oder Indien im deutschen politischen Journalismus eine prominente Rolle spielen. Das machen sie also immer wieder. Wie können sie in dieser Studie vergleichen? Wie kommen Stimmen aus dem Ausland vor? Und wie werden auch Studien aus dem Ausland zitiert?
Wenn man das qualitativ nochmal nacharbeitet, also klar, die haben jetzt das Buch im Vorfeld, warum sollten sie jetzt nochmal da so rein, aber gerade bei dieser Lula-Äußerung in China, wo Lula irgendwie einen Spruch machte, der, wenn man ihn las, einfach hieß, auch die Europäer sollen mal und so weiter und irgendwie gleiche Werte. Und es aber eine tagesschau.de Überschrift gab, die einfach nur verkürzte, Lula ruft Russland zufrieden auf. Was aber sich inhaltlich wirklich gar nicht gedeckt hat. Und wenn ich jetzt diese Zahlen höre, die da in dieser Studie drinstecken, heißt das ja, von den Leuten hören wir wenig und dann auch noch verkürzt und so ein bisschen verändert, sagen wir mal so neutral. Während ja Strack Zimmermann nicht nur mit ihrer Haltung, sondern auch der hohen Redundanz, mit der das ja immer wieder betont wird, auch noch mal eine qualitative Bedeutung eigentlich beizumessen ist. Und an sich hat man jetzt diese Zahlen, wie du sie vorstellst, und müsste dann immer noch mal eigentlich noch diese Katalysatorfunktion, dieser Redundanz oder die Veränderung der wenig Nachrichten, noch mal mit drauf addieren. Also man hat dann noch mal so ein paar Faktoren, die das noch verschärfen, dieses Problem.
Sie nennen dann fünf Experten, die wichtig sind zum Beispiel für Financial Times oder Guardian, unter anderem auch Gideon Rachmann, den wir hier mal besprochen haben, oder Ivan Krastev. Und dann gucken sie, kommen diese Intellektuellen, die im Ausland sehr wichtig sind in dem Diskurs über den Krieg, wie kommen die eigentlich hier in Deutschland vor? Und da heißt es, über den gesamten Untersuchungszeitraum, also knapp ein Jahr hinweg, finden sich in den deutschen Leitmedien ganze 20 Texte, in denen diese Autoren erwähnt werden oder die von ihnen verfasst wurden. Also da hat es eigentlich mit wichtigen Stimmen zu tun, und da werden ja noch viele weitere zu nennen. Die kommen aber sonst eigentlich gar nicht vor. Wenn man diese Menge mit jener der deutschen Expertinnen und Experten, die in den Medien mit ihren Expertisen zum Ukraine-Krieg auftreten, vergleicht, rangiert die komplette Gruppe der genannten auf Platz 34 in allen Medien-Channels. In den Leitmedien kommt sie immerhin auf Platz 28. Es ist nun ganz interessant, dass einige zu völlig unverhoffter Promenenz kommen, wie sie hier schreiben, zum Beispiel Carlo Massalla, der sowohl absolut als auch relativ noch wie kein anderer Form als Experte vorkommt, obwohl der vorher in dem Sinne keine besondere Rolle gespielt hat. Noch dramatischer fällt der Vergleich der fünf mit den Nennungen der waffenfordernden Expertinnen und Experten aus. Also als da sind Massalla, Claudia Mayor etc. Da ist die internationale Perspektive so winzig, dass man sie kaum noch sehen kann. Also sie zeigen dann mal das im Verhältnis zu den anderen. Da spielt es dann gar keine Rolle mehr. Was ist also die Diagnose? Es gibt eine Provinzialisierung der Betrachtung. Und das finde ich ist interessant. Und das haben wir auch immer mal wieder im Podcast angesprochen. Ich glaube, da müssen wir viel mehr noch den Blick drauf legen generell. Alles wird eigentlich globaler, vernetzter. Vom was in Wuhan passiert ist plötzlich für die ganze Welt entscheidend. Ganz viele Konzernenentscheidungen. Alles ist wahnsinnig global. Und zugleich wird unser Blick immer provenzieller.
Dabei ist nichts so global gerade wie dieser Krieg.
Und dabei wird die ganze Zeit Diversity in den Medien eingefordert. Aber Diversity meint ja, wie wir wissen, oft Journalisten mit Migrationshintergrund sind dann beliebt, wenn sie exakt diese Positionen wie Jan Fleischhauer haben.
Da passt ja auch diese Dramatisierung, dass man sich dann zwischendurch fragt, warum sind die Ostdeutschen so anders? Und ja, also bis zu den Ostdeutschen hat der Blick gereicht. Die müssen doch auch zu uns und so. Und die anderen hat man erst gar nicht thematisiert.
Es gibt eine Studie, die ich auch nicht kannte, von Mark Engelhardt. Die hat den Titel das Verblassen der Welt. Die ist aus dem letzten Jahr. Und da geht es schon darum, wie das Ausland im politischen Journalismus verschwindet. Da heißt es, so wurde 100.000 Mal in den vergangenen zehn Jahren über ganze acht Staaten in 23 deutschen Zeitungen berichtet. Über 34 Staaten hingegen weniger als 50 Mal. Über viele überhaupt nicht. Das heißt, wer diese zehn Staaten da sind, diese acht Staaten sind, können wir uns leicht vorstellen. Das wird Frankreich sein, das wird Großbritannien sein, USA.
Aber selbst da, am England, um uns drüber lustig zu machen, Frankreich, um unsere Unverständnisse zu erklären, und Amerika, die hat sich auch schon von uns distanziert.
Das Ausland verschwindet immer mehr aus unserer Perspektive, obwohl wir immer globaler sind. Unter den politischen Akteuren, klar, wer wird genannt? Der Bundeskanzler, dann Habeck, dann Baerbock, dann kommt Christian Lindner, dann Lamprecht und dann nachher Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz. Das ist erstmal nicht verwunderlich. Es geht hier immer nur um Nennungen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht besonders spezifisch. Da gibt es auch dann einen gewissen Unterschied zu Twitter. Da ist zum Beispiel dann Baerbock auf Platz zwei. Und Scholz liegt noch viel deutlicher an der Spitze. Wir wissen um diese ganzen Debatten, warum liefert Scholz nicht? Ist Scholz überhaupt noch Kanzler? Hallo Scholz, bist du noch da? Also die werten ja hier nur quantitativ aus. Ich weiß doch gar nicht, wie man sowas dann qualitativ mit einer solchen Anzahl von Tweets machen sollte. Dann heißt es, Marie-Agnestrak Zimmermann von der FDP hat sich wie schon in den Vormonaten auch im Panzerdiskurs im Januar 23 mit 19 Prozent Erwähnung in allen Leitmedien-Artikel den eindeutigen Spitzenplatz erobert. Mit weitem Abstand gefolgt vom grünen Anton Hofreiter. Und dann kommt, abgeschlagen mit 6,7 Prozent auf Platz drei, Rolf Mützenich. Bei Twitter ist es anders. Da dominieren zwei Namen, Strack Zimmermann und Wagenknecht. Weiß man ja auch, diese ganzen Debatten, einmal wieder ein Wagenknecht aufsitzt und dann geht Strack Zimmermann wieder los. Und so funktioniert das dann. Also es ist ein völlig irres Bild. Das heißt, hier auf Twitter zeigt sich ein frappierend anderes Bild. Da liegt die AfD dann auch über den ganzen Zeitraum bei diesem Diskurs an zweiter Stelle zwischen SPD und Grün, weil das ja dann immer von beiden Seiten enorm entfacht wird. Deswegen sage ich ja immer nicht über die Stöckchen springen, die so hingehalten werden. Es heißt hier, die Berichterstattung zu einem global wirksamen Ereignis wie dem Ukrainekrieg fällt in Deutschland unfassbar provinziell und geradezu fahrlässig monoperspektivisch aus. Wozu übrigens passt, dass die meisten Ereignisse auf dem Schlachtfeld vom ominösen britischen Geheimdienst berichtet werden? Man fragt sich, ob die deutschen Geheimdienste wie der deutsche politische Journalismus vor allem an Deutschland interessiert sind. Oder was machen die eigentlich sonst, wird hier gefragt. Naja, das ist jedenfalls ein wichtiges Ergebnis dieser Studie. Diese mediale Debatte der Panzer wird dann nochmal genauer aufgelistet. Dabei stieg auch die Zahl der negativen Attributierungen bei Scholz. Also man hat ja Scholz immer nachgesagt zu zögern. Aber jetzt bei dieser Panzerfrage 23, ich habe das ja eben auf meinem Podcast damals verhandelt, hat man wirklich dann diesen Zögerervorwurf immer mehr verstärkt. Dann mit entsprechenden Begriffen wird hier geschrieben. Und so groß war dann auch diese Einheitlichkeit, diese Einhelligkeit nicht mehr gewesen, während die Weltkriegsgefahr ausgeblendet wird. Sie ist zwar in der Bevölkerung durchaus da. Und hier befürchten dann bei manchen Umfragen 48 Prozent die Gefahr der Entgrenzung. Aber das ist etwas, was so dann medial nicht widergespiegelt ist. Und insofern bestätigt sich hier ein Teil der Thesen, die in die vierte Macht angestellt werden. Sicherlich kann man jetzt hier an der Studie auch sagen, da fehlt einiges. Und ich hätte eigentlich gerne mal so eine quantitative Studie zu den Talkshows. Das wäre dann zu leisten. Oder vielleicht kann auch Chet Chippity da uns Twitter nochmal genauer aufschlüsseln. Das muss man, glaube ich, sehr klug prompten, aber es wäre möglich. Jedenfalls zeigt es doch, dass die Stoßrichtung an sich nicht falsch war von Precht und Welzer.
Sowieso nicht. Man hat ja schon eine Legitimation, nachträgliche Legitimierung der Argumentation dadurch gehabt, dass die Journalisten sich so angegriffen gefühlt haben. Gut, düster, aber wahr. Und so ist auch. Bisschen nimmt das Wegducken seiner eigenen Argumentation die, naja gut, Argumentation, also er hat einen Text geschrieben, in dem keine Argumente drinstecken. Er hat es auf Englisch getan und in der Financial Times und hinter einer Paywall. Man hat uns also eigentlich im Unklaren lassen wollen, gleichzeitig aber da, wo niemals ein deutscher Journalist hinguckt, im Ausland eine Bombe platzieren, so eine Tretmine einfach. Und wir lesen hier trotzdem, also in der Financial Times, eine Überschrift. Wir brauchen eine strengere EU-Fiskalpolitik und keine lockerere. Christian Lindner beginnt und ich lese die aus der, ich habe sie mir mal von Deep L auf Deutsch übersetzen lassen. Ich fand das jetzt so, ich habe es später bei dem New York Times Text auch gemacht. Ist ganz angenehm für uns alle. Solide öffentliche Finanzen sind eine Voraussetzung für das Wirtschaftswachstum in der EU. Wir müssen sicherstellen, also er beginnt schon mit einer Pointe gleich am Anfang, wir müssen sicherstellen, dass wir über fiskalische Puffer für mögliche zukünftige Krisen verfügen. Was ist ein fiskalischer Puffer? Wenn Schulden machen ausgeschlossen ist, ein Geldberg, irgendwas, was wir angespart haben. Also er möchte gerne die nächste, was auch immer, Corona, Kriegskrise, die wir haben, nicht mehr mit Schulden finanzieren, sondern mit einem fiskalischen Puffer. Also er glaubt, wir legen jetzt schon mal irgendwo etwas zurück, was man dann benutzen kann.
Vielleicht seine Aktienrente.
Vielleicht seine Aktienrente, die einzigen Schulden, die jetzt uns zugesteht. Also das ist wirklich ganz verrückt. Nun gut, der europäische Stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt. Wir erinnern uns, Maastricht Kriterien 92, also im Gründungsvertrag der EU, festgeschrieben, hat die in ihn gesetzten Hoffnungen bisher nicht ausreichend erfüllt. Da also sein Ansatz, wir müssen das jetzt strenger machen, wir brauchen klare fiskalische Regeln, fiskalpolitische Regeln, die solide öffentliche Finanzen in der EU sicherstellen. Wir wissen, was solide öffentliche Finanzen heißt. Das Geld muss zusammengehalten werden, niemand darf was bekommen. Diese Durchsetzung der Regeln, die er dann anschärfen will, müssen wir noch verbessern. Derzeit diskutieren wir über die künftige Ausgestaltung der gemeinsamen europäischen finanzpolitischen Rahmens. Ja, machen wir das. In Deutschland diskutieren wir das irgendwie nicht. Lindner macht das auf englischem Boden mit den Leuten unter sich. Die deutsche Bevölkerung wird hier nicht so richtig dran beteiligt. Das ist so mein Eindruck. Er schreibt, unser Ziel, also seins, ist es, den Stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt zu stärken und nicht ihn zu schwächen. Wir brauchen mehr Rechenschaftspflicht. Die Europäische Kommission hat im November erste Ideen für eine mögliche Reform vorgestellt. Diese Ideen definieren jedoch nicht ausreichend klare Anforderungen, um Defizite und Schuldenquoten zu reduzieren oder auf einem ausreichend niedrigen Niveau zu halten. Also wer hohe Schuldenberge hat, muss sie abtragen. Wer niedriger hat, muss dabei bleiben.
Fortsetzung der alten Austeritätspolitik.
Der letzten 20 Jahre. Oder sagen wir mal so grob seit 2008. Was ja bedeutete Verdopplung der Kindersterblichkeit in Griechenland. 30 Prozent Jugendarbeitslosigkeit in Italien, Spanien und so weiter. Er möchte eine sogenannte Schuldentragfähigkeitsanalyse. Und diese Analysen sollen dann auf Schuldenabbau, heuristisch getrimmt werden. Er möchte jedenfalls, dass bevor irgendwas entschieden wird, eine Schuldentragfähigkeitsanalyse gemacht wird. Das ist für ihn dann Ausgangspunkt einer politischen Verhandlung, die ihm seinem, dem deutschen Ziel näher bringt. Statt bilateraler Verfahren und Verhandlungen, also dass die Europäische Kommission sich dann Länder unterschiedlich anschaut und sagt, die skandinavischen Länder haben andere Problemlagen als Frankreich, in dem es seit drei Monaten nicht geregnet hat zum Beispiel, will er nicht, diese bilateralen Verfahren und Verhandlungen sind falsch. Wir brauchen ein funktionierendes System fiskalischer Regeln, Gleichbehandlung aller Mitgliedstaaten.
Das heißt, Deutschland braucht ein System, bei dem es den Ton angeben kann.
Wir brauchen ein deutsches Europa, und zwar für alle keine Sonderwege. Und das ist dann in seinem Wortlaut ein gemeinsames Verständnis von soliden öffentlichen Finanzen in der Union, das möchte er bewahren.
Ja, das würde alle Europäer wahnsinnig freuen. Und in dieser Geschlossenheit stellen wir uns dann auch dem großen System rival in China.
Genau. Wir sparen uns zur Tode. Wir erwirtschaften durch Verzicht. Diese gemeinsamen Regeln, also die gemeinsamen Regeln, von denen wir wissen, dass es seine sind. Gemeinsame finanzpolitische Regeln müssen einen raschen und ausreichenden Abbau von Defiziten und hohen Schuldenquoten gewährleisten und gleichzeitig die notwendigen öffentlichen und privaten Investitionen ermöglichen. Die Verbesserung der Qualität der öffentlichen Finanzen durch Prioritätensetzung bei den Ausgaben ist nach wie vor entscheidend. Also Ausgabendisziplin, alles muss auf dem Prüfstand, so wie er jetzt auch auf Twitter mal ankündigt. Wir haben zwar eine Billion, das erste Mal nimmt der Staat mehr als eine Billion Euro im Jahr ein, aber alles muss ausgabenseitig auf dem Prüfstand. Die Referenzwerte von 3% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts bei der Neuverschuldung und die Defizitquote 60% –das können wir alle raten und überlegen –muss unangetastet bleiben.
Natürlich. Denn das ist ja diese wichtige…
Alle fragen sich, was sind das für zwei Zahlen? Kann man das irgendwie begründen?
Das ist ja auch inzwischen alles in sehr gutem Paper nachvollziehbar. Wenn man sagt, es ist gewürfelt, dann hat man damit doch schon recht.
Er schreibt dann, wir –wer auch immer das ist –wir sind überzeugt davon, dass nachvollziehbare und gemeinsam vereinbarte numerische Benchmarks eine Mindestvoraussetzung sind. Also, 3 und 60%. Er argumentiert ja nichts. Er macht ja nur Thesen, Thesen, Thesen. Ich will so Wunschkatalog. Es wird überhaupt nicht erklärt. Einfach nur, und so wird es schon immer, es ist halt historisch. Wir haben uns dran gewöhnt. Die Schuldenregeln sind 3% und 60%, also bleibt man einfach dabei. Aber abseits eines historischen Arguments haben wir einfach gar nichts. Wir brauchen einfache und transparente Ausgabenregeln. Er möchte also zentral aus deutscher, mit deutscher Brille nochmal mitentscheiden, wie andere Länder mit ihren Geldern umgehen. Wir brauchen Schutzbestimmungen. Sie sind ganz erforderlich, die Ausgabendisziplin durchsetzen. Und eine tatsächliche Senkung der Schuldenquote über die Maastricht-Referenzwerte hinaus muss in jedem Jahr sichergestellt werden.
Also Maastricht ist eigentlich noch zu schwach.
Ist zu schwach. Wir müssen darüber hinaus, über die Maastricht-Referenzwerte hinaus, bis wir irgendwann vielleicht bei Null sind.
Oder wirklich dann die paar Millionen noch alle in Lager haben.
Es ist irre. Wir brauchen auch weitere Maßnahmen, um die Einhaltung der Vorschriften durch die Mitgliedsstaaten zu gewährleisten. Also Selbstverpflichtungen. Das kennen wir ja. Legt mal erstmal euren Haushalt vor. Wir genehmigen dann. Also macht die EU-Kommission sowieso. Aber dann sollen diese Regeln nochmal besonders hart rein. Und wir wissen, Ursula von der Leyen argumentiert gerade genau in die andere Richtung. Aber auch ein bisschen so, dass man es erst entschlüsseln muss. Erfordert darüber hinaus weniger Ermessensspielraum bei der Auslegung und Anwendung der Vorschriften. Also es geht in einem Wunsch hier einfach durch. Die Reform des Stabilitäts- und Wachstumspaktes kann kein Selbstzweck sein. Sie ist nur akzeptabel, wenn wir den Rahmen deutlich verbessern. Ansonsten wäre eine Änderung der Regeln nicht ratsam. Also entweder härter oder es bleibt, wie es ist. Das ist seine Verhandlungsposition.
Kann es sein, dass das gar kein Artikel von ihm ist? Oder hast du einfach bei Chagy BT eingegeben, schreibt mal alles, was Christian Lindner an Ideologie im Kopf hat, hier auf?
So ungefähr. Das sind nur Thesen und Wünsche. Hier wird nichts argumentiert. Hier gibt es keine funktionellen Zusammenhänge. Hier wird nicht auf Einzelfälle, auf Erfahrungen gesetzt. Wir haben es schon immer so gemacht. 63% ist seit über 20 Jahren etabliert. Ziehen wir weiter oder machen es strenger.
Soll ja ein guter Rhetoriker sein.
So tritt er einfach auf.
Ja, so tritt er auf. Und klar, wenn ich mich da hinstelle und sage, wir müssen wieder zu einer neuen Sparsamkeit zurückkehren, und dann drückt er ja immer noch die Stimme so ein bisschen stärker nach unten, als er sie eigentlich hat, das macht einen Druck.
Es ist wirklich schlimm.
Wir wollen uns mit einem philosophischen Thema beschäftigen, nämlich mit Generativität. Über ein Desiderat in der Philosophie heißt ein Aufsatz von Tatjana Noemi Tömmel, erschienen in der Zeitschrift Merkur. Und sie stellt sich die Frage, warum kommen eigentlich Eltern, kommt Elternschaft in der Philosophie so gut wie nicht vor? Sie schreibt vor einigen Jahren, beschrieb die Lyrikerin Dagmara Kraus, die Banalität der Mutterschaft. Müttern fehlt es demnach nicht nur an Muße zum Dichten, sondern ihr Leben sei angesichts von Windeln und Rotznasen aller Poesie beraubt. Kein Wunder, dass Mütter schon mal den Tod ihrer Kinder fantasieren. Ja, es fehlt Müttern heute auch immer mehr Väter an Muße. Kaum ein Beruf vor dazu radikal den pausenlosen Einsatz tagsnachtstags. Aber fehlt es auch an Poesie? Hier ist für die Autorin klar, nein, mit einem Kind kommt Anmut in die Welt. Sie blickt dann erst auf die Geschichte der Philosophie. So gut wie nie, schreibt sie, wird das Wunder eigentlich, dass da ein Kind geboren wird, als erwähnenswertes Thema in der Philosophie angesehen. Sie schreibt, während Tod und Sterblichkeit von der Antike bis zur Existenzphilosophie im Zentrum philosophischer Überlegungen standen, war der Anfang des menschlichen Lebens kaum je ein Thema. Die Fruchtbarkeit als Gegenstück zur Sterblichkeit, also die Möglichkeit der Fortpflanzung und die Frage, was dies für den Einzelnen bedeutet, wurden so gut wie nie reflektiert. Und ich habe dann auch so überlegt, naja, was hast du dann gelesen? Dann müsste doch eigentlich, nee, und dann kommt man erst mal auf gar nichts.
Ich verrate eine Pointe, die schon Philipp Kindler auf der Bühne hatte. Das Programm ist ja, ich glaube, es sind noch zwei Auftritte oder so, durch. Deswegen kam das ja hier so, ist immer sehr lustig, finde ich. Steht er so da, sagt er, er hat auch einen Sohn und so. Und dann kommen irgendwelche christlichen Leute auf ihn zu, auf der Straße, die ihn so ansprechen. Ja, und das Wunder, sie müssen doch hier pro live und so. Sie haben doch als Vater und das Wunder des Lebens, die Geburt. Und dann steht er so vor ihnen. Und sie möchten gerne, dass ihre leuchtenden Augen sich auf ihn übertragen. Und er jetzt so weinerlich in die Vaterrolle. Ja, das war der tollste Tag meines Lebens. Und dann macht er so eine Denkerpause und sagt dann, naja. Ich finde, das ist wirklich eine der am weitestgehenden und vielsachsten Reflexionen zum Thema. Abseits dieser ganzen Heulsusen. Oh, das ist so schön, dass ein Kind geboren wurde und so weiter. Das ist, stimmt, da haben wir ein echtes Defizit.
Und das will sie aber nicht jetzt hier einfach nur das so verkitschen. Und sie sagt erst mal, warum findet das in der Philosophie nicht statt? Und naheliegend ist natürlich zu sagen, das liegt an den Geschlechterverhältnissen. Kinder kommen durch Frauen dann auf die Welt. Und Frauen sind in der Philosophie unterrepräsentiert. Es gibt viel weniger Philosophinnen in der Philosophiegeschichte etc. Und dann gibt es auch ganz viele kinderlose Philosophen, wie zum Beispiel Foucault, Leibniz, Descartes, Kant. Es gibt auch Väter in der Philosophie. Zum Beispiel Sokrates, Aristoteles, Rousseau. Über den einen oder anderen ist ja mehr oder weniger Gutes bekannt. Aber sie sagt, naja, das kann nicht der einzige Grund sein. Schließlich sind kinderlose Philosophinnen auch fähig, darüber zu resonieren, wie zum Beispiel Hannah Arendt und Simone de Beauvoir. Bei ihnen findet man etwas. Es ist erstaunlich, dass Sokrates zwar die Hebammenkunst als eine Möglichkeit sieht, dass man also durch eine gewisse Fragetechnik das, was schon in einem liegt, zutage fördern kann. Also dass jeder eigentlich schon Erkenntnis in sich trägt, dass aber das niemals mal auf Geburt wirklich übertragen wird. Das heißt denn hier, angestoßen durch Hannah Arendts Überlegungen zur Natalität, hat sich im ausgehenden 20. Jahrhundert zwar ein Bewusstsein dafür entwickelt, dass die Fortpflanzung des Menschen seit der Antike im Schatten der geistigen Selbsthervorbringung des Subjekts stand und Zeugung, Schwangerschaft und Geburt metaphorisch vereinnahmt und überlagert wurden. Doch selbst wenn die Geburtsvergessenheit bemerkt worden ist, kann von einem rastlosen Umkreisen der Natalität gar von einem Wechsel des philosophischen Paradigmas nicht die Rede sein. Tatsächlich sind Arendts Thesen zur Geburtlichkeit nicht weniger metaphorisch als das platonische Zeugen im Schönen, mit der durch die leibliche Geburt gestifteten Beziehungen zwischen Eltern und Kindern hat die Aufwertung der Natalität als Fundament der Politik so gut wie nichts gemein. Denn eigentlich ließen sich ja von den Fragen der Elternschaft sehr existenzielle Fragen ableiten. Was bedeutet es denn eigentlich, Eltern zu werden, Leben zu zeugen? Das wird kaum thematisiert. Auch der Feminismus kommt dem nicht nach. Der beschäftigt sich natürlich mit der Unterdrückung der Frau. Dann gibt es ja einen modernen Feminismus, der sagt, eigentlich muss man die Frau vom Muttersein befreien. Also wir müssen das am besten durch künstliche Reproduktion alles tun, damit Frauen nicht mehr schwanger sein müssen. Da schreibt die Autorin hier, das ist eine Abwertung der Elternschaft innerhalb des philosophischen Diskurses. Und das deutet da, das liegt auch daran, dass man Elternschaft und auch Schwangersein als bloßen Naturprozess auffasst. Sie schreibt, als bestünde das Leben und die Sorge für Kinder nichts anderem als füttern, Windeln wechseln und wieder füttern. Selbst dort, wo Elternschaft philosophisch ernst genommen und in Detail diskutiert wird, wie bei Hegel und de Beauvoir, wird sie den Makel der Natur nicht los, die über ihren inferioren Status entscheidet, also diesen untergeordneten Status. Der Vorort von Anzung kommt sowohl für das Verhältnis der Eltern zueinander, als auch für die Beziehung zum Kind eine subjekttheoretische Bedeutung zu. Und sie bezieht sich dann hier auf Hegel. Im Kind erfahren die Eltern ihre Einheit als objektiviert. Ihr Verhältnis zum Kind ist eine Anschauung ihrer selbst in einem Fremden. Obwohl Hegel Eltern schafft, bzw. die Familie als eine Form intersubjektiv vermittelter Selbstverwirklichung versteht, stellt die familiäre Liebe noch keine vollständige Form der Anerkennung dar. Denn Anerkennung ist nur in einem symmetrischen Verhältnis möglich. Aber diese Anerkennung ist sehr wichtig. Und hinzu kommt auch, was macht man da eigentlich? Na ja, man schöpft ja etwas. Man schöpft Leben. Und es gibt ja eine große Auseinandersetzung mit dem Homophaber, der Mensch, der was bauen, was schaffen kann. Aber wie ist es dann, schaut dann de Beauvoir mit der Mutter. Die schafft ja eigentlich auch was mit dem Körper der Mutter. Und da sagt de Beauvoir, sie wird eben degradiert zum passiven Werkzeug des Lebens. Und hier sagt aber dann die Autorin das Gefühl, Leben zu erschaffen. Er weise sich damit als Illusion. Also so de Beauvoir, nicht die Mutter erschaffe das Kind, sondern es selbst erschaffe sich in ihr als ein reines Faktum Prutum. Und dem möchte aber die Autorin wieder sprechen. Und sie sagt dann etwas sehr, sehr Schönes. In Wahrheit ist Generativität, also Elternschaft, weder ausschließlich noch primär eine natürliche Tatsache. Es sei denn, man hält das Leben und das Aufwachsen eines Menschen für das Blühen und Welken einer Pflanze. Für Wesen wie uns, selbstbewusste Wesen, sind all jenen natürlichen Bedingungen der Existenz, Sterblichkeit, Verletzlichkeit und eben auch Fruchtbarkeit, nie einfach nur biologische Tatsachen. Wir existieren nicht nur. Wir verhalten uns immer zugleich reflexiv zu unserer Existenz. Für Menschen ist die eigene Fortpflanzung, also zugleich ein geistiger Prozess, eine durch die potenzielle Beziehung zum anderen vermittelte Selbstbeziehung.
Ja, wenn das so ein rein natürlicher Prozess wäre, gäbe es ja auch diesen ganzen Markt der Ausbeutung nicht, dass man diese ganzen kleinen Unsicherheiten und überhaupt... Wir haben ja auch viel Aufklärung zu den frühen Hilfen bekommen. Ich habe mich daran erinnert, klar, frühe Hilfen, das ist dieses, ich bin Student, ich werde Vater, ich gehe zum Amt, um mir einen Kinderwagen mitzufinanzieren zu lassen. Also dafür sind die frühen Hilfen da. Und die zeigen ja so ein bisschen, dass es da diese eigentlich politische, soziale Dimension und so weiter gibt. Ich frage mich dann sowieso, wenn man diese ganze Philosophiegeschichte kennt, die immer mit diesem, die Augenöffnung, die Verstandesbedienung und so weiter. Wo kommt denn der Verstand her? Wo kommen denn die Augen her? Also, dass man überhaupt was erkennt und so. Das ist ja... Da haben wir auch kritische Kritik bekommen zum Thema das Bildungssystem. Weil du ja so viel den Frontalunterricht nochmal abgefeiert hast und so weiter. Dass dann auch wieder die Frage ist, ja, man muss in der Schule schon sehr viele stupide, repetitive Sachen machen, weil man noch nicht genau weiß, was bleibt denn am Ende... Also, was führt denn dazu, dass man irgendwann mal in der Lage ist, eine Oper inhaltlich durchzuhalten, zu verstehen, sich dann auf die nächste zu freuen? Also diesen sehr artificiellen Akt plötzlich wertzuschätzen. Und die Antwort kann ja durchaus sein, ja, das ist genau diese stupide Repetitive, das im Vorfeld 20 Jahre lang einfach passieren muss, mit dem man sich aber so wenig befassen will. Weshalb auch die Schule so lieber als er geschieht. Kümmern wir uns gerade nicht politisch so groß drum. Da muss ja eh viel mit Leidenschaft gearbeitet werden. Also, so wie man auch den Eltern sagt, ihr macht das doch aus Leidenschaft, oder? Ihr habt doch einen natürlichen Trieb, eure Kinder gut zu erziehen. So wird das auch mit diesen ganzen angegliederten Professionen ist man dann irgendwie umgegangen und zieht halt die Politik raus. Wir hatten ja auch mal diesen einen Text der New York Times, wo die Mutterrolle so in den Jahrhunderten entwickelt wurde, als das Relikt aus der Natürlichkeit, wo sich die Politik dann bloß nicht einmischen darf.
Elternschaft muss man jedenfalls dann immer als ein Beziehungsgeflecht verstehen. Man kann auch sagen, Elternschaft ist, wie Dieter Thome sagt, eine riskante Lebensform, da man ja nicht weiß, was denn aus dem Kind so wird. Stell dir mal vor, du hast jetzt ein Kind und das wird FDP-Mitglied irgendwann. Was macht man dann? Und das finde ich nämlich hier sehr schön formuliert. Homo Faber bringt mit jedem Werk auch sich selbst zum Ausdruck. Kinder sind zwar wahrhaftig das Eigenste, was ein Paar aus sich machen kann. Sie sind aber zugleich völlig eigenständige, unabhängige Personen. Das Sein im Anderen, die Identifikation und Spiegelung im Kind, muss sich dafür hüten, zur Projektion eigener Ziele zu werden. Wer Kinder hat, erschafft nicht, er wird erschaffen. Das ist ausgezeichnet formuliert. Und Elternschaft meint, Handeln in Beziehungen meint, du hast gerade gesagt, ja, wie wird dann das sehen trainiert, meint zu filtern, meint Informationen zurückzuhalten, Informationen zu geben, meint anzuleiten, meint Rückhalt zu geben, wenn die Emotionen-Affekte instabil sind. All das wird hier sehr, sehr gut geschildert, was eigentlich Elternschaft ist. Also es ist eigentlich der Beginn jetzt für so eine generative Philosophie. Und dieser lange, aber gute Aufsatz schließt mit den Worten Jenseits von romantischer Idealisierung und pauschalem Ideologieverdacht, gilt es, das Verhältnis zwischen den Generationen und die Generativität als solche philosophisch zu entdecken. Und ich würde sagen, ein Anfang ist damit gemacht.
Hm, sehr gut. Schließen wir mal direkt dran an. Vermögende Familien als Akteure im gegenwärtigen Kapitalismus. Also Nachwuchsfragen. Und hier wird auch ein Hintergrund ziemlich großer Forschungsfragenunlust sozusagen thematisiert. Gerade jetzt, wo doch die dynastische Familie als machtvolle gesellschaftlichen Akteure hervortreten. Wir haben es also mit einem Wiedererstarken des Einflusses von Familien im Kapitalismus zu tun. Und das erfordert nun öffentlichen Diskurs und fordert auch die Sozialwissenschaften heraus, schreibt Isabelle Stamm als Forschungsüberblick in der aktuellen Ausgabe. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Zeitung heißt, aber das ist das Max-Planck-Institut für Gesellschaftsforschung. Und sie selbst ist Soziologin und leitet seit 2021 die Forschungsgruppe Unternehmen, Eigentum und Familienvermögen bei Max Planck. Das ist also sehr gut. Das trifft mehrere meiner Fragestellungen gleich auf einmal. Welche Rollen spielen sie heute als Akteure im gegenwärtigen Kapitalismus? Dieser Frage geht die Vermögensforschung hier nach. Also in den letzten Jahrzehnten gab es eine Konzentration von Vermögen in Deutschland. Wir haben es mit einer Vermögensungleichheit zu tun, die beispiellos ist in der Welt. Die oberen 10% besitzen 60% des privat verfügbaren Vermögens. Die Zahl steht jetzt ja nicht drin, aber kürzlich wurde ja wieder von 25 Billionen Euro gesprochen. Und dann weiß man, 60% davon ist ganz schön viel in der Hand von 10% der Leuten. Und das ist, umso reicher die Familien sind, umso mehr Unternehmens-Eigentum, das da verbrieft ist, ja kein Bargeld, das rumliegt, sondern die sind ja tief verstrickt über Investitionen. Und es wird eben, und da kommt die Konzentration zustande, vor allem über Schenkung und Vererbung weitergegeben. Und ja, auch die reichen Familien haben nicht drei, vier Kinder pro Nase, sondern da sind es dann eben auch die weniger als zwei. Also es wird immer auch weniger vererbt, als vererbt wird. Und über dieses Eigentum an Unternehmen wissen wir recht wenig. Aber eins wissen wir, der strukturelle Einfluss auf die Beschaffenheit der deutschen Wirtschaft, schreibt sich hier, ist sehr hoch. Es geht um machtvolle Positionen, die sozialwissenschaftlich schwer zu fassen sind. Und die vorherrschenden Traditionen der Gesellschaftstheorie nimmt gerade das nicht in den Blick, weil ja Familien als Relikte gerade im ökonomischen Kosmos sind. Sie erinnern dann so an die Budenbrocken, die Orksche Manier. Eigentlich sinkt ja die Bedeutung der Familie, bis dann irgendwann die Familie ausstirbt, aber das Unternehmertum bleibt und so.
Die Individuen werden ja dann in der letzten Generation Künstler, weil nichts mehr anstarrt.
Genau, sie werden entkoppelt sozusagen rausmodernisiert aus diesem ganzen ökonomischen Zusammenhang. Dabei ist genau das Gegenteil wahr, wenn man ihr so folgt. Sie hat jetzt ihre Unternehmen, Eigentum und Familienvermögen-Forschungsgruppe und die stellt sich mehrere Fragen. Und es ist witzig, wie sie immer wieder von dynastischen Familien spricht. Ich bin ja auch sehr dafür, von Julia Friedrichs angeleitet, von Dynastien zu sprechen. Wie die eigentlich diese Spitze der Vermögensherarchie so besetzen, wie das funktioniert, wie das aufgebaut ist, wie das organisiert wird, wie diese Werte transformiert und auch legitimiert werden. Also es geht auch darum, wie Öffentlichkeitsarbeit da stattfindet. Wir haben es mit kulturellen Besonderheiten in Deutschland zu tun, also diese deutschen Industriedynastien, wie sie sagt. Sie nennt dann so einige Autoren, die wie Hartmut Berghoff mal dieses Selbstverständnis herausgearbeitet haben, dass nämlich diese Familien als heute mehr so Treuhänder ihres Unternehmens, also sie sind nicht mehr ganz so verquickt mit den Unternehmensentscheidungen, die da stattfinden. Dafür hat man ja Angestellte im Management, der CEO, der berufen wird und so. Man ist dann als Treuhänder, schwebt man so ein bisschen drüber und rutscht immer mehr aus der Unternehmerrolle raus in die Gesellschaft der Rollereien, weil man dann auch den Spagat schafft zwischen wir, die Familie Porsche oder Peech oder wie auch immer, haben ein Unternehmen, das unseren Namen trägt. Mit dem sind wir traditionell verbunden, aber wir investieren ja auch woanders. Und jetzt können sie in der gleichen Gesellschaft eine Rolle in eigentlich an fremden Unternehmen in dem Fall, aber die sie eben vom Mögen, wie sie sind, trotzdem zu ihren Unternehmen gemacht haben, plötzlich so auftreten. Also diese Rolle des Gesellschaftes wurde erfunden die letzten Jahre und auch in der Sozialisation daraufhin trainiert. Also man lernte nicht mal das Handwerk des Motorbauen vom Vater, sondern man lernte jetzt die treuhänderische gesellschaftliche Position für schön Wetter zu sorgen, mediale Stimmung zu machen und so weiter, politische Forderungen zu formulieren und immer mal auch mit dem Management zu reden, aber sich da gar nicht groß einzumischen.
Ja, das ist ja eine ganz eigenartige Rolle. Es gibt ja Gesellschafter, die sich dann völlig rausnehmen und vielleicht nur noch so Repräsentanzaufgaben wahrnehmen. Dann ist aber dann immer wieder, naja, im Ernstfall wird ja dann vielleicht doch mal so das eine oder andere angestoßen. Es ist eine sehr merkwürdige Art des Regierens, die sich da einschlagt, weil sie so gar nicht klar ist. Sondern am Ende ist das dann doch nochmal so eine Feudalstruktur. Der Fürst ruft jetzt mal durch und sagt, lieber mal nicht so.
Genau, also sie kommt auf einige Autoren zu sprechen, die zum einen sagen, der Einfluss einzelner Eigentümerfamilien an Unternehmen ging zugunsten des Managements zurück. Trotzdem werden natürlich Dividenden und so gezahlt. Also das ändert nichts am Vermögen, wenn auch die organisationspolitische Macht da schwindet. Bleibt trotzdem das Vermögen. Und dann gibt es ja diese neue Rolle der Investoren. Wir kennen das von BlackRock, die sich eben überall so einmischen, dass sie dann doch wieder eine politische Rolle spielen über die Richtung des Unternehmens, indem sie einfach, ihr kauft jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, und dann gibt es so von Bayer und Monsanto plötzlich, und keiner kann sich das erklären. Das ist dann wirklich nur noch durch ja, die Family Offices haben entschieden und so. Sondern irgendwie Blackhawk kommt und sagt, ihr macht das jetzt mal, wir sind bei beiden mit 8 Prozent drin. Also können wir das mit entscheiden.
Hatten wir jetzt in der Autoindustrie ja so Splits von Unternehmen, dass man sagt, die bekommen jetzt nochmal so ein eigenes Ding, also bei Porsche. Und bei anderen Konzernen haben wir das erlebt. Also das ist auch nochmal so eine spezielle Eitelkeit dann der Familien-Offices, die dann sagen, ja, wäre doch nochmal schön, die Marke aufzuwerten durch so eine eigene Aktie.
Und das bedeutet auch, mit diesem Wandel kam ein Herr, das früher unterschiedlich vererbt wurde. Also die Bevorzugung des ersten Sohnes und so weiter, weil der muss ja dann den Laden übernehmen als Manager. Jetzt hat man das Phänomen, dass man ja nicht mehr das Kind als den Nachfolger am Unternehmen ausbildet, sondern allgemein, wodurch man die Erbanteile wieder gleichmäßig verteilt. Die Gesellschaft, die Rolle kann einfach jeder gleichmäßig ausfüllen. Da braucht man nicht den einen auf dem Superchef posten, sondern alle sind Gesellschafter. Das wiederum bindet die Familien wieder mehr zusammen, weil die mehr miteinander koordinieren müssen. Also es finden dann Gesellschafter-Treffen, Lehrgänge und so weiter statt, was diese ganze Unternehmensdynastie-Verbünde wieder mehr zusammenschweißt. Weil auch die Zweit- und Drittgeborenen jetzt nicht einfach, ich bin sozusagen aus dem Spiel, weil der Erste erbt ja alles und übernimmt und ich werde einfach nur entschädigt, sondern nein, sie alle drei übernehmen gleichmäßig Verantwortung, alle bekommen den gleichen Anteil an dieser Gesellschafter-Rolle übers Vermögen und müssen sich dann auch miteinander verständigen. Und dann auch Bande mit anderen Familien schließen, weil sie über die Family Offices in anderen Unternehmen. Also es findet da auch sozusagen, was die soziale Landkarte angeht, eine Konzentration von Absprachen politischer Macht und so weiter statt.
Wir sind ja eingestiegen im Teaser damit, dass der Fußballspiegel der Gesellschaft ist. Aber jetzt blick doch mal auf die Unterhaltungsindustrie. Da haben wir solche Heiraten zwischen Familienunterhaltungsdynastien, die Katzenbergers und die Cordalis heiraten. Oder die Kelly Family wird immer größer und hat immer noch mehr Nachkommen und Auskopplungen. Und dann gibt es wieder alle zusammen. Man hat also immer mehr diese dynastischen Strukturen im Unterhaltungsbusiness, erstaunlicherweise.
Große Diskussionen in Hollywood, dass irgendwelche Schauspieler kommen. Ich habe es ja auch selber dabei erlebt bei Tenet. Ach so, das ist der Sohn von Denzel Washington, der die Hauptrolle spielt. Weiß man gar nicht, aber man weiß, die kennen sich halt am Set aus. Die kommen da als nicht Newbies hin. Die wissen, wie es geht und so. Und da hat man es auf dieser kulturellen Ebene. Aber ja, man kennt sich. Man ist sowieso als führender Schauspieler dann immer. Das sind ja die eigenen Filme, die man produziert. Tom Cruise und so. Das ist ja auch alles dann selbst finanziert und so. Ja, ja, also das sieht man überall. Diese Art von Verquickung, aber hier in Deutschland eben besonders streng, weil es um besonders viel Geld geht. Diese Familien haben dann so was Neues, was sie jetzt erforschen wollen hier. Family Governance. Also ein Gesellschaftsausschuss, der ein Beirat oder eine Kommission und so weiter. Was machen die eigentlich? Also Family Offices sind ja eh schon so ein kleines Desiderat. Man weiß fast nichts. Jetzt gibt es Family Governance, über die man auch wenig weiß. Da kündigt sie sich hier so an. Man hat schon 2022-23 teilnarrative Interviews mit Mitgliedern dieser Familien geführt und will diese Forschung auch fortführen. Wir wissen ja von Michael Hartmann, der ansonsten so Elite-Forschung macht. Richtig Zugang gibt es da eigentlich nicht. Die haben hier auch im Text so ein Bild von einem Lidl. Oder war das in dem Text? Na ja, irgendwo tauchte so ein Bild aus der Lidl-Familie und so weiter. Dann stand darunter 2016, Archiv. Man sucht irgendwelche Leute und hat quasi nur acht Jahre alte Bilder. Man kommt da immer so gar nicht weiter. Hier wird jedenfalls die Forschung versucht. Es geht um die Rolle der Gesellschafter, um das Gesellschaftsrecht an sich, um deren Wertekanon, die Norm, wie geht man jetzt eigentlich mit seinem Nachwuchs um, Schenkungs- und Erbrechte, wie werden die so ausgelegt. Also es sind alles wahnsinnig interessante Fragestellungen, die uns dann auch künftig hoffentlich noch ein bisschen dargelegt werden, um was es hier geht. Familienvermögen können heute leichter liquidiert werden und sind damit aber frei für neue Investitionen. Also man klebt nicht, das hatten wir ja kürzlich bei diesen Neureichen, die kein altes Vermögen mitschleppen, Elon Musk zum Beispiel oder Mark Zuckerberg. Deren Vermögen hängt ja ganz klar an ihrem Unternehmen. Also hat man ja bei Elon Musk gesehen, der konnte ja gar nicht einfach Twitter kaufen, ohne durch Verkäufe, also Liquidierung seines Geldes, bei Tesla das Unternehmen in Gefahr zu bringen. Davon machen die sich so ein bisschen unabhängig, indem die einfach ihre alten Vermögen sowieso schon breitstreuen. Und man heute, und das ist ja so ein Text, der dann auch in die Richtung geht, immer wieder darauf hinzuweisen, das macht der Julia Friedrichs auch, wir haben in der Politik, gerade von Markus Söder, immer so eine Betonung der Familienunternehmen. Das sind ja die Arbeitgeber, und da können wir jetzt nicht einfach diejenigen, die durch deren Familiengeneration das Wandel da eine Erbschaftssteuer ansetzen, weil dann geht das ja direkt ans Betriebsvermögen und so weiter. Und hier wird dann auch wieder das Bild aufgemacht. Nee, wir haben es nicht mit Unternehmerfamilien, mit Familienunternehmen zu tun, sondern mit Unternehmerfamilien, die, Julia Friedrichs hatte ja diese Zahl, in 800 verschiedenen Unternehmen investiert sind. Und dadurch gelten diese Unternehmen als Familienunternehmen.
Man erbt ein Portfolio.
Genau, man hat so ein Portfolio, das wird über diese Shared Heals und so weiter.
Und da geht es nicht darum, dass die eine Fabrik haben mit 100 Mitarbeitern. Wenn die eine hohe Erbschaftssteuer zahlen müssen, muss die Hälfte der Fabrik verkauft werden. Und dann kann sie nicht mehr betrieben werden. Das ist ja das Bild, das Markus Söder zeichnen würde.
Genau, der industrielle, der Patrouillage.
Würden wir mal sagen, dann stoß doch mal Aktien ab.
Genau, und genauso ist es eben nicht. Also es hat sich einmal gewandelt, aber unser Bild von die Unternehmerfamilie ist sozusagen einfach geblieben im 19. Jahrhundert.
Bei Trigema ist das der Fall, mit Wolfgang Kruppe. Aber das ist ja auch deshalb so eine Ausnahme. Deshalb taucht er ja überall auf.
So, also wir haben es mit einem Familienmodell zu tun, das heute als Investor und Asset-Manager auftritt und auch nicht anders zu beobachten wäre. Also die bleibt natürlich ganz zurückhaltend in politischen Forderungen, aber ich sage, dieses Bild, was wir da bisher hatten, ist total überholt und es gibt hier einiges zu klären. Ich finde es auch interessant, wenn du aufwächst, in absoluter ökonomischer Sicherheit stellen sich ja ganz andere Fragestellungen. Es geht ja nicht mehr darum, was lernst du, um ein monatliches Gehalt usw. zu erwirtschaften, sondern es geht nur noch darum, wie kannst du den Vermögensbestand sichern? Und dazu zählt heute politischen Einfluss ausüben. Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Hier in Frankfurt sind ja auch so Städte, in denen es einfach Milliardäre gibt. Und die haben einfach Termine, die andere Menschen nicht haben. Und zwar indem die einfach so auf Zuruf was veranstalten. Bei Döppner, der wollte mit den Mächtigen im Silicon Valley reden, um da ein bisschen Einfluss. Also hat er diesen komischen Preis ausgerufen, den dann nur Elon Musk und Mark Zuckerberg usw., damit er mal eine Stunde mit denen reden kann. Also solche Einfluss-Erkäufe. Und wir haben ja auch diesen Eintext gelesen, wie sich Jeff Bezos in Washington einkauft, mit einem Happening nach dem anderen. Hotelflächen, Partyzonen mietet usw. und so fort. Also all diese Sachen sind hier Forschungsgegenstand. Und das ist natürlich hochinteressant.
Ich würde ein eigenes Opernhaus bauen. Ich würde den Fitzcarraldo machen. Ein Fitzcarraldo von Koblenz.
Mal gucken, ob wir... Du hast ja uns schon gesagt, es ist keine Hochkultur mehr. Es ist jetzt Subkultur. Also die Aussicht steht schlecht, dass das dann noch mal passiert.
Naja, wenn ich das Vermögen hätte.
Wenn du es hättest, ja.
Ja, ich wäre dann natürlich schlecht angesehen der Familie, weil ich würde das Vermögen ja nicht vermehren, sondern ich würde es dann verbraten.
Genau. Aber das ist ja eine wichtige Lehre aus dieser Forschung. Es kommt ja nicht drauf an, was du mit deiner Einstellung machst, wenn du Vermögen hättest. Weil dieser Weg ist verschlossen. Es geht nur noch darum, die Vermögenden, die Geld haben, was die denn für eine Einstellung haben. Also, dass irgendwer noch mal von unten da reinwächst und sagt, ich mach alles anders.
Nee, das macht mir auch keine Illusionen, dass ich da bald noch hin komme.
Man kann einen heiraten vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht. Da müsste man sich sehr mit beschäftigen, wo man da hin muss. Dass man die trifft. Die werden ja jetzt vermutlich nicht heute Abend auch in derselben Bar sitzen.
Wobei unsere Bar und so weiter...
Ist schon schön. Ist schon sehr schön. Aber ob da Millionen Nähere sind, ich weiß es nicht. Das sah mir bis dahin nicht so nach aus.
Wir stellen uns am Ende Ihres Forschungsüberblicks noch mal die forschungsrelevanten Leute aus dem Institut vor. Das fand ich ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Deswegen kann ich es hier noch mal vortragen. Der Bedeutungswandel von Unternehmenseigentum machte Isabel Stamm. Dynamiken sozialer Ordnung Franziska Wiest. Mal gucken, was das für Fragestellungen ergibt. Sozialer Aufstieg und lokaler Einfluss. Das macht auch Isabel Stamm mit Georg Walter. Und es geht grundsätzlich um vermögende Familien in dieser Forschung. Also mal sehen. Wir behalten das natürlich im Blick. Das ist eine monatlich erscheinende Zeitung, in der jetzt dieser Überblicksartikel erschien. Mal gucken.
Wir haben Don't Look Up gesehen. Könnte das auch Realität werden? Denn immerhin war es ja so vor einer Weile. Nämlich vor 66 Millionen Jahren. Dorian Schiffer schreibt in der Standard einen Artikel darüber, dass man dabei ist, darüber nachzudenken, wie kann man sich eigentlich vor einem Asteroiden-Ernstfall schützen. Der Text beginnt mit, es begann wohl als ganz normaler Tag, an dessen Ende das Schicksal der Dinosaurier besiegelt sein sollte. Der Einschlag eines gewaltigen Asteroiden von über 10 km Durchmesser ließ Schockwellen um den Planeten jagen und führte zu drastischen Klimaveränderungen, die den Sauriern schnell zum Verhängnis wurden. Stellt sich selbstredend die Frage, wer sind die Saurier unserer Zeit? Ja, dann sind wir es. Nun, es wird hier Michael Kuppers zitiert, ein Physiker der Europäischen Weltraumorganisation ESA. Er ist Spezialist für astronomisch gesehen kleine Körper. Das sind Objekte, die bei Objekten von ungefähr 100 Metern, die regionale Effekte haben können, nur 40 Prozent bekannt sind. Es gibt noch mehr Objekte, von denen wir aber gar nicht wissen, dass es sie gibt. Es sei jetzt erstmal sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass wieder ein Asteroid in einer so großen Größe kommt, wie das bei den Sauriern der Fall war. Aber bei den anderen Objekten steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Aber auch diese Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es eines dieser Objekte unbemerkt auf die Erde zusteuert, ist gering. Aus vergangenen Einschlägen können wir abschätzen, dass auch ein Impact dieser Größe nur alle 10.000 bis 100.000 Jahre stattfindet, sagt Kuppers. Wie bei Pandemien lohnt es sich aber, auf seltene, aber katastrophale Ereignisse vorbereitet zu sein, zumal wir die erste Generation sind, die dazu die technischen Mittel hat. Und zwar ist es so, dass es zuletzt eine planetare Verteidigungskonferenz in Wien gegeben hat. Und die fand statt unter der Schirmherrschaft der Vereinten Nationen und der Österreichischen Akademie der Wissenschaften. Und dort haben sich Experten auf diesem Gebiet getroffen, um zu verhandeln, was es zu tun. Es gibt aber, sagt dann der Chef des ESA-Abwehramtes Mäusel, nicht besonders viele Experten. Also sie passen alle, sagt er, in einen Vortragssaal. Anders als in Science-Fiction-Filmen müsste man aber sehr, sehr frühzeitig reagieren. Wir hatten eben bei Alexander Kluge, wie Entscheidungen, die früh gefällt werden, dann sehr viel später wichtig werden. Hier heißt es, anders als in Science-Fiction-Filmen müsste man schon fünf bis zehn Jahre vor dem Einschlag gegen Maßnahmen treffen. Also es geht nicht wie bei deinem geliebten Michael Bay, dass die sich da kurz zusammentun und dann mal hochgehen. Es gibt verschiedene Optionen. Einerseits den kinetischen Impact, bei dem eine Sonde kontrolliert mit dem Asteroiden zusammenstößt. Andererseits könnte man einen Satelliten direkt neben dem Brocken platzieren. Durch die Gravitation der Sonde würde der Asteroid dann langsam abgelenkt. Bei genügend langer Formwahnzeit kann dieser leichte Push reichen, erklärt Kuppers. Als letzte Option gibt es nukleare Explosionen, um den Asteroiden abzulenken. Aber das ist etwas, was man eigentlich nicht will. Das ist doch ein bisschen riskant, eine Atombombe mal ins All zu schießen und gucken, ob es klappt.
Du könntest auf dem Weg dahin schon exponieren.
Das ist nicht besonders aussichtsreich. Jedenfalls beschäftigt man sich mit diesen sehr auf lange Sicht gedachten Dinge. Wie sieht es aus? Was passiert da gerade? Man schaut dann immer auch jetzt schon mal, wie ist eigentlich so ein Einschlag? Wie macht sich das bemerkbar? Was würde so ein Ablenkungsmanöver bringen? Das heißt, hier die nächste Gelegenheit, unseren Asteroidenschutzschirm zu testen, gibt es schon bald. Am Freitag, dem 13. April 2029, kommt der Asteroid Apophis der Erde sehr nah, sogar näher als unsere Fernsehsatelliten. Obwohl er mit bloßem Auge sichtbar sein wird, wissen wir mit Sicherheit, dass keine Einschlagsgefahr besteht, sagt Meusel.
Näher als unsere Fernsehsatelliten, also näher als der Mond. Wie groß wird er sein? Diese 100 Meter-Dingshow?
Das steht jetzt hier nicht, aber so unten etwa, ja.
Ich wollte gerade noch die Pointe machen. Ist es nicht eine wahnsinnig erfüllende Erwerbsbiografie, die man macht, sich über sowas Gedanken machen, dann passiert ja doch nichts. Aber wenn schon 2029 so ein Ding im sichtbaren Bereich an uns vorbei fliegt?
Ja, und das ist ja toll. Wir werden es ja dann im 29er Podcast verhandeln.
Das ist nicht mehr lange hin.
Ich hoffe, es ist dann nicht die letzte Ausgabe wegen der Zeitung von Stereoiden.
Vor allem, das sind ja noch sechs Jahre. Und die können uns jetzt aber schon sagen, nah, aber nicht zu nah.
Wissen wir mit Sicherheit, sagt hier der ESA-Chef für Abwehr.
Kommt mir in astronomischen Maßstäben also eine wirklich kleine räumliche Distanz vor, die da prognostiziert wird.
Mir scheint mir auch so zu sein. Also der 29er Podcast endet je am 13. April 2020.
Na gut, stellen wir uns drauf ein. Oder schon früher, denn The Godfather of AI leaves Google and warns of danger ahead. Kite Metz hat es in der New York Times aufgeschrieben. Es ist ein bisschen komischer Text. Man weiß nicht so genau, ob sie einfach zu ihm nach Hause gefahren sind. Und er hat dann so aufgesprochen, was sie dann schreiben. Aber gut, es geht um Jeffrey Hinton, also einen Pionier der künstlichen Intelligenz. Er hat die intellektuellen Grundlagen für die KI-Systeme mitentwickelt, die heute sowohl bei der Bildgenerierung als auch bei Chagy PT und so eine Rolle spielen, nämlich diese neuronalen Verknüpfungen, die man eben so gut trainieren kann. Und 2012 war das, als er da tätig war, an der Uni. Damals hat er eine Forschungsgruppe gehabt, zu der ganz illustre Leute gehört haben. Und Google hat das damals alles gekauft. Ich habe das selber nochmal nachgegoogelt, weil die New York Times dann irgendwie dachte, das erwähnen wir dann am Ende des Textes nochmal. Aber gut, die sind ja manchmal so ein bisschen irre in ihrem Schreibstil, wie auch immer. Am Montag schloss er sich offiziell einem wachsenden Chor von Kritikern an, wird hier gesagt. Also mit Montag dann, vergangene Woche. Und wir kennen ja diese Briefe, also eine wachsende Zahl von Kritikern und so. Es gab diesen einen Brief, es gab sogar noch einen zweiten Brief, der damals geschrieben wurde. Er hat beide nicht unterschrieben, sondern möchte einfach nur ein Freigeist sein. Also er hat Google verlassen, um da jetzt einfach noch so eine Art Aufklärungsarbeit selber schon im Rentenalter machen zu können. Und er befürchtet oder sieht hier aggressive Kampagnen zur Entwicklung von Produkten auf der Grundlage seiner Forschung, also dieser generativen künstlichen Intelligenz. Und er sieht uns auf Gefahr zu steuern. Jetzt zehn Jahre hatte er das bei Google mitentwickelt, vorher in der Universität. Und jetzt möchte er davor warnen. Und er hat, also er steht zu einem längeren Interview in seinem Esszimmer dafür zur Verfügung. Nun gut. Der Weg vom Wegbereiter der künstlichen Intelligenz zum Schwarzmaler markiert insbesondere, sagen jetzt, sagt der Autor hier, einen besonders bemerkenswerten Moment in der Technologiebranche. Also wir haben nicht nur JetGBT, das jetzt da ist und funktioniert, wie es eben funktioniert, gerade jetzt mit der Vorstellung von GBT4, sondern auch solche Aktionen werden wahrscheinlich dann im Geschichtsbuch nochmal ein bisschen von Bedeutung sein, wenn es dann hieß, ah ja, das war doch die Zeit, als die diese sechs Monate gefordert haben und dann solche Leute wie der hinten Google verlassen hat, um nochmal vor den Gefahren zu warnen. Es geht hier um die große Gefährlichkeit dieser Forschung in freier Wildbahn. Er sieht vor allem sie als Werkzeug für Fehlinformation. Und dazu zählt hier auch diese unüberschaubare Masse, die jetzt einfach droht. Gefahr für Arbeitsplätze und so nennt er natürlich auch. Es ist schwer vorstellbar, wie man verhindern kann, dass die bösen Akteure es für böse Dinge nutzen. Also es lässt sich wenig gut verhindern. Schon allein, weil man nicht genau sehen kann, wer daran forscht. Da es ja keine Atomwaffentests gibt, die einfach weltweit detektiert werden können. Sondern man ist jetzt einfach dem ausgeliefert, dass man nicht genau weiß, was wo passiert. Und dann kommt jemand damit an die Öffentlichkeit. Also es gab diesen einen Brief, der dieses 6-monatige Moratorium gefordert hat, den ja 1000 Leute unterzeichnet haben. Auch Elon Musk einige Tage später, das wusste ich gar nicht, veröffentlichten 19 aktuelle und ehemalige Führungskräfte der Association for the Advancement of Artificial Intelligence, die seit 40 Jahren eine akademische Gemeinschaft bilden, auch einen Brief, den beispielsweise Eric Horowitz, also der Chief Scientist Officer bei Microsoft, hat den beispielsweise mit unterzeichnet, obwohl die ja gerade mit bingen und so weiter. Also es scheint da nochmal eine andere Argumentation zu geben, der sich dann auch diese Leute da anschließen.
Und der hinten hat nun beide Briefe nicht unterzeichnet, sah aber den Punkt zu sagen, ich trete hier zurück. Er hat dann zum Abschied noch mit Sundar Pichai, also dem Google-Chef telefoniert, und dann gehen sie ja mal kurz in diese Geschichte ein. 2012 entwickeln er und zwei Studenten, der eine davon Ilja Sutzkever, von dem haben wir ja Clips gehört, das war der Forschungsleiter von OpenAI, und Alex Krischewski, der sich auch damit auskennt, diese neuronalen Netzwerke, die es natürlich auch vorher schon gab, aber dann diese besonderen Drehs bekamen, die jetzt eine Rolle spielen. Sie haben damals schon Fotos analysiert, und der erste Durchbruch war, als plötzlich Objekte erkannt werden konnten. Also hier werden Blumen, Hunde, Autos und so genannt. Damals wurde Google auf ihn aufmerksam. Für 44 Millionen wurde der ganze Forschungsbereich einfach aufgekauft, und er war ab dann Vice-President bei Google und hat da mitgearbeitet. Schutzkäfer, heute wird im Text genannt, Chefwissenschaftler von OpenAI, und er hat ja 2018 für seine Arbeit schon den Turing Award bekommen, der so als der Nobelpreis der Informatik, was auch immer, gilt für diese Arbeit an neuronalen Netzen. Und jetzt kommen diese Unternehmen, Google, OpenAI und so weiter, und stellen die Möglichkeiten neuronaler Netze plötzlich der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung. Und hier möchte er jetzt warnen, denn es sind leistungsstarke Methoden für Maschinen, Sprache zu verstehen und zu generieren, die, also wo er jetzt sagt, dahinten, es droht hier, die menschliche Art, mit Sprache umzugehen, nicht mehr überlegend zu sein. Also er sieht jetzt vor allem diesen Wandel von GPT-3 zu GPT-4 und so.
Obwohl ja dieses Sprachverständnis der KI ein völlig anderes als unseres, wie wir ja schon verhandelt haben.
Genau, aber es geht hier einfach auch um den Blick praktisch. Welche Fragestellungen kann man der Maschine stellen? Mit welchen Antworten kommt sie dann? Und kann man das nach aufwiegend mit begleiten durch menschliche Begleitung? Oder ist hier einfach eine Überlegenheit im Spiel? Und davor warnt er, weil er hätte das auch nicht für möglich gehalten. Aber er sieht jetzt so Sachen, die ihn so ein bisschen fürchten lernen, gerade in diesem letzten Jahr, in dem zwar prinzipiell bei seinem Ansatz von 2012 geblieben wurde, aber die Datenmenge und die Rechenkraft so größer geworden ist. Also die Lernkapazität einfach quantitativ so riesig. Und wir haben ja von dem Sutzkäfer gehört, war ja ganz interessant, wie er meinte, an Rechenkraft mangelt es uns nicht, aber an Daten. Und jetzt kommt plötzlich OpenAI und veröffentlicht Whisper, um zu transkribieren. Also um einfach alle YouTube-Videos und auch noch alle Podcasts, alles, was audio-mäßig vorliegt, auch noch zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das dann zu lernen. Naja.
Hakt da doch mal gerade ein oder macht da doch mal gerade einen Satz zu dieser Transkription von Podcasts. Denn das ist doch jetzt auch möglich bei uns.
Ja, wir hatten das auch schon mal vor zwei Jahren. Aber da mit Techniken von Speechmatics und Amazon und Google und so. Das war aber alles nicht unbedingt gut und kostet da auch Geld. Und jetzt stellt OpenAI Whisper zur Verfügung, kostenlos. Das ist ein Auphonic eingebunden. Und ich habe es einfach mal eingeschaltet. Und dann bekam ich einen Hörerhinweis, dass unsere Namen vertauscht seien. Ich fragte, wo denn? Naja, im Player wurde das einfach mit reingeladen, weil ich damals noch alles vorbereitet hatte dafür, dass, wenn Transkriptionen vorliegen, eingeladen sind. Also einfach reingeladen werden können in den Player. Wer also auf neuezwanziger.de geht und unsere Monatsfolge vom letzten Monat, vom April, hört, kann einfach im Player unten mitlesen. Da läuft der Text einfach mit. Und das Wort, das gerade gesprochen wird, ist gehighlightet. Und da gibt es auch eine Suchfunktion. Also man kann dann Worte suchen und einfach dahinspringen und dann den Satz anklicken und ihn sich auch wirklich anhören. Also es ist, ja, funktioniert. Ich fand's jetzt dann doch erstaunlich gut so insgesamt.
Es scheint mir eigentlich auch sinnvoller zu sein als der Trend-Video-Podcast, oder?
Es ist so der Umgedrehte, genau. Es wird jetzt alles vertextlicht, was vorher so da stand. Also ja, gilt jetzt also auch für unseren Podcast. Wir können jetzt noch leichter von Open AI für GPT-5 mit eingeladen werden.
Ja, wir helfen, dass eine kleine Diskursverschiebung stattfindet.
So, und jetzt kommt hier, das ist ganz interessant, eigentlich klingen ja die Texte bei den New York Times nach der Hälfte immer so aus. Jetzt geht es aber erst richtig zur Sache, denn jetzt werden Zitate gespielt. Vielleicht ist das, sagt er hinten, was in diesem System vor sich geht, tatsächlich viel besser als das, was im Gehirn vor sich geht. Glaub ich nicht. Und der hat das Gehirn wirklich studiert. Also der kam aus dieser Gehirnforschung und hat dann die Informatik für sich entdeckt und so weiter.
Ja, aber die Gehirnforschung, also bestimmte Zweige der Gehirnforschung und dann Zweige der Computerwissenschaften sind ja ideologisch etwas vorgeprägt.
Ja, er sagt dann einfach, schauen sie sich an, was vor fünf Jahren war und wie es jetzt ist. Nehmen sie den Unterschied und übertragen sie ihn in die Zukunft. Das ist beängstigend. Und er betont ja nochmal, Google war bisher ein guter Verwalter dieser Technologie. Denn sie haben ganz viel geforscht und kaum etwas veröffentlicht. Die Tech-Giganten haben also gesagt, wir bauen das mal so ganz punktuell da ein, wo es irgendwie für uns Sinn ergibt. Aber wir stellen das jetzt nicht so als das große nächste Produkt, die Googlesuche zur Verfügung. Dann kam aber Open AI mit diesem Vorschlag. Daraufhin fielten sich alle angestachelt. Und jetzt haben wir plötzlich diesen Katalysator, kennen wir ja, ökonomischen Wettstreit zwischen Organisationen, die diese Profite einfach erwirtschaften wollen. Die natürlich dann auch so Halbgares schon mal der Öffentlichkeit zeigen, nur damit sozusagen die Investitionsentscheidungen entsprechend getroffen werden. Und er ist in unmittelbarer Sorge erst mal, dass das Internet mit falschen Fotos, Videos und Texten überflutet wird. So weit so gut. Durchschnittsbürger werden nicht mehr in der Lage sein, zu erkennen, was wahr ist. Also da würde ich sagen, okay, das haben wir schon seit einer Weile und das wird jetzt strapaziert. Es wird den Arbeitsmarkt umkrempeln. Aber wir haben es eben auch mit unerwarteten Verhaltensweisen dieser KI-Systeme zu tun, die bislang, haben wir ja auch thematisiert, sehr gut programmieren können, aber diesen Code noch nicht ausführen. Und diese Verknüpfung ist ja nun, also warum sollte man das nicht machen? Es liegt ja auf der Hand, dass man, wenn man einmal Code schreiben kann, den dann auch direkt ausführt, also dass man nicht nur Hinweise bekommt, wie man jetzt seine Maschine besser steuert, sondern das ist dann einfach Auto, GPT und so, ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen, wo diese Verquickung von diesem Zeug stattfindet. Die Vorstellung, dass dieses Zeug tatsächlich schlauer als der Mensch werden könnte, daran haben ein paar Leute geglaubt, sagt er, aber die meisten Leute hielten das für völlig abwegig. Und ich dachte, es sei weit weg. Ich dachte, es sei noch 30 bis 50 Jahre oder noch länger entfernt, aber das glaube ich natürlich nicht mehr. Also er ist einfach überrumpelt von sich selber, also von seinen eigenen Erfahrungen, die er so hatte, und überprüfte seine Erwartungen, die er so hatte. Das finde ich, sollte man schon mal ernst nehmen, wenn jemand in dieser Position plötzlich so darüber spricht.
Ich denke nur, dass die Prämisse nicht stimmt. Und das ist das Problem. Also reden wir über Extrementwicklungen, die die KI machen wird und dass die sehr viele Fragen beantworten kann, Aufgaben lösen, übernehmen kann? Oder reden wir die KI ersetzt den Menschen? Reden wir davon? Wenn wir davon reden, dann würde ich immer sehr stark deutlich machen, dass es schon einen fundamentalen Unterschied gibt zwischen dem menschlichen Denken und dem Denken eines Computers. Während die Prämisse solcher Hirnforscher meist ist, dass eigentlich das menschliche Gehirn ähnlich funktioniert wie ein Computer. Und das scheint mir grundsätzlich wichtig zu sein, wenn man diese Prämisse nicht teilt. Dann kann auch die Entwicklung der KI zwar rasant vonstattengehen, muss aber nicht gleich bedrohlich für den Menschen sein.
Ich will mal eine Sache nennen, die im Text nicht drinsteht, die mich aber schon ein bisschen verblüfft hat. Bei diesen ganzen Twitter-Threads zum Thema GPT ist jetzt so und so alt, guck mal, was man alles damit machen kann. Und da war ein Fall dabei, dieses Anlernen, Modell entwickeln. Wir haben ja jetzt einfach nur Text. Also bei GPT stellen wir eine Textfrage und dann bekommen wir eine Textantwort. Und das lernt auf Basis von Texten. Und OpenAI will noch mehr Texte. Das werden jetzt podcasts transkribiert usw. Schön und gut. Wir Menschen haben Bezug zur Text. Wir lernen ihn, können ihn lesen, können ihn schreiben. Damit steht der Mensch im Mittelpunkt. Der Text ist das Handwerkszeug. Und dann ist die Frage, kann der Computer künftig besser mit Text umgehen, also uns irgendwie ersetzen? Dieses Prinzip, mit neuronalen Netzen so umzugehen, ist aber natürlich nicht auf Text beschränkt. Man kann mit Pixeln umgehen, die Bilder analysieren usw. Jetzt haben die eine Forschung gemacht, indem Menschen mit sehr hochauflösenden Gehirnströme, Lesedingern der Podcast gehört. Und man konnte nachvollziehen, welcher Text wird ihnen gerade akustisch zugespielt und wie das Gehirn darauf reagiert. Daraufhin wurde ein Modell entwickelt, dem dann später, und die Forschungsfrage wurde umgedreht, ein Hirnscan gezeigt wurde mit der Fragestellung anhand einer Lernerfahrung, was denken die denn gerade. Und da wurden doch erhebliche treffsichere Nährungswerte hergestellt. Also man konnte doch so das eine oder andere Substantiv mit relativ hoher Zielgenauigkeit aus diesem Kontext herauslesen. Und das fand ich schon erstaunlich. Weil das dann auch wieder zeigte, also nicht nur die Frage, kann man jetzt in unser Gehirn schauen, irgendwann wahrscheinlich schon über diese Technik, sondern auch ach so, ja stimmt, neuronale Netze. Es geht ja nicht nur um Text, sondern es geht halt um Datengrundlage, die einfach, und umso mehr man hat, umso besser wird es dann am Ende, indem man einfach alles Mögliche machen kann. Und was ist, wenn die Fragestellung jetzt ist, wer kann als erstes die Gehirnströme so nachvollziehen, dass man wieder Text generiert? Und das ist jetzt zumindest mal eine relevante Fragestellung. Da kann dann immer noch ein Kritiker daneben stehen und sagen, sie werden uns nie so ganz durchschauen und so weiter. Aber plötzlich sind solche Fragestellungen anthalbar.
Ich finde nur, dass diese andere Kritiker-Stimme auch wichtig ist. Wir haben sehr stark den philosophischen Diskurs aus dem Spiel genommen und haben immer mehr behauptet, naja, die neuronalen Wissenschaften können eigentlich jetzt die Antworten, die die Philosophie nicht hatte, geben. Und der Mensch hat keinen freien Willen. Das können wir hier nochmal ganz deutlich zeigen. Und ich glaube aber, dass da die Philosophie eigentlich ihre große Stunde hat. Also Leute wie Gerd Keil oder wir haben hier mal im Salon über das Shijak-Buch Hegel im vertrateten Gehirn gesprochen, wo es um diese Idee von Neuralink geht, wo er doch sehr, sehr kohärent und konzise durcharbeitet, wo da die falschen Prämissen von Elon Musk sind. Also ich finde, dass diese Position wichtig ist, sich mit dieser da auseinanderzusetzen. Nur ich glaube, man muss sie sehr klar auch als eine Position deutlich machen. Und was gerade bei dem KI-Diskurs so dominant ist, und da wiederhole ich jetzt eigentlich nur das, was Tante in Corporate Theory gesagt hat, ist das so der Diskurs über KI. Also die KI kann das jetzt oder die ist jetzt schlau. Aber sie ist in dem Sinne, zumindest jetzt, noch nicht schlau. Und die Frage ist dann, ob eine KI ein Bewusstsein erlangen kann. Und da würde ich erst mal sagen, mir leuchtet nicht ein, warum sollte sie das können?
Ja, mir leuchtet die ganze Fragestellung nicht ein. Also Bewusstsein, was ist das überhaupt? Und warum sollte die Maschine?
Das ist schon entscheidend für dich, denn das ist ja der Grund, warum wir anders agieren, leben können, über Dinge sprechen können.
Ja, aber die Gefahr, von der ihr hier spricht, ist ja, wir können Maschinen anlernen, etwas zu tun. Und dieses Lernprinzip, einen Zielwurf zu verfolgen, das klappt ziemlich gut. Und bisher hatten wir Computer, die als Trivialmaschine und so weiter, wenn dann Konditionierung, also wenn das, dann macht das, und dann passiert einfach. Dann irgendwann gab es ja diese neuen Paradigmen, dass man auch bei objektorientierter Programmierung, das heißt, nicht mehr genau wusste, wie jetzt alle Einzelteile einer Software miteinander zusammenwirken, sondern die stehen sich dann nochmal gegenseitig im Weg. Und das ist ja auch dann eine Quelle für sehr viele Fehler gewesen und so weiter und so fort. Nur jetzt haben wir ja Maschinen, die in dem Sinne ein Ziel verfolgen können und noch viel mehr Komplexität, also es könnte auch anders der Weg gestaltet werden, ankommen. Und was wir jetzt gerade immens erleben, das hat mir Human auch nochmal beschrieben, der ist ja da in näheren Kontakten mit diesen ganzen Unternehmen und so, aber noch niemals waren die Unternehmen so digital attackiert wie jetzt. Also diese Folgekosten von, ja, wir haben schon ein paar Ersparnisse, dadurch, dass wir digitalisieren werden, fast aufgefressen von, oh, das müssen wir so krass absichern, und dann brauchen wir noch eine Sonderabteilung, die sich darum kümmert, das alles zu verstehen, was da alles notwendig ist und so. Dass Digitalisierung fast kaum noch Benefits hat für das eine oder andere Unternehmen, weil es so viele Nebenfolgen an Gefahren mit sich bringt. Und jetzt haben wir eine Maschine, die plötzlich nicht nur so ein Programmcode sehr viel schneller, sehr viel leichter und vielleicht auch sehr viel besser als Menschen herstellen kann, sondern es wirklich nur ein Tastendruck davon ist, sie zu ermächtigen, auch selbstständig diesen Programmcode tatsächlich anzuwenden. Finde mir eine Sicherheitslücke in dem und dem, und dann probier so lange und probier aus.
Diese Fragen sind ganz wichtig, ja.
Genau, und damit, und da ist aber, also da ist diese Frage, sagen wir mal, die Deutsche Bank wird so attackiert, dass wirklich einfach die Konten eine Woche lang nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Niemand kann eine Verbuchung machen, und damit liegt das ganze Bankensystem brach. Dann kann man natürlich immer noch daneben stehen und sagen, ja, aber sie hatte kein Bewusstsein, die Maschine. Aber sie hat trotzdem die ganze Welt lahmgelegt. Also diese Gefahr, diese ganz pragmatische, praktische Sache, die muss man so ein bisschen unabhängig davon diskutieren, was natürlich für uns immer super attraktiv ist.
Dieses romantische Bild, ja, aber das ist genau mein Plädoyer, was aber bei solchen Cassantras, die momentan sehr häufig auftreten, und davon zeugte dann beispielsweise dieser erste Brief, unterschrieben von Harari und Elon Musk, ist diese Idee von, die KI wird uns regieren. Und dann würde ich sagen, nein, die KI kann natürlich schlimme Folgen haben, und du hast jetzt gerade mal eine beschrieben. Aber da stellt sich noch nicht die Frage, ist das menschliche Gehirn am Ende unterlegen, beziehungsweise ist die KI das bessere menschliche Gehirn?
Also hier im Text schließt er hinten mit einem Hinweis auf, wie sollte es alle sein in diesen Zeiten, Robert Oppenheimer. Denn der hat auch noch dieses Zitat im Petto, das muss man noch mal ein bisschen deuten, glaube ich. Wenn man etwas sieht, das technisch gut ist, dann macht man es. Ich würde sagen, dieses technisch gut müsste man deuten im Sinne von in sich logisch, geschlossen, stringent. Ja, das ist eine Forschungsfrage, der müsste man nachgehen. Es wäre so interessant und attraktiv herauszufinden, was sie kann. Wir müssen es ausprobieren. Und das haben wir auf jeden Fall gegeben. Also dieser Forschungsantrieb und der ökonomische Wettbewerb sind in einem Maße jetzt da, dass das einem wirklich ein bisschen schummerig wird bei der Frage angesichts der Möglichkeiten Räume, was da so demnächst passiert. Und wenn dann solche Typen wieder hinten da so auftreten, finde ich schon nicht ohne. Ich finde, wir sollten es wirklich ernst nehmen, wenn die hier einfach behaupten, der technische Wandel ist gerade genauso entscheidend für uns wie die Kritik daran. Also die Kritik markiert gerade wirklich einen relevanten Punkt in der Menschheitsgeschichte. Gerade unter all dem ökonomischen Druck, der da ist, Fachkräftemangel und so weiter. Jedes Unternehmen möchte jetzt irgendwie diese Profite, diese kleine Automatisierungsdividende auch für sich nutzen. Und sei es nur, keine Ahnung, für wie verteilen wir jetzt unsere Lehrer auf die Stunden, die wir abhalten müssen. Also Personalplanung und der ganze Kram und so weiter. Das spielt da einfach eine große Rolle und da ist sehr viel Bewegung. Und nicht nur das, wir haben auch diese Kritik. Und man müsste so einen kleinen Katalog mal aufziehen, wie diese Kritik abläuft und auch, wie sie sich verändert. Also ob sie sich mal ein bisschen spezifiziert. Ich fand das hier, das war schon besser. Ich wollte nichts von Bewusstsein, das Gehirn, der Geist und so. Sondern es war schon sehr spezifisch. Und das scheint mir doch in diese Richtung jetzt häufiger zu gehen.
Ich habe etwas Kurioses gefunden in Le Monde Diplomatique in der April-Ausgabe. Hast du schon mal etwas von Atlantropa gehört?
Sind das die neuen Städte auf dem Wasser?
Fast. Es gab einen Hermann Sörgel, der in den 20er-, 30er-Jahren des 20. Jahrhunderts von sich Reden machte. Und dieser Münchner Architekt hatte eine Idee, man könnte doch das Mittelmeer trocken legen. Pierre Rambert schreibt darüber einen Artikel in The Mount Diplomatique. Das Projekt, das Staudämme im Nildelta, im Bosporus, in der Meerenge von Gibraltar und der Straße von Messina vorsah, taufte er Atlantropa. Damit sollte Europa mit dem kolonisierten Afrika zu einer geografischen und politischen Einheit verschmelzen. Die Idee kam ihm, als er 1927 in einem Geografiebuch las, dass das Mittelmeer ein Verdunstungsmeer sei. Und dann hat er das immer so weiter fortgesponnen und hat sich überlegt, na, wäre das nicht eigentlich viel besser? Und auch im Sinne der Natur, wenn wir als Menschen diesen Verdunstungsprozess ein bisschen beschleunigen, und zwar durch Staudämme. Und dann war die Idee, dass dann auch diese Staudämme enorm viel Energie produzieren. Vor 50.000 Megawatt ist da die Rede. Sörgel war sich sicher. Kohle und Öl werden nur noch 200, 300 Jahre reichen für Europa. Und was machen wir dann? Also müssen wir da schon mal früh anfangen, das ein bisschen neu zu skalieren. Ende der 1930er Jahre fiel es dem Architekten, heißt es dann auch, nicht schwer, seine eigentlich postnationale und pazifistische Utopie dem Nationalsozialismus anzupassen. Und zwar hieß es schon in einer früheren Schrift bei Sörgel, durch Einverleibung Afrikas in den abendländischen Kulturkreis ist heute noch eine Beherrschung der schwarzen Rasse möglich. Ja, also er hat sich dann auch bei Mussolini gemeldet, hat dieses Irrsinnprojekt vorgestellt. Er hat auch mit Einstein versucht zu korrespondieren, wollte ihn für die Idee begeistern. Da heißt es dann, Einstein antwortet 1929 und weist ihn darauf hin, dass das Salzwasser, mit dem er die Wüste bewässern wollte, für die Landwirtschaft nicht geeignet sei. Also Einstein ließ sich nicht dafür begeistern. Sörgel hat auch dann mit der Deutschen Reichsstelle für Raumordnung korrespondiert. Aber 1943 hatte die Gestapo genug von seinen Extravaganzen und verbot ihm weitere Publikationen. Aber Sörgel war ein Phänomen mit seinen Fantastereien. So sind von New York Times bis in französische Zeitungen immer wieder Berichte zu finden zwischen 1929 und 1933 über dieses verrückte Vorhaben. Insgesamt gab es damals in den vier Jahren 450 Artikel über Sörgel und dieses Projekt. Nun kennen wir ja solche Großprojekte, was da so alles angekündigt wird. Also hier haben wir ein frühes, ich fand das nur als Kuriosität interessant. Wir sind am Ende bzw. ich habe meinen letzten Text und will es kurz machen, aber ich muss es mit aller Euphorie tun. Esther Kinski hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Weitersehen. Es steht nicht dran, direkt Roman. Es ist eine autobiografische Erzählung vielleicht. Vielleicht ist es aber doch auch eher ein Roman, spielt sie hier mit Fiktionen. Sie erzählt aus der Ich-Perspektive von einer Frau, die nach dem Jugoslawien-Krieg nach Ungarn reist, im Südosten unterwegs ist und dann ein Mossi, ein Kino, so heißt das auf Ungarisch, ein Mossi, sieht, das sie sehr gefällt, das längst geschlossen ist. Und sie entscheidet sich, dieses Kino wieder zum Leben zu erwecken. Und sie findet dann auch Anhänger bei diesem Projekt. Und so entsteht da eine kurze neue Blütezeit des Sehens, ein kleines Kino. Denn ins Kino zu gehen, ist wichtig. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht die Geschichte erzählen und gar nicht darüber reflektieren, was ist Fiktion, was ist Wirklichkeit. Ich möchte erst festhalten, dass Esther Kinski eine der wahrscheinlich momentan wichtigsten deutschsprachigen Schriftstellerinnen ist. Aber das zweite, worum es mir eigentlich geht, ist diese unglaubliche Liebeserklärung an das Kino. Und das macht sie so hervorragend, denn sie zeigt uns wirklich, warum man eigentlich ins Kino gehen soll. Das macht sie schon auf den ersten Seiten. Ich will ein paar Absätze zitieren. Und zwar heißt es da, wohin mit dem Blick. Beim Sehen geht es um zweierlei, was man sieht und wie man sieht. Bei der Frage nach dem Weitersehen soll es nur um das Wie gehen. Beim Wie geht es um den Platz, den man selbst sehend einnimmt. Um den Blickwinkel und um die Distanz zu den Dingen, Bildern zum Geschehen, zu Nähe und Ferne, zu Weite. Die Weite ist mehr als Ferne. Sie ist das, was man an Möglichem zulässt. Das gilt für das Sehen von Landschaft, Gelände, von Menschen, von Kunst. Im vergangenen Jahrhundert ist kein Ort für das Wie des Sehens, für die Besinnung auf den Platz, den man sich sehend zuweist oder nimmt, so bedeutend gewesen wie das Kino als Ort, als Raum. Dieser Raum, der nicht einmal 100 Jahre lang Bedeutung und Gültigkeit hatte, schließt sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten immer weiter. Der Blick aus dem Dunkel in eine vom Film geschaffene Weite verengt sich mit dem Schwinden dieses Sehraums. Die mit dem Raum verbundene kollektive Erfahrung und die mehr oder weniger ausdrückliche Freude am Vorhandensein dieser Erfahrungsmöglichkeiten schwinden. Und das ist ein Verlust, der, ob betrauert oder nicht, beschrieben gehört und Gedanken verdient. Das ist der Anlass für dieses Buch. Denn für sie ist klar, wie es heißt, das Kino war der Schauplatz eines Jahrhunderts. Heute scheiden sich die Geister am Verhältnis zu diesem Ort. Warum Kino? Filme stehen in anderen Formaten zur Verfügung. Die Black Box des Zuschauerraums, die den Rahmen schuf, wird nur noch von wenigen als notwendiger Ort des Sehens empfunden. Das Beharren auf dem Film erleben, im Kino gelegentlich sogar als Elitär abgetan, als ginge es nur noch um das Was und nie mehr ums Wie. Und das ist für mich sehr, sehr wichtig, das zu lesen. Denn ich bin auch der Auffassung, ja, man kann zu Hause gut Filme sehen. Und fast alle wirklich bedeutenden Filme der Filmgeschichte habe ich nicht im Kino gesehen, einfach weil ich keine Gelegenheit dazu hatte, sondern ich habe sie zu Hause gesehen. Und doch ist das Kino für mich als Ort, ganz unabhängig davon, was dort gezeigt wird, ein wichtiger Ort, denn das Wie des Sehens ist ein so anderes. Und ich gehe ja sehr viel allein ins Kino, weil ich mir unglaublich viel ansehe oder auch zu Tageszeiten ins Kino gehe, mittags um 16 Uhr, wo viele Leute nicht können oder auch nicht wollen. Und für mich geht es immer da auch um das Wie in dieser Gesellschaft, allein zu sein, ohne eine zu starke Einsamkeit zu empfinden. Und ich finde auch, dass diese Lenkung des Blicks eine ganz wichtige ist. Wir sind so umgeben von Bildern mehr denn je. Und dass jetzt aber dieses fokussierte Sehen, das eigentlich das Kino uns ermöglicht, verschwindet und das nochmal in Literatur zu fassen, ist herausragend. Sie sagt, auch wer nie mehr ins Kino geht, weiß doch etwas von dem Besonderen der Erfahrung des Ortes, des Eintretens ins Dunkel. Das ist glaube ich jetzt allen, auch wenn hier wahrscheinlich Leute zuhören, die Jahre nicht im Kino waren, sofort klar, ja Kino gehen, das war so eine Sache. Das ist irgendwie ein anderes Sehen. Das weiß man gleich. Und was mir besonders gefällt an diesem Buch, dass sie immer wieder das Sehen als etwas herausstellt, dass man nicht einfach mal so kann. Sie sagt, Sehen ist eine Fertigkeit, die man erlernt. Eine Fähigkeit, der man sich langsam bewusst wird, wenn man will. Am Anfang ist immer der gerahmte Blick aus dem Drinnen ins Draußen, aus dem Fenster, dessen Ausschnitt dem Hinausblicken die Welt bestimmt. Dann die Entdeckung der Differenz zwischen dem Anblick der Dinge aus dem Fenster und dem derselben Dinge im Draußen umringt von ungerahmter Welt das Auge selbst ein Teil der Welt. Denn das ist ja eine Kinoerfahrung, die jeder macht, auch wenn er nicht im Kino ist. Wir blicken aus dem Fenster und sehen es gerahmt. Wir gehen hinaus, sind dann aber in der Welt, haben also dann nicht mehr diese Distanz. Und der Blick durch das Fenster kann oft viel eindringlicher sein, als dann direkt hinauszugehen. Das ist etwas, was das Kino vermittelt. Und das schildert sie hier ganz wunderbar. Das ist also eine Erzählung, die starke essayistischen Charakter hat und immer wieder davon erzählt, was eigentlich das Kino ausmacht, was die Filme sind. Sie schreibt dann auch, wie das dann ist, wenn Zelluloid geliefert wird. Und auch das ist so schön, was sie über den Film sagt. Was haben wir denn da eigentlich, wenn da die Filmrollen kommen? Nun, ein verdichtetes, verletzliches Zeugnis von vereinten Anstrengungen von Eingriffen und Übergriffen und unzähligen unwegbaren Umständen, geschuldeten Umständen, dem Technik und händisches Können dazu verhelfen, immer wieder mit jeder Vorführung, sich zu der Welt zu entfalten, die für die Dauer, die die Zelluloidstreifen brauchen, um vor einer starken Lichtquelle mit festgesetzter Geschwindigkeit und von mehreren Spulen und Spindeln geleitet vorbeizulaufen, den dunklen Zuschaueraum vor der Leinwand zu erfüllen, dass sie die auf kein erkennbares, geheißablaufende Wirklichkeit außerhalb des Kinos in den Hintergrund treten lässt. Ein Film im Kino ist in seiner Dichte und Absolutheit immer ein Eingriff in den Lauf der Welt für den Zuschauenden. Das Kino als Ort der Klassenlosigkeit stellt sie heraus. Es ist ein großes Buch über das Kino, übrigens auch mit sehr schönen, sehr verstörenden Fotografien. Wir sehen hier auf dem Cover einen Blick in einen Kinosaal, der aber schon ein bisschen zugerümpelt ist. Da sind auch Sitzreihen zu sehen, aber da stehen Bilder auf dem Boden. Wir sehen auch hier Kinos Niemandsorte, die irgendwie verweist sind. Das Ganze endet auch ziemlich traurig, wenn die Kinos sterben. Aber ich empfehle das sehr für alle, die das Kino mögen. Die sollen sich unbedingt den Blick weiten mit Weitersehen von Esther Kinski.
Ich war letztens mal wieder im Kino und möchte anmerken, klassenloser Raum, man bezahlte fünf Euro mehr und kann dafür in einen kleinen Kinosaal gehen, in dem man am Platz sein Popcorn serviert bekommt. Für mich eine neue Erfahrung, die aber nochmal einen Unterschied macht. Da sieht man aber dann keine Jugendlichen und so.
Da sehen wir doch hier schon einen Photagonisten der alten Republik, der sich jetzt schon am Platz bedienen lässt.
Ich war überrascht davon, dass es so abläuft.
Ja, hier geht es natürlich noch um das Kino, in dem man einfach mal sitzt.
Und ich will noch einen Punkt zu John Wick sagen.
Das kommt aber jetzt. Komm sage ich Kino, da kommst du mit John Wick.
Nee, jetzt fällt mir gerade ein, ich wollte es eigentlich auch schon in der Monatsausgabe im April noch sagen, aber ich will es nur mal kurz andiskutieren.
Aber Stefan, das war jetzt eigentlich ganz schön doch.
Ja, ich weiß. Das Kino zeigt uns etwas. Wir sind hinter einer Fensterscheibe usw. Bei John Wick spielen ja nicht nur Waffen eine Rolle, sondern auch Schutz vor Waffen. Und ich habe es doch mit so ein bisschen mulmigem Gefühl gesehen, dass plötzlich, während wir in Amerika Schusswaffeneinsätze privater, illegaler Natur haben, wie nie zuvor jetzt gerade. Also 50% Steigerung Schusswaffentoter innerhalb von drei Jahren bei den U30 und so. Ja, das ist ganz brutal. Früher waren es noch Schuhschießereien, mittlerweile Geburtstagsfeiern, überall. Und John Wick macht uns jetzt plötzlich vor, wenn Waffen gezückt werden, kannst du weiter auf den Fein drauf zulaufen. Du musst dir nur deine Teflonjacke, die es aber nur im Film gibt.
Eine Anzugsjacke ist das.
Ja, die einfach mit so Teflon verstärkt, also die ist einfach schusssicher.
Da weißt du, warum ich immer einen Anzug trage.
Ja, aber ich fand es so ein bisschen, es ist ja schon so eine Art Signature-Move von John Wick, sich das Jackett so vor die Stirn zu halten und trotzdem weiter auf den Fein zuzulaufen. Und ich dachte mir irgendwie, Schusswaffen im Film zu zeigen, okay, daran haben wir uns gewöhnt. Aber jetzt plötzlich so ein Pseudoschutz vor Schusswaffen zu zeigen, passt nicht so richtig in die Zeit gerade.
Also du findest es pädagogisch problematisch.
Ja, und zwar hochproblematisch. Weil den Leuten plötzlich weisgemacht wird so…
Ich bin ja wie ein unpädagogisch denkender Kunstprinzipient.
Schusswaffen sind doch nicht so gefährlich. Also in deren Sicht fand ich diese John-Wick-Cook-Erfahrung so ein bisschen…
Ja, aber ich mein…
Vielleicht war ich auch ablenkt davon, dass mich der Film nicht überzeugt hat wie alle anderen.
Also der Film ist großartig und die Sache ist ja…
Er rollt die Treppen wieder runter.
Die meisten Filme leben ja davon, dass wir gerne Menschen zusehen, wie sie sich Gewalt antun. Ich glaube aber nicht an diesen Effekt.
Ich auch nicht.
Also wir sagen ja eigentlich, wir gehen ja in John Wick und Co. Und sind dann doch ganz unbewaffnet sonst unterwegs und finden das auch nicht toll, wenn Waffen in die Hand genommen werden.
Einmal mehr habe ich die Hoffnung, dass das Prinzip so gilt. Denn dieser Film, falls es doch anders ist, lässt Leute mit falschen Vorstellungen zurück, dass man sich vor Schusswaffen irgendwie schützen könnte und nicht einfach nur Flucht hilft. Aber gut, das steckt ja eh in John Wick und so weiter drin. Dass da ein bisschen über die Stränge geschlagen wird. Gut.
Wir wünschen einen schönen Monat. Wir lenken uns etwas aus, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen. Wir uns dann wieder streiten werden. Mal schauen. Angeregt diskutieren bestimmt. Und wir wünschen einen schönen Monat.
So ist es. Genießt die Sonne.